hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we're
going to learn data analytics with excel
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech gig in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn now without further ado
let's get started with the agenda for
today's session
first we will get started with the brief
introduction with excel followed by that
we will understand the fundamental
functions and formulas in excel later we
will understand the data validation in
excel conditional formatting then we
will dive into the pivot tables and
power query in excel followed by that we
will understand the dashboards in excel
where we will create the interactive
dashboards using excel followed by that
we will learn data analysis and
regression in excel and finally we will
wind up the session by discussing excel
macros and visual basics in excel
so i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now go to our training experts
hi everyone let's continue learning
excel so
we will learn about functions and
formulas we will learn about conditional
formatting data validation pivot chart
and pivot table
now let's look at a scenario here so
one day in a startup
one professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague response
well we can make use of microsoft excel
to do this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to
their business needs
now
the colleague responds well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question
says let's go ahead with excellent let's
train our employees in excel
and
the suggestion is welcomed which would
make the job easier for them
and they would basically
decide on using excel so they decide on
taking a training right away and
basically starting to learn excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use excel so
let's look at some of the points here
so excel proves to be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days
various features in excel like searching
sorting filtering makes it easier for
you to play with the data
and excel also allows you to beautify
your data and present it in the form of
charts tables and data bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
excel also provides good security for
your data excel files have the feature
of password protection
this way your information can be safe
now when we talk about what is excel and
how it can be used
so excel or you might have heard a
spreadsheet can be basically used for
a lot of different tasks than just
storing the information in so called
tabular format
now
microsoft excel is an application that
is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a
small tour to understand how to work
with excel now to do that what we can do
is we can
type in in our search say for example
excel and just select your excel app
which is installed and here you see you
have a lot of options which says take a
tour drop down list get started with
formulas make your pivot table
going forward with pie charts and much
more so we can click on this one which
says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to excel and
if you have always wanted to be better
at excel
you have this
which can help you so let's click on
create
and that takes us to the store window
now that says instructions for screen
readers which basically talks about 10
different steps in which we can learn
excel
and using the spreadsheet app
so there are more than 11 sheets
which we see here at the bottom end and
each one gives us a simple example which
we can work on
so for example if i click on add
now that takes me to this page which
says
how do we add numbers now you might be
provided data which we can
upload by loading a file from our
machine or getting data from a web
source or even connecting to a database
so there are various options which we
will see in some time so here we have an
option which is called data you can
click on this one and this basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from sql
server from analysis services
from odata data feed you can get in from
xml from data connection wizard or also
from microsoft query you can be running
in different queries here which shows up
in the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use
and that basically will display all the
connections
for this particular workbook which we
did not have as of now but we can create
them but let's look at simple examples
now you can follow these instructions
here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here
and what you could do is either you can
type in the formula that is
from which row to which row you would
want to add the data so for example i
could just do a sum here and that shows
up all the different functions which are
available then we can open up a
parenthesis and we can say i would be
interested in totaling the amount
from
column d and i would select for example
d4
so
i could be doing this and then i could
say d4
onwards till d7 so that's the data which
i'm interested in you can close your
parenthesis and hit enter and that gives
you the total
there is also a shortcut for this which
you can always do is we can first delete
this and you can just place your cursor
here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime
expand or basically collapse so i will
basically select this which says this
function needs two numbers which is
number one and number two and then you
can hit on enter and that gives you the
total
so similarly we can be getting in the
data
here by selecting all the fields
so here it also says that you can use a
shortcut now what we can also do is we
can add numbers over 50
by selecting the yellow cell here and
then giving a condition
such as so i can basically use something
like sum if
and then open a paranthesis i can select
i would be interested in this row and
then
i can even drag and drop
till here so that tells me d11 to be 15.
you can then put in a comma here and you
can give your condition say for example
we would say i would be interested
in numbers only above 50
and we can select this
close your quotes and then just close
your parenthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total is hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here i could select this now
there is also an option i can click on
home
and i can go for something like auto sum
so that's one more way of doing it which
anyway says
sum is alt plus equals so it
automatically adds up your values and i
can try doing a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then i can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
sum if formula here but add amounts that
are less than 100 and the result should
be 160. so what we can do is we can
basically
select all the numbers which are lesser
than 100 so the way we did earlier here
there can be always a shortcut so you
can always for example if you would want
to avoid typing in the formula you can
always copy it from here
and then
just hit on enter
so you are back into this cell and then
i can basically go here and paste
the number and then as per the
requirement we are required to select
anything which is lesser than 100 so
what i could do is i could select here i
could say let's say g
and then i can change this value to g15
and that's one more way now we see our
selected rows have been changed so i can
hit on enter and i can check what is the
result so we would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so i will have to also change
this one to
a lesser sign and that basically gives
me the total which is 160
so that's how you can simply add numbers
you can use autosum you can type in the
formula you can select the fields or you
can just place your cursor where you
would be looking for a sum and then you
can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at
some easy options of filling your cells
or automatically populating the values
in your
cells within your excel sheet now here
we have an option which says 100 now we
can click on this and that basically
says it is making a sum of
column c4 to d4 so if i click on this
one i can check that this is
row number 4
which shows up here
and i also know this is column c i also
have d so this equals is basically
giving me a sum of c4 to d4 now what we
can do is we can always
place our cursor here at the right
corner and then we can just drag and
drop and this basically gives me a total
of all the numbers for all different
rows
so this is one shortcut which we can do
to get the total excel will
automatically give the totals which we
call as filling down
now what we can do is in the same way if
we would want to get the totals here we
can first check what is this 200 and
this tells me it is c11 to c14 total so
it is totaling the rows from c11 so
column c and 11th row till 14th row and
that's the sum now what i can also do is
i can similarly like above we can do a
filling right which basically means
bringing your cursor here and then just
dragging and dropping it all the way
where you would need the totals and this
basically gives me the total there is
one more quick way to check if this is
right
so the easiest option would be
to select this cell now
what i can also do is i can just select
all of these fields by just highlighting
and selecting all the fields once it is
selected
press on ctrl r and that gives you the
total now if we would be doing this top
down then i could select all these
rows
for this particular column and then i
could do a control d so that's your
filling down and this one was filling
right so this is an easier option of
doing a fill
when you would want to have the formula
applied to every row as it occurs in the
first row or the last row
we could test this by for example
selecting these fields i could delete
them and i have here which says 130 i
could just place my cursor here and i
could drag it all the way up and that
should also do the same magic which we
were seeing from top down so this is a
simple way wherein you can fill up your
cells and you can also automatically
propagate
or move your computation to all the
cells
let's
look at the split option which basically
helps us in splitting the data when we
have some kind of pattern or when we
have some kind of delimiters in our data
in say one particular column and we
would want to derive the values out of
it so we can always use the splitting
option now the easiest option would be
so for example we have our email column
which has the email ids and which we can
clearly see has a first name dot last
name now i see that there is a last name
smith filled up here first name is empty
so what i can also do is i can just type
in say
nancy here
now that's the first name i can again
start typing the second name and as soon
as you do that you would see a faded
list of numbers and that's your clue to
hit enter and once you do that you would
see all the first names have been filled
in here if you would want to maintain
the case sensitiveness you can just go
ahead and delete these and let's type in
as it occurs so let's say nancy as the
first name go down to the next cell and
just type in andy and there is your
grade list so just hit on enter and that
basically fills up your first name
what we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now i can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking control z
and that's basically gone
what i can also do is i can select a
particular field and then i can go into
home option and under home
you should have an option here which
says fill so you can select this and
then you can do a flash fill which is
what we are doing here so click on flash
fill and that automatically fills up the
values so in this way you can work
within your spreadsheet and you can be
filling up the values where a delimiter
by default is understood and we can
split the data now however sometimes you
might have some data which has a
different kind of delimiter and there is
again a smarter way of splitting your
data
so you can always scroll down here and
that says splitting a column based on
delimiters so we have some values in the
data column and
these values in each row are separated
by comma so
select this
your data is already selected text to
columns delimited
comma is selected and now click on next
so it basically says
what is the destination let's select
this one
and i can choose
what would you want to have so that
shows me this would be my data preview
now i can basically select this one
i can say finish
and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in
in the columns appropriately so this is
how you can split your data based on a
delimiter and then organize your data in
a better way now there are some advanced
options which we can learn later but
this basically tells about using a
formula so this is something if say if
we have some name in one cell and if you
would want to split it into first name
your helper column
your middle name last name so that can
also be done using formulas and this
basically tells how would you extract
characters from your left
cell and how would you place them in
your right cell so you can try this
activity which is a little more of
advanced option the benefit is that
you can always use this
wherein if you
do some kind of transformation using
your formulas if your original data gets
updated then the split data will also
get updated and that's the benefit of
using formulas where you can place
values from one cell into multiple cells
based on execution of your details in
the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your x and y axis or as i would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become
your rows so what we can do is the
simplest way is you can
select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and i would say two rows now i
can select all of these and then i can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt v that's a
shortcut what you can also do is
once you have selected all your fields
you can just copy them so just do a
control c
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home you have the paste option and here
you can go for paste special and once
you do that you need to select the
transpose option over here and click on
ok
and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as amount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed
in this particular format now there is
another way of doing that and again
that's using your formulas so what you
can do is you can transpose with a
formula also and that basically
works
when you have similar kind of data so
this has six columns
and basically two rows so you can
basically do this so you can
select this and earlier we were doing a
copy but now what we would want to do is
we would want to just look at the row
numbers which tells me it is c 33 c 34
and it starts with c and ends in with
your h column so what we can do is we
know that we have six columns and two
rows so transposing that would actually
give me two columns and six rows so what
we can do is we can select
two columns and six rows in our excel
sheet i can then basically start typing
in the message or i can just go to the
address bar and here
i can say
transpose
let's go for c33 h34 it basically
selects my data
and now i can just do a
control shift and enter and now if you
see all the values have been populated
now you can just place your cursor in
one of the cells but if you see the
address bar the formula remains the same
this is because this is an array formula
so we can read more about an array
formula here it's basically something
which performs calculations and on more
than one cell in an array and in the
example here the array is the original
data that is c33 to h34 so your
transpose is just changing
the horizontal orientation to the
vertical orientation so this is a very
simple way in which you can basically
use the excel's capability to transpose
your data and convert your rows into
columns and columns into rows apart from
working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data
sorting
the data or basically splitting your
data
transposing your data one of the other
requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data and you would want to sort it
in a particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so
let's check that so if we're going to
sort and filter and say this is the data
i have say for example i would want to
sort the values in the department column
alphabetically so what i can do is i can
select department column and i'm already
in the home tab i can straight away go
here which says sort and filter i can
then say sort a to z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column
and once once i do this you would see
the data has been sorted but it's not
just this data we can just do a control
z and check what are the values we have
so here we have meat which is beef and
ninety thousand
hundred ten thousand the values
then you have bakery which should
ideally be the first
row if we sort it in alphabetical order
which goes with bakery as desserts you
have the values so we can check this
again so select department and then just
do a sort and filter and let's say sort
a to z
and if you see the data has changed but
it's not just in changing your first
column but then it has taken care of all
the data however the data has been
sorted based on the department column so
you have bakery which aligns with
deserts which has the values and now we
have all the data which has been
filtered now what we can also do is we
can sort december's amounts from largest
to smallest so what we can do is we can
basically click any cell in the december
column let's say 20 000
and then what i can do is i can go into
sort
filter and then i can say sort largest
to smallest so if you see bakery breads
is the row which has the smallest data
or might be you have delhi sandwiches so
that one looks also smaller so let's do
a
larger to smallest and if i do this you
would see the values have been shifted
now so it is no more based on the
department column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values in the december
column and you see bakery which was
alphabetically the first one has become
second last
so either you can sort the data based on
a department column which goes
based on the values these are all string
values or words so it sorts
alphabetically if you have numbers might
be you can give some values and you can
sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select
if you would want to select the data so
i could do a custom sort and then i
could choose which is the column which
we would want to use for sorting what is
the sorting needs to be done
is it cell values is its cell color font
color conditional formatting and then
you can also choose the order so that's
one more way to do that
now if you scroll down that also shows
how you can sort by date or a color so
for example if you would want to sort
based on the expense date so there are
different options so what i can do is i
can select this date field i can just do
a right click i can go into sort and
then i can choose i would want to sort
oldest to newest so since i selected the
date field it basically has sorted all
the data
and it has taken the expense date into
consideration now there are these
filters which you see on the row
headings we could have also used those
so i could have selected this and that
basically says or mentions which are the
dates i would be interested in looking
at
i also have sort by color here i can do
a sort oldest to newest or newest to
oldest so i could also use these filters
which have been applied here now we have
the data which is in color so if i would
want to basically select
the color columns or color cells i could
select this
i can basically do a right click here
and when i go into sort i could choose
put selected color or cell color on the
top
and that basically will make sure that
my data is sorted and it has also sorted
that in a descending order so in this
way you can sort or basically filter
your data what we can also do is we can
add filters so sometimes we can go for
formulas which we would want to use what
we can also do is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here now how does the
filter come in there so if i would
select a particular row i could select a
particular row and then i could decide
if i would want to just add a filter to
this one and that's how the filter has
come in so we have the filter what we
can do is we can basically click on this
drop down
and then you have something like number
filters so we can always go here
we can basically choose one of these so
we can basically choose above average so
i could select this and then basically
it shows me the values we could also
delete the filter by clicking on this
one and we could say well i'm not
interested in this filter anymore so i
could clear the filter and that shows me
all the values
or i could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food i can go in here i can go
into number filters and then i could say
well i'm interested in
values which are below average above
average might be greater than and then i
can choose what is the value so for
example if we say i'm interested in food
which is
greater than 25 dollars i could give a
value here i could say ok
and now i have applied the filter
similarly you can select this and then
you can just clear your filter and your
data is back
so remember
no data is lost
it is just
hidden or basically based on the filter
not shown
so that's good enough for us and in this
way you can sort and filter the data so
for more details obviously in all the
sheets you have the links which point to
more information on the web and you can
always refer to these so this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data which has been stored
within your excel within a particular
sheet now that we have learned about add
fill split transpose sorting and
filtering it will also be good to learn
how to work with tables or basically
converting your data into a tabular
format and then doing some easy
computations so click on this tables
option here now here we see there is
some data which is in
five columns and n number of rows so i
can basically select this data and then
what i can do is i can insert
choose the table option and then it says
my table as headers and we'll be okay
with that i'll say okay and now if you
see this is the table created it
basically has different filters which we
have learnt earlier how to use and this
is basically my table which is a
collection of cells which has some
special features so we can easily add
rows to this table we can add columns to
this table and we can even do some
calculations so for example here i can
click on this one i can
basically enter
some field
and then i can hit on enter and we see
that this row has been inserted wherein
we can easily fill in values for example
i would say chocolates
i could give some value here size 25 000
might be 35 000
and then
basically i can given some values here
now what you can also do is you can
continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this option
here in the top bottom right corner you
can just drag it towards the right and
that basically has automatically created
columns for my next months
wherein i can feed in the data so this
is a simpler way wherein you can keep
adding more rows and columns to your
data if that has been converted in a
tabular format
now let me just do a ctrl z that
basically deletes the columns again
control z deletes the last row which we
added and i can stop here or i can even
remove my values by doing multiple
control z and removing my rows so this
is how i converted my data into a table
and then i can easily work on this what
i can also do is i can do some
calculations so what we can do
we have a table here we have a total
field and what we can do is we can just
select one cell here now as we have
learned earlier we can do a alt and then
equals
and that basically says what is this
doing so it says it is calculating the
sum of
the last three months and if that's what
you would want to do just hit on enter
and it has automatically calculated
the totals for
all your rows for these three columns
so the sum formula is getting filled up
now i can select any particular cell and
i can look in my address bar so it has
already given me the formula where it
has started
calculating the sum from the october
column till the december column and has
given me the calculated values of the
columns what we can also do is we can
get total rows in the table now that's a
simpler option so what we can do is we
can select any cell in this particular
table
and then
we see that there is a table tools
design option showing up here now i can
select this and then it says
well let's get a total row so let's
select this and it automatically
populates the total here
and if you would want the average then
we could select this and from the drop
down i can select what i'm interested in
so for example i would want the average
values and not the total i could just
select this and that gives me the
average of these values
so we can always do simpler computations
here
by converting our data into table format
let's learn about one more efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here
now
say for example you have this data which
has the values in the food column and
department is empty and say for example
you would want to
enter the values and department however
you would want to select
the department should either have
produce or meat and bakery and these are
the only three options which should be
available for any user to fill in the
values how do we do that so we can
basically create a table by pressing
ctrl d so what i can do is under my
department
here i can select one of the cells and
then i can do a control t that basically
converts this into a table i can say ok
and my table is created now what i can
do is once this part is done
we can
select all the blank fields here where
we would want this drop down to be
applicable
now under your data tab you can go in
and select data validation
and this has an option called data
validation click on this
which basically says allow any value so
here i will select i would want to give
a list of values and then i can type in
my values here which i can say produce
say for example meet and then say
bakery now these are the values
so we can click on ok
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so i can go into every cell and
then i can basically choose
what is the department which handles
this
and then basically i can select one of
these from the drop down so this is an
easier option of creating your drop down
and then feeding in the values from the
set of values which you have defined
here on the right
so this is a simple example of using
your drop downs
working with your tables working with
your sort and filter transpose split
filling up your data adding in some data
here and similarly you can use excel for
more than
one use case using its inbuilt features
to easily work with your data
let's see how we can import data or
bring in data into our excel from
your local machine or from an external
web source
so
what we can do is we can open up a blank
excel sheet and say for example you have
been provided a text file or a csv file
and you would want to import that data
into your excel sheet that can be easily
done
so right now i've opened an
excel sheet now i can click on data and
here i have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources
so or you can click on connections if
you have already created some so we can
click on from other sources
so this is one option where you can
connect to your different data sources
and you can get the data from
one of these what we can also do is i
can click on connections now it says
there is none i can click on add it says
well show the connections where
connection files on network
connection files on this computer so i
can say let's get some files from this
computer
now if that does not show up something
so say browse for more and that
basically shows you different options so
let's basically select a folder where i
have
some data sets i'll click in here
and this is basically a folder where i
have some data sets now let me select
this particular file and i know it is a
csv file
so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a dot csv file which is what we
are interested in so i'll take this file
i'll say open now this basically shows
me
the text import wizard option which says
is the file delimited i'll say yes
click on next so i will select comma as
my delimiter i can say text qualifier is
none
now this is my data so my data preview
is already showing me the data is
what is the data in the csv file
you can click on next and then you have
an option which says data format is
general you can go for date format you
can go for advanced options so i'll just
say finish
and basically now this has been created
here
so we basically have this and now i can
click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data which we have here the
connection which we have created say
open
and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on ok
and now this data is automatically
inserted in my excel file i can
basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what i
can do is i can go into my github
and let's say i would be interested in
this csv file so i can select this
and this is my github path a path on web
so i can click on draw and that
basically gives me
the raw path where this particular file
is now you can select this
copy this particular path
and here you can come back to your excel
sheet we would be interested in getting
the data from web might be from a text
file where we will have to specify the
delimiters or let's go to web
and here
i can given the web path from where i
would be interested in getting the file
let's give the github path which is
publicly available and then click on
import now once you click on import it
tells me there are two fields data and
value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on ok
and now you have the data coming in but
then this basically shows me in one
particular field so what we can also do
is we can just do a control a that
selects all my columns here
and that's my data so we can then
basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next
we can select comma and
let the text qualifier be quotes
it shows me data
preview click on next
so you have the general format it shows
the destination that's the column
click on finish and now your data has
been split and you have the data which
you have imported from web so this is
the data which is coming in from web
this is the data which came in from my
local machine and similarly we can even
create connection with an existing
database so i can basically click on
connections if i would want to do that
so i have an option called connection
here
and it says where the selected
connections are used
i can basically click on add
i can basically choose
if i would want to get the files from
network or from computer like we did
earlier
i can click on browse for more which
should
show me different other options to
create connections say you would want to
create a new sql server connection you
can connect to a new data source coming
in from different place you could
basically choose what kind of connection
you would you want so these are all the
different options which we can go for
and we can basically connect to a
database for example
if i have some database
and say for example access database
i can see if there are some files with
that particular database and i can
import it
so similarly we can also
click in here which says new query and
that also gives you an option of getting
the data from your files from all these
folders
from databases so you can basically
click here and then you can import data
from a mysql database provided that is
set up on your local machine or on a
particular server you can go from cloud
you can get it from online services
you can get it from other sources which
says from web
from your hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor
you can get the data from different
sources and then you can bring it into
your excel so in this way you can get
your data from different sources into
your excel into your spreadsheet and
then you can continue working on those
data sets
we have
already learned some basic operations
which you can do in excel and let's
implement our knowledge by working on
this particular data which is coming in
from housing data set
now here if we see some fields we have
agent
date listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been
sorted in newest to oldest order of date
listed
so how do we
arrive at this so what i can do is i can
just click on data listed and then
i can either
go in here
i can select sort i can get into custom
sort
and then i can choose the column
based on which i would want to sort the
data so i would look for the newest data
to the oldest data that means that would
be in a descending order of dates or you
could say the oldest date
or the earliest month will be towards
the lower side of your sheet so here we
can select date listed now i can say let
it sort
based on cell values and the order what
we have here so we have newest to oldest
so let's select this i can say okay and
now if you see the date has been sorted
so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see
an earlier month hour and
earlier month than that in this date
listed so we have sorted our data
into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your
date column so the result shows up here
now what we can also do is we can have
different questions which we would want
to answer so for example i would want to
sort the data in ascending order of area
and descending order of agent name how
do we do that so let's look into this so
this is here i already have the result
here and how did i get this so i'm
looking for ascending order of area in
descending order of agent name so we can
start with any particular column that
does not matter so for example if i look
into this excel sheet i have my agent
name select this which we want in a
descending order so we could either do a
sort and then go for
descending sort z to a we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it
or i could just say sort z to a and then
it
has arranged the data
based on the agent column being in
descending order now i can go into area
and then i can again do a sort and i
wanted my area column
to be used for
sorting the data ascending to descending
and that basically not only changes the
order of this particular column but for
my complete data so let's do that
and now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so
we can see how many values we have here
and the area values which we see and
this is how you get your result so i'll
just do a ctrl z
and
again and i'm back to my original data
and this is the sorted result which we
are seeing at
similarly we can answer other questions
for example sort the data according to
the following order
of area
that is we are saying county
central
and then your county so we can basically
choose
in which particular way we would want to
do it so it is county central and then
again county so if i look into my sheet
3 so here
i basically have my data which is
having some south county then you have
your central and then you have your
north county so we would want to
sort the data to solve our problem which
is
according to the following order so
first we go for area then we go for
south county central and north county so
what we can do is we can basically
have area field selected
and i would want to sort this particular
data so i have south county central and
north county so i can basically go for
custom sort
and then i can choose which is the value
or column which i'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like
cell values well you can also try to
explore conditional formatting icon
if this is what you would want to use or
we can basically go for just sell values
and here we can say
if i would be interested in first
getting my values for
south county so for example i can say
custom list
and then i can basically given the new
list here so i can say s
dot
county
and then i would want central
and then i would want north county
so let's select this
as it exists
we can
basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay
and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with kelly you have in the 12th
row something like lang and that's what
we are doing so we can basically arrange
the data in a particular order by
choosing a custom list and then sorting
your data
so that's one more simpler task what we
have done
where we have sorted the data in the
order where
under our area column we first wanted
south county
then we wanted central data and then we
wanted north county so this is how you
can do it
now
let's look into one more problem so it
says find all the houses in the central
area
and we would want to basically apply a
regular filter let's let's see how do we
do that so we can click on this and here
we have the data so the problem
statement is we would want to find all
the houses in central
area now how do we do that we can do a
sorting but
we would want to use the filter which
you see here
is implemented so how do you do it so
you can select this area
and say for example i would want to
apply filter i can just go in here and i
can say let's get a filter on my first
row and now i have filters applied so we
are interested in looking into the
central area houses let's go in here it
says
all these fields are selected that means
it shows everything
wherein your area has all these values
let's unselect this and then i will only
be interested in the central so let's
say okay
and then say okay so now you see that
the area
filter has been applied and we are
looking at the central column so what we
have done is we have applied a simple
filter and we are looking at our data at
any point of time if you do not
want
the filter
then
what i can do is i can select this and i
can say well i'm interested in all the
data
so i could do this or you can clear the
filters from area
and you get your data back
so
that's in one way you can filter out
your data so let's look at an example of
sort and filter where we might have to
filter the data based on two columns
or multiple columns with different kind
of values where it could be and and or
condition now say for example this is
the data i have and this is the question
which we need to answer such as find the
list of all houses
in the central region with pool
and south county without pool now if it
was a simple filter based on one cell i
could have
just selected my
header row i could have then applied the
filter
and once i have the filter i can look in
area where i have three regions so i'm
only interested in central and south
county so i can get rid of north county
and that's fine but then
we have two different conditions here so
we need
the
data in central region to have
the value for pool being true
and for south county the value has to be
without pool now how do we
do that so what we can do is we can
first create a copy of these headers
here
so let me do that
now the area has to be
south county so basically i can
either
just select this and i can choose this
value
and then i can select this and then i
can choose central so that's the
criteria which i have
and the pool value has to be
so
central region should be with pool so
then this one
basically has to be true
and
this one has to be basically false so
south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now
to get my result uh we can always place
your cursor here and you can check this
is m column and eighth row
okay so we would want the result here so
let's go ahead and now click on data
and then in filter you have an option
called advanced and here what i can do
is i can say i would want to filter the
list in the place but that's not what i
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location and here if you see the
list range will tell me that this is the
data so a1 to j126 so a to j column
selected and all the rows
criteria range is basically based on
what i've given here so that is m
from 1
to v
which is 3
so i am selecting these columns and then
i am saying all the way whatever
criteria i have given and copy 2
i i'm saying m8
to v8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say okay
and now i have my data which has been
filtered and i have my area which is
south county
that is without pool central with pool
again south county without pool
and then if you look at your central
value that's pool so this is an advanced
filter which we have applied where
simply we have filtered the data based
on two columns and then we have our
result so in this way you can have your
customized filter applied on two
different columns and get your data
which can be either
replacing the existing content or
in the same sheet in different set of
columns and rows you can have your
result let's look at one more example of
filtering where you are trying to filter
the data based on an and condition
condition being met in two different
columns and then you would want to
filter out the data for only specific
columns so the situation is the agents
with a house in north county that should
be county
area having two
and a single type family so we are
talking about two bedrooms
and
we would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that we
would want to
only populate these columns which is
agent area bedroom and type now what you
can do is as i explained earlier that
you can get your result in
the same sheet in a different location
so here i have created these headers
which says agent area bedrooms and type
now this is basically a copy of all the
columns what we have here agent data
listed area list price bedrooms bath
square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here and this is where we will give our
advanced criteria to filter the data
so the conditions which need to be met
is we need to look at north county
so for example here in area i can
basically go ahead and select one of the
values north county
now the criteria is having two bedrooms
only so let's say
bedrooms and let's say the value should
be 2
and then basically i am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type i
can give the criteria
single type
so
this is my and condition so we are
saying north county area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if i select this this one tells me
that this is m
one row onwards till v
two
so this is what we have
and we would want to filter based on
this so let's go ahead and then go for
data filter advanced
and here in advanced it says filter the
list in place now that's not what we
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location
this basically selects the list range
so which is telling me
a1
to j126
so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on m1 v2 which we have given
here and copy 2 i would say for example
from
m7
to
p7 now this is the area where i would
this is the place where i want the
result let's say okay and now i get my
data which is
based on the question which has been
hello everyone welcome to this live
session on data analysis with excel by
simply learn
in today's session we will learn about
microsoft excel and how it can be used
to perform data analysis
our instructors with good industry
experience will help you learn
everything from scratch
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
so we will start by understanding the
basics of microsoft excel followed by
learning the top excel functions and
formulas
we will then see how to validate and
format data in excel moving further we
will learn two important features of
excel that help in analysis of data so
we look at pivot tables and power query
we'll get an idea about using the data
analysis tool pack for performing
statistical analysis such as descriptive
statistics regression analysis and
sampling
finally we'll focus on automating tasks
in excel using macros and vba so let's
get started
hi everyone let's continue learning
excel so
we will learn about functions and
formulas we will learn about conditional
formatting data validation pivot chart
and pivot table
now let's look at a scenario here so one
day in a startup
one professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague responds
well we can make use of microsoft excel
to do this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to
their business needs
now
the colleague responds well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question
says let's go ahead with excellent let's
train our employees in excel
and
the suggestion is welcomed which would
make the job easier for them
and they would basically
decide on using excel so they decide on
taking a training right away and
basically starting to learn excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so excel proves to be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days
various features in excel like searching
sorting filtering makes it easier for
you to play with the data
and excel also allows you to beautify
your data and present it in the form of
charts tables and data bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
excel also provides good security for
your data excel files have the feature
of password protection
this way your information can be safe
now when we talk about what is excel and
how it can be used
so excel or you might have heard a
spreadsheet can be basically used for
a lot of different tasks than just
storing the information in so called
tabular format
now
microsoft excel is an application that
is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a
small tour to understand how to work
with excel now to do that what we can do
is we can type in in our search say for
example excel and just select your excel
app which is installed and here you see
you have a lot of options which says
take a tour drop down list get started
with formulas make your pivot table
going forward with pie charts and much
more so we can click on this one which
says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to excel and
if you have always wanted to be better
at excel
you have this
which can help you so let's click on
create and that takes us to the store
window now that says instructions for
screen readers which basically talks
about 10 different steps in which we can
learn excel
and using the spreadsheet app
so there are more than 11 sheets
which we see here at the bottom end and
each one gives us a simple example which
we can work on
so for example if i click on add
now that takes me to this page which
says
how do we add numbers now
you might be provided data which we can
upload by loading a file from our
machine or getting data from a web
source or even connecting to a database
so there are various options which we
will see in some time so here we have an
option which is called data you can
click on this one and this basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from sql
server from analysis services
from odata data feed you can get in from
xml from data connection wizard or also
from microsoft query you can be running
in different queries here which shows up
in the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use
and that basically will display all the
connections
for this particular workbook which we
did not have as of now but we can create
them but let's look at simple examples
now you can follow these instructions
here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here
and what you could do is either you can
type in the formula that is
from which row to which row you would
want to add the data so for example i
could just do a sum here and that shows
up all the different functions which are
available then we can open up a
parenthesis and we can say
i would be interested in totaling the
amount
from
column d and i would select for example
d4
so
i could be doing this and then i could
say d4
onwards till d7 so that's the data which
i'm interested in you can close your
parenthesis and hit enter and that gives
you the total
there is also a shortcut for this which
you can always do is we can first delete
this and you can just place your cursor
here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime
expand or basically collapse so i will
basically select this which says this
function needs two numbers which is
number one and number two and then you
can hit on enter and that gives you the
total
so similarly we can be getting in the
data
here by selecting all the fields so here
it also says that you can use a shortcut
now what we can also do is we can add
numbers over 50
by selecting the yellow cell here and
then giving a condition
such as so i can basically use something
like sum if
and then open a parenthesis i can select
i would be interested in this row and
then i can even drag and drop
till here so that tells me d11 to d15
you can then put in a comma here and you
can give your condition say for example
we would say i would be interested in
numbers only above 50 and we can select
this
close your quotes and then just close
your parenthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total is hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here i could select this now
there is also an option i can click on
home and i can go for something like
auto sum so that's one more way of doing
it which anyway says sum is alt plus
equals so it automatically adds up your
values and i can try doing a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then i can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
sum if formula here but add amounts that
are less than 100 and the result should
be 160. so what we can do is we can
basically
select all the numbers which are lesser
than 100 so the way we did earlier here
there can be always a shortcut so you
can always for example if you would want
to avoid typing in the formula you can
always copy it from here
and then
just hit on enter so you are back into
this cell and then i can basically go
here and paste the number and then as
per the requirement we are required to
select anything which is lesser than 100
so what i could do is i could select
here i could say let's say g
and then i can change this value to g15
and that's one more way now we see our
selected rows have been changed so i can
hit on enter and i can check what is the
result so we would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so i will have to also change
this one to
a lesser sign and that basically gives
me the total which is
160. so that's how you can simply add
numbers you can use autosum you can type
in the formula
you can select the fields
or you can just place your cursor where
you would be looking for a sum and then
you can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at
some easy options of filling your cells
or automatically populating the values
in your
cells within your excel sheet now here
we have an option with says 100 now we
can click on this and that basically
says it is making a sum of
column c4 to d4 so if i click on this
one i can check that this is
row number four
which shows up here
and i also know this is column c i also
have d so this equals is basically
giving me a sum of c4 to d4 now what we
can do is we can always place our cursor
here at the right corner and then we can
just drag and drop and this basically
gives me a total of all the numbers for
all different rows
so this is one shortcut which we can do
to get the total excel will
automatically give the totals which we
call as filling down
now what we can do is in the same way if
we would want to get the totals here we
can first check what is this 200 and
this tells me it is c11 to see 14 total
so it is totaling the rows from c11 so
column c and 11th row till 14th row and
that's the sum now what i can also do is
i can similarly like above we can do a
filling right which basically means
bringing your cursor here and then just
dragging and dropping it all the way
where you would need the totals and this
basically gives me the total there is
one more quick way to check if this is
right
so the easiest option would be to select
this cell now what i can also do is i
can just select all of these fields by
just highlighting and selecting all the
fields once it is selected
press on control r
and that gives you the total now if we
would be doing this top down then i
could select all these
rows
for this particular column and then i
could do a ctrl d so that's your
filling down and this one was filling
right so this is an easier option of
doing a fill
when you would want to have the formula
applied to every row as it occurs in the
first row or the last row we could test
this by for example selecting these
fields i could delete them and i have
here which says 130 i could just place
my cursor here and i could drag it all
the way up
and that should also do the same magic
which we were seeing from top down so
this is a simple way wherein you can
fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate
or move your computation to all the
cells
let's look at the split option which
basically helps us in splitting the data
when we have some kind of pattern or
when we have some kind of delimiters in
our data in say one particular column
and we would want to derive the values
out of it so we can always use the
splitting option now the easiest option
would be so for example we have our
email column which has the email ids in
which we can clearly see has a first
name dot last name now i see that there
is a last name smith filled up here
first name is empty so what i can also
do is i can just type in say
nancy here now that's the first name i
can again start typing the second name
and as soon as you do that you would see
a faded list of numbers and that's your
clue to hit enter and once you do that
you would see all the first names have
been filled in here if you would want to
maintain the case sensitiveness you can
just go ahead and delete these and let's
type in as it occurs so let's say nancy
as the first name go down to the next
cell and just type in andy and there is
your grade list so just hit on enter and
that basically fills up your first name
what we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now i can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking ctrl z and that's basically
gone
what i can also do is i can select a
particular field and then i can go into
home option and under home
you should have an option here which
says fill so you can select this and
then you can do a flash fill which is
what we are doing here so click on flash
fill and that automatically fills up the
values so in this way you can work
within your spreadsheet and you can be
filling up the values where a delimiter
by default is understood and we can
split the data now however sometimes you
might have some data which has a
different kind of delimiter and there is
again a smarter way of splitting your
data so you can always scroll down here
and that says splitting a column based
on delimiters so we have some values in
the data column and
these values in each row are separated
by comma so
select this
your data is already selected text to
columns delimited
comma is selected
and now click on next
so it basically says
what is the destination let's select
this one
and i can choose
what would you want to have so that
shows me this would be my data preview
now i can basically select this one
i can say finish
and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in
in the columns appropriately so this is
how you can split your data based on a
delimiter and then organize your data in
a better way now there are some advanced
options which we can learn later but
this basically tells about using a
formula so this is something if say if
we have some name in one cell and if you
would want to split it into first name
your helper column
your middle name last name so that can
also be done using formulas and this
basically tells how would you extract
characters
from your left cell and how would you
place them in your right cell so you can
try this activity which is a little more
of advanced option the benefit is that
you can always use this
wherein if you
do some kind of transformation using
your formulas if your original data gets
updated then the split data will also
get updated and that's the benefit of
using formulas where you can place
values from one cell into multiple cells
based on execution of your details in
the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your x and y axis or as i would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become your rows
so what we can do is the simplest way is
you can
select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and i would say two rows now i
can select all of these and then i can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt v that's a
shortcut what you can also do is
once you have selected all your fields
you can just copy them so just do a ctrl
c
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home you have the paste option and here
you can go for paste special
and once you do that you need to select
the transpose option over here and click
on ok
and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as amount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed
in
this particular format now there is
another way of doing that and again
that's using your formulas so what you
can do is you can transpose with a
formula also and that basically
works
when you have similar kind of data so
this has six columns
and basically two rows so you can
basically do this so you can
select this and earlier we were doing a
copy but now what we would want to do is
we would want to just look at the row
numbers which tells me it is c 33 c 34
and it starts with c and ends in with
your h column so what we can do is we
know that we have six columns and two
rows so transposing that would actually
give me two columns and six rows so what
we can do is we can select
two columns
and six rows in our excel sheet i can
then basically start typing in the
message or i can just go to the address
bar and here
i can say
transpose
let's go for c33 h34 it basically
selects my data and now i can just do a
control shift and enter and now if you
see all the values have been populated
now you can just place your cursor in
one of the cells but if you see the
address bar the formula remains the same
this is because this is an array formula
so we can read more about an array
formula here it's basically something
which performs calculations and on more
than one cell in an array
and in the example here the array is the
original data that is c33 to h34 so your
transpose is just changing
the horizontal orientation to the
vertical orientation so this is a very
simple way in which you can basically
use the excel's capability to transpose
your data and convert your rows into
columns and columns into rows
apart from
working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data
sorting
the data or basically splitting your
data
transposing your data one of the other
requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data and you would want to sort it
in a particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so
let's check that so if we go into sort
and filter and say this is the data i
have say for example i would want to
sort the values in the department column
alphabetically so what i can do is i can
select department column and i'm already
in the home tab i can straight away go
here which says sort and filter i can
then say sort a to z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column
and once once i do this you would see
the data has been sorted but it's not
just this data we can just do a ctrl z
and check what are the values we have so
here we have meat which is beef and
ninety thousand
hundred ten thousand the values
then you have bakery which should
ideally be the first
row if we sort it in alphabetical order
which goes with bakery as desserts you
have the values so we can check this
again so select department and then just
do a sort and filter and let's say sort
a to z and if you see the data has
changed but it's not just in changing
your first column but then it has taken
care of all the data however the data
has been sorted based on the department
column so you have bakery
which aligns with deserts which has the
values and now we have all the data
which has been filtered now what we can
also do is we can sort december's
amounts from largest to smallest so what
we can do is we can basically click any
cell in the december column let's say 20
000
and then what i can do is i can go into
sort
filter and then i can say sort largest
to smallest so if you see bakery breads
is the row which has the smallest data
or might be you have delhi sandwiches so
that one looks also smaller so let's do
a
larger to smallest and if i do this you
would see the values have been shifted
now so it is no more based on the
department column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values in the december
column and you see bakery which was
alphabetically the first one has become
second last
so either you can sort the data based on
a department column which goes
based on the values these are all string
values or words so it sorts
alphabetically if you have numbers might
be you can give some values and you can
sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select
if you would want to select the data so
i could do a custom sort and then i
could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the sorting
needs to be done
is it cell values is itself color font
color conditional formatting and then
you can also choose the order so that's
one more way to do that
now if you scroll down that also shows
how you can sort by date
or a color so for example if you would
want to sort
based on the expense date so there are
different options so what i can do is i
can select this date field i can just do
a right click
i can go into sort and then i can choose
i would want to sort oldest to newest so
since i selected the date field
it basically has sorted all the data
and it has taken the expense state into
consideration now there are these
filters which you see on the row
headings we could have also used those
so i could have selected this and that
basically says or mentions which are the
dates i would be interested in looking
at
i also have sort by color here
i can do a sort oldest to newest or
newest to oldest so i could also use
these filters which have been applied
here now we have the data which is in
color so if i would want to basically
select
the color columns or color cells i could
select this i can basically do a right
click here and when i go into sort i
could choose
put selected color or cell color on the
top
and that basically will make sure that
my data is sorted and it has also sorted
that in a descending order so in this
way you can sort or basically filter
your data
what we can also do is we can add
filters so sometimes we can go for
formulas which we would want to use what
we can also do is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here now how does the
filter come in there so if i would
select a particular row
i could select a particular row and then
i could decide if i would want to just
add a filter to this one and that's how
the filter has come in so we have the
filter what we can do is we can
basically click on this drop down
and then you have something like number
filters so we can always go here we can
basically choose one of these so we can
basically choose above average so i
could select this and then basically it
shows me the values we could also delete
the filter by clicking on this one and
we could say well i'm not interested in
this filter anymore so i could clear the
filter and that shows me all the values
or i could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food i can go in here i can go
into number filters and then i could say
well i'm interested in
values which are below average above
average might be greater than and then i
can choose what is the value so for
example if we say i'm interested in food
which is
greater than 25 dollars i could give a
value here i could say ok
and now i have applied the filter
similarly you can select this and then
you can just clear your filter and your
data is back
so remember no data is lost
it is just hidden or basically based on
the filter not shown
so that's good enough for us and in this
way you can sort and filter the data so
for more details obviously in all the
sheets you have the links which point to
more information on the web and you can
always refer to these so this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data which has been stored
within your excel within a particular
sheet now that we have learned about add
fill split transpose sorting and
filtering it will also be good to learn
how to work with tables or basically
converting your data into a tabular
format and then doing some easy
computations so click on this tables
option here now here we see there is
some data which is in
five columns and n number of rows so i
can basically select this data and then
what i can do is i can insert
choose the table option
and then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that i'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learnt earlier how
to use and this is basically my table
which is a collection of cells which has
some special features
so we can easily add rows to this table
we can add columns to this table and we
can even do some calculations so for
example here i can click on this one i
can
basically enter some field and then i
can hit on enter and we see that this
row has been inserted wherein we can
easily fill in values for example i
would say chocolates
i could give some value here size 25 000
might be 35 000
and then
basically i can given some values here
now what you can also do is you can
continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this
option here in the top bottom right
corner you can just drag it towards the
right and that basically has
automatically created
columns for my next month
wherein i can feed in the data so this
is a simpler way wherein you can keep
adding more rows and columns to your
data if that has been converted in a
tabular format now let me just do a ctrl
z that basically deletes the columns
again ctrl z deletes the last row which
we added and i can stop here or i can
even remove my values by doing multiple
control z
and removing my rows so this is how
i converted my data into a table and
then i can easily work on this what i
can also do is i can do some
calculations so what we can do
we have a table here we have a total
field and what we can do is we can just
select one cell here now as we have
learned earlier we can do a alt and then
equals
and that basically says what
is this doing so it says it is
calculating the sum of
the last three months and if that's what
you would want to do just hit on enter
and it has automatically calculated
the totals for
all your rows for these three columns
so the sum formula is getting filled up
now i can select any particular cell and
i can look in my address bar so it has
already given me the formula where it
has started
calculating the sum from the october
column
till the december column and has given
me the calculated values of the columns
what we can also do is we can get total
rows in the table now that's a simpler
option so what we can do is we can
select any cell in this particular table
and then we see that there is a table
tools design option showing up here now
i can select this and then it says well
let's get a total row so let's select
this and it automatically populates the
total here
and if you would want the average then
we could select this and from the drop
down i can select what i'm interested in
so for example i would want the average
values and not the total i could just
select this and that gives me the
average of these values
so we can always do simpler computations
here
by converting our data into table format
let's learn about one more efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here
now
say for example you have this data which
has the values in the food column and
department is empty and say for example
you would want to
enter the values in department however
you would want to select
the department should either have
produce or meat and bakery and these are
the only three options which should be
available for any user to fill in the
values how do we do that so we can
basically
create a table by pressing ctrl d so
what i can do is under my department
here i can select one of the cells
and then i can do a control t that
basically converts this into a table i
can say ok and my table is created now
what i can do is once this part is done
we can
select all the blank fields here where
we would want this drop down to be
applicable
now under your data tab you can go in
and select data validation and this has
an option called data validation click
on this
which basically says allow any value so
here i will select i would want to give
a list of values and then i can type in
my values here which i can say produce
say for example meat and then say
bakery now these are the values
so we can click on ok
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so i can go into every cell and
then i can basically choose
what is the department which handles
this
and then basically i can select one of
these from the drop down so this is an
easier option of creating your drop down
and then feeding in the values from the
set of values which you have defined
here on the right so this is a simple
example of using your drop downs
working with your tables working with
your sort and filter transpose split
filling up your data adding in some data
here and similarly you can use excel for
more than
one use case using its inbuilt features
to easily work with your data
let's see how we can import data or
bring in data into our excel from
your local machine or from an external
web source
so what we can do is we can open up a
blank excel sheet and say for example
you have been provided
a text file or a csv file and you would
want to import that data into your excel
sheet that can be easily done
so right now i've opened an
excel sheet now i can click on data and
here i have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources
so or you can click on connections if
you have already created some so we can
click on from other sources
so this is one option where you can
connect to your different data sources
and you can get the data
from
one of these what we can also do is i
can click on connections now it says
there is none
i can click on add it says
well show the connections where
connection files on network
connection files on this computer so i
can say let's get some files from this
computer
now if that does not show up something
so say browse for more
and that basically shows you different
options so let's basically select a
folder where i have some data sets i'll
click in here
and this is basically a folder where i
have some data sets now let me select
this particular file and i know it is a
csv file
so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a dot csv file which is what we
are interested in so i will take this
file i'll say open now this basically
shows me
the text import wizard option which says
is the file delimited i'll say yes
click on next so i will select comma as
my delimiter
i can say text qualifier is none
now this is my data so my data preview
is already showing me the data is
what is the data in the csv file you can
click on next and then you have an
option which says data format is general
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options so i'll just say
finish
and basically now this has been created
here
so we basically have this and now i can
click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data
which we have here the connection which
we have created say open
and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on ok
and now this data is automatically
inserted in my excel file i can
basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what i
can do is i can go into my github
and let's say
i would be interested in this csv file
so i can select this
and this is my github path a path on web
so i can click on draw and that
basically gives me
the raw path where this particular file
is now you can select this
copy this particular path
and here you can come back to your excel
sheet we would be interested in getting
the data from web might be from a text
file where we will have to specify the
delimiters or let's go to web
and here
i can given the web path from where i
would be interested in getting the file
let's give the github path which is
publicly available and then click on
import now once you click on import it
tells me there are two fields data and
value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on ok
and now you have the data coming in but
then this basically shows me in one
particular field so what we can also do
is we can just do a control a that
selects all my columns here
and that's my data so we can then
basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next
we can select comma and
let the text qualifier be quotes
it shows me data
preview click on next
so you have the general format it shows
the destination that's the column
click on finish and now your data has
been split and you have the data which
you have imported from web so this is
the data which is coming in from web
this is the data which came in from my
local machine and similarly we can even
create connection with an existing
database
so i can basically click on connections
if i would want to do that so i have an
option called connection here
and it says where the selected
connections are used
i can basically click on add
i can basically choose
if i would want to get the files from
network or from computer like we did
earlier
i can click on browse for more which
should show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new sql server connection you can
connect to a new data source coming in
from different place
you could basically choose what kind of
connection you would you want so these
are all the different options which we
can go for
and we can basically connect to a
database for example
if i have some database
and say for example access database
i can see if there are some files with
that particular database and i can
import it
so similarly we can also
uh click in here which is new query and
that also gives you an option of getting
the data from your files from all these
folders from databases so you can
basically click here and then you can
import data from a mysql database
provided that is set up on your local
machine or on a particular server you
can go from cloud you can get it from
online services you can get it from
other sources which says from web
from your hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor you can get the
data from different sources and then you
can bring it into your excel so in this
way you can get your data from different
sources into your excel into your
spreadsheet and then you can continue
working on those data sets
we have
already learned some basic operations
which you can do in excel and let's
implement our knowledge by working on
this particular data which is coming in
from housing data set now here if we see
some fields we have agent
date listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been
sorted in newest to oldest order of date
listed so how do we
arrive at this so what i can do is i can
just click on data listed
and then i can either
go in here i can select sort i can get
into custom sort
and then i can choose the column
based on which i would want to sort the
data so i would look for the newest data
to the oldest data that means that would
be in a descending order of dates or you
could say the oldest date or the
earliest month will be towards the lower
side of your sheet so here we can select
date listed now i can say let it sort
based on cell values and the order what
we have here so we have newest to oldest
so let's select this
i can say okay and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see
an earlier month hour
and
earlier month than that in this date
listed so we have sorted our data
into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your
date column so the result shows up here
now what we can also do is we can have
different questions which we would want
to answer so for example i would want to
sort the data in ascending order of area
and descending order of agent name how
do we do that so let's look into this so
this is here i already have the result
here and how did i get this so i'm
looking for ascending order of area in
descending order of agent name so we can
start with any particular column that
does not matter so for example if i look
into this excel sheet i have my agent
name select this which we want in a
descending order so we could either do a
sort and then go for
descending sort z to a we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or i could just say
sort z to a and then it
has arranged the data
based on the agent column being in
descending order now i can go into area
and then i can again do a sort and i
wanted my area column
to be used for
sorting the data ascending to descending
and that basically not only changes the
order of this particular column but for
my complete data so let's do that and
now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so
we can see how many values we have here
and the area values which we see and
this is how you get your result so i'll
just do a control z
and again and i'm back to my original
data and this is the sorted result which
we are seeing at
similarly we can answer other questions
for example sort the data according to
the following order
of area that is we are saying county
central
and then your county so we can basically
choose
in which particular way we would want to
do it so it is county central and then
again county
so if i look into my sheet 3 so here i
basically have my data which is
having some south county then you have
your central and then you have your
north county so we would want to
sort the data to solve our problem which
is
according to the following order so
first we go for area then we go for
south county central and north county so
what we can do is we can basically
have area field selected
and
i would want to sort this particular
data so i have south county central and
north county so i can basically go for
custom sort
and then i can choose which is the value
or column which i'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like
cell values well you can also try to
explore conditional formatting icon
if this is what you would want to use
or we can basically go for just cell
values
and here we can say
if i would be interested in first
getting my values for
south county so
for example i can say custom list
and then
i can basically given the new list here
so i can say s
dot county
and then i would want central
and then i would want north county
so let's select this
as it exists
we can
basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay
and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with kelly
you have in the 12th row something like
lang and that's what we are doing so we
can basically arrange the data in a
particular order by choosing a custom
list and then sorting your data
so that's one more simpler task of what
we have done where we have sorted the
data in the order where
under our area column we first wanted
south county
then we wanted central data and then we
wanted north county so this is how you
can do it
now
let's look into one more problem so it
says find all the houses in the central
area
and we would want to basically apply a
regular filter let's let's see how do we
do that so we can click on this and here
we have the data so the problem
statement is we would want to find all
the houses in central area now how do we
do that we can do a sorting but
we would want to use the filter which
you see here
is implemented so how do you do it so
you can select this area
and say for example i would want to
apply filter i can just go in here and i
can say let's get a filter on my first
row and now i have filters applied so we
are interested in looking into the
central area houses let's go in here it
says
all these fields are selected that means
it shows everything
wherein your area has all these values
let's unselect this and then i will only
be interested in the central so let's
say okay
and then say okay so now you see that
the area
filter has been applied and we are
looking at the central column so what we
have done is we have applied a symbol
filter and we are looking at our data at
any point of time if you do not
want
the filter
then
what i can do is i can select this and i
can say well i'm interested in all the
data
so i could do this or you can clear the
filters from area
and you get your data back
so
that's in one way you can filter out
your data so let's look at an example of
sort and filter where we might have to
filter the data based on two columns
or multiple columns with different kind
of values where it could be and and or
condition now say for example this is
the data i have and this is the question
which we need to answer such as find the
list of all houses
in the central region with pool
and south county without pool now if it
was a simple filter based on one cell i
could have
just selected my header row
i could have then applied the filter
and once i have the filter i can look in
area where i have three regions so i'm
only interested in central and south
county so i can get rid of north county
and that's fine but then
we have two different conditions here so
we need
the
data in central region to have
the value for pool being true
and for south county the value has to be
without pool now how do we
do that so what we can do is we can
first create a copy of these headers
here
so let me do that now the area has to be
south county so basically i can
either just select this and i can choose
this value
and then i can select this and then i
can choose central so that's the
criteria which i have
and the pool value has to be
so
central region should be with pool so
then this one
basically has to be true
and
this one has to be basically false so
south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now
to get my result
we can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is m column and
eighth row
okay so we would want the result here so
let's go ahead and now click on data
and then in filter you have an option
called advanced and here what i can do
is i can say i would want to filter the
list in the place but that's not what i
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location and here if you see the
list range will tell me that this is the
data so a1 to j126 so a to j column
selected and all the rows
criteria range
is basically based on what i have given
here so that is m
from 1
to v
which is 3
so i'm selecting these columns and then
i'm saying all the way whatever criteria
i've given and copy 2 i'm saying m8
to v8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say okay
and now i have my data which has been
filtered
and i have my area which is south county
that is without pool central with pool
again south county without pool and then
if you look at your central value that's
pool so this is an advanced filter which
we have applied where simply we have
filtered the data based on two columns
and then we have our result so in this
way you can have your customized filter
applied on two different columns and get
your data which can be either replacing
the existing content or
in the same sheet in different set of
columns and rows you can have your
result let's look at one more example of
filtering where you are trying to filter
the data based on an and condition
condition being met in two different
columns and then you would want to
filter out
the data for only specific columns so
the situation is the agents with a house
in north county that should be county
area having two
and a single type family so we are
talking about two bedrooms
and
we would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that we
would want to
only populate these columns which is
agent area bedroom and type now what you
can do is as i explained earlier that
you can get your result in
the same sheet in a different location
so here i have created these headers
which says agent area bedrooms and type
now this is basically a copy of all the
columns what we have here agent data
listed area list price bedrooms bath
square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here and this is where we will give our
advanced criteria to filter the data
so the conditions which need to be met
is we need to look at north county
so for example here in area i can
basically go ahead and select one of the
values north county
now the criteria is having two bedrooms
only so let's say bedrooms and let's say
the value should be two
and then basically i am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type i
can give the criteria
single type
so
this is my and condition so we are
saying north county area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if i select this this one tells me
that this is m
one row onwards till v
2
so this is what we have
and we would want to filter based on
this so let's go ahead and then go for
data filter advanced
and here in advanced it says filter the
list in place now that's not what we
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location
this basically selects the list range so
which is telling me
a 1
2 to j126
so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on m1 v2 which we have given
here and copy 2 i would say for example
from m7
to
p7 now this is the area where i would
this is the place where i want the
result let's say okay and now i get my
data which is
based on the question which has been
asked
that you would want the agents with a
house in north county area having two
bedrooms and single type family so in
this way you can basically do advanced
filtering
get your data and get it stored in the
sheet anywhere at a different location
well i could have also done filtering in
place and that would have replaced the
data
which we have but that's not what we
want we would want the filtered result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some advanced filtering we can
also use excel to filter out the data in
one particular column which might be
conditional or say
using some numerical filters now here
say for example the problem statement is
that you would want to display all the
houses whose list price is between
45 000 to 600 000
or say for example we would want to
filter out the data to something else
say for example let's say i have
i would want to filter out the data
between 300 thousand and four hundred
thousand so we can basically
update this
say for example i'm saying i'm
interested in 300
000
to
400
000 and that's the criteria to filter
out the data now there are two different
ways or there are two easier ways to do
it one is
i would want to look at the list price
so i can select this
i can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy you can click on this
one and then you can go into number
filters and you can choose between now
that's one easier way of doing it so i
could basically select this
i could say i'm looking for value which
is greater than or equal to 300 000
and then is less than or equal to 400
000 so if i just do this
i have applied my filter and i have my
data which is filtered based on my
criteria right so that's one easier way
of doing it or let me do a control
z
now
let the filter be there which you can
anyways use but what we can also do is
as we have seen earlier methods so get a
set or get your column headers here
and then
you are giving two columns here now the
only difference between
my
this set of columns which i have 1 2 3 4
and then you have 7 and 10 columns and
if you see here
we have 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 right so whenever you
want a and condition you will basically
add the columns where i can give add
condition if it is the same column if it
was a different column then it would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line and
all condition would lie in a different
line now here i can give this value so i
am looking for listed price
being
between 300 000 so i am saying it should
be greater than or equal to
300 000 and then i can say less than or
equal to 400 000 now that's my criteria
and then i need my result here which is
in m7
so what i can do is once i have given my
criteria which i'll be using
to filter i can get into data i can get
into advanced
and then i can say copy to another
location so it is selecting my a1 to
j126
criteria range is based on m1 to
w2
and then i would want my result from
this particular column
so let's say okay and now you have your
data filtered out
in a different location in the sheet
which has been filtered based on your
and condition so you can filter out the
data in this way or you could just apply
a filter on a column and give the
conditions
now let's solve one more interesting
problem and here we would want to use
excel where we would have an and and
an or condition so say for example this
is the data given to you and the
question is that you would want to find
all the houses in north county again
that's a spelling mistake but then the
north county area with a list price
greater than 300 000
and having three or four bedrooms so the
bedroom has conditional so it has r
three and four
and then basically you have
list price which is greater than three
hundred thousand now i could have
obviously
selected the columns and then basically
gone for a filter
so i can just do a filtering here
and then i'm looking for list price
being greater than 300 000 so which we
can always give a number filter and i
can say greater than and then i can say
greater than or equal so i can say
greater than and then i can give three
thousand thirty three hundred thousand
and that's basically the filter which we
would want
and
here i would want to select the bedrooms
which should be just either three or
four
so if for example here i go in here and
i unselect this and then i say three and
four
right so i am getting my data which is
greater than three hundred thousand and
it should have the bettering values
which will be
either three or four selected now that's
one way of doing it let's do a ctrl z
and get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear filter so you get your data back
as it was so what we can do is we can
here
give the criteria
so for example i have my
list price now this is what i would want
as a condition so let's say greater than
three hundred thousand
three hundred thousand and bedrooms
should be three
and then i can say greater than three
hundred thousand
then i can say four
so this one basically gives me a
situation where your list price has to
be greater than three hundred thousand
and bedroom should be either three or
four so we have given our filtering
criteria now to get the result what we
can do is we can go into data we can go
into advanced
and we can say copy to another location
so our list range is selected which is
columns a to j row number 1 to 126. your
criteria range is given in m1 to v3
where we have specified and we are
saying the result would be in m7 to v7
so if i do this now i have got the same
data which we were seeing earlier and
here the bedroom values are three or
four
and basically the list price is greater
than three hundred thousand so this is a
simpler way in which you can create your
filters and
all this advanced filtering what we are
seeing it will be saved with your sheet
you can always go back and change this
value or
you could do filtering where one person
has to look into the filter to see what
values have been selected
now let's understand what is a formula
in excel
in microsoft excel a formula is an
expression that operates on values in a
range of cells all formulas in excel
return a result even when the result is
an error
there are different ways to handling
errors which we'll see later
formulas allow you to perform basic
calculations such as addition
subtraction multiplication and division
you can also find out percentages and
average for a range of cells manipulate
date and time and lots more
now let me open an excel spreadsheet and
show you what a formula is
so here i have my excel worksheet
now let's say
i have some values under this a column
say 20
30 and 40.
now
i want to write a formula that will add
the values that are present from cell a1
to cell a3 so i'll give an equal to sine
and give my
cell green that is e1 plus
e2 plus a3 now if i hit enter it will
give me the addition of 20 plus 30 plus
40 which is 90.
now let's say
i want to divide
40
by
30
if i hit enter it will give me the
division of 40 by 30 which is 1.33 now
let's see what a function is in excel
when you are working in excel you will
often hear the terms formula and
function used frequently and sometimes
interchangeably
they are closely related but not exactly
the same
technically a formula is an expression
that begins with an equal sign functions
are used to perform complex calculations
that cannot be done manually
functions have names that reflect their
intended use
now let me take you back to the excel
sheet
and i'll show you what a function is
suppose
now i want to add
the values ranging from a1
to a4
either you can use a formula like we did
here we wrote a formula using multiple
addition operator
but there is another way which you can
use
that is to write a function
so excel provides a function called sum
that allows you to select a range of
cells so i'll select e1 to a4
and close the bracket and if i hit enter
it will return me the result of 20 plus
30 plus 40 plus 90 which is 180.
similarly there are other functions
let's say i want to find the average of
a range of cells so you can use the
average function to do that
if i hit tab it will auto complete i
will select the same range of cells from
a1 to e4 and close the bracket if i hit
enter it will return me the average
of these selected cells which is 45. now
that you have understood the basics of
formulas and functions in excel let's
dig deeper into learning the different
types of functions available in excel
and use relevant formulas when needed
along the journey
on your screens you can see we have a
mathematical functions worksheet where
we will learn the different mathematical
functions present in excel
let's begin at looking at the simple
table
that has three columns the quantity
column price per unit and total sales
now let's find the product of quantity
and price per unit to get the total
sales value
for that we will write a formula using
the multiplication operator so here i'll
write the formula i'll give an equal to
sign i'll select the first quantity
multiplication operator and then select
my price per unit
and if i hit enter
it will give me the product of quantity
and price per unit so 10 into 30 is 300
now to copy that formula i will just
drag this down
you can see we have all our total sales
values
now
if you want to find the sum of total
sales
you can use the sum function so here
i'll write equal to the news the sum
function i'll open the bracket then i'll
select
my total sales values close the bracket
and i hit enter
it will give me the total sales or the
sum of sales
similarly
if you want to find the average of total
sales
you can use the average function so i'll
type average and hit tab it will auto
complete
i'll select my sales values
close the bracket if i hit enter it will
give me the average total sales now
there's another function called sum
product that is available in excel you
can use the sum product function to
return the sum of the product of
corresponding ranges or arrays
so let's find the total sales using the
sum product function
the first array we will have the
quantity values while the second array
will have the price per unit
so i'll
select my sum product function
my first array i'll give the quantity
values
i'll give a comma
and i'll select my second array that is
price per unit i'll close the bracket
hit enter you can see we have the total
sales value that is 1165.
now
moving ahead let's understand the types
of logical functions in excel and how
you can use it
to the extreme left
you can see there are a number of
logical functions i have noted here so
you have is even function resort
function is logical and so on
now let's use them one by one and see
how it works
the is even function returns true if the
given number is an even value and it
returns false if it's not an even number
so we have here two numbers 4 and 13.
now
if i want to check if 4 is an even
number or not i can use the is even
function so i'll give equal to sign
and type is even
and i'll select this number or the cell
close the bracket
if i hit enter
it will return true because 4 is an even
number
similarly if i have to check for 13
i'll write this even
and select this cell which is a3 close
the bracket
i'll hit enter
it will return false because 13 is not
an even number
similarly
the is odd function returns true if the
given number is odd and it returns false
if it's not an odd number so let's check
if 4 is an odd number or not
so i'll write is
odd
tab
then i'll select the cell
close the bracket hit enter it returns
false because 4 is not an odd number
similarly
let's check for 13 i'll write is odd
select
e7 which has 13
i'll hit enter
it returns true because 13 is an odd
number
now
next we have the is logical function
this logical function returns true if
the given value is a logical value and
it returns false if it's not a logical
value
when i say logical value i mean true or
false now let's check if 30 is a logical
value or not
so i'll write equal to
is logical
i'll select 30
if i hit enter
it returns false because 30 is not a
logical number
similarly
let's check for the next two values
i'll select this cell value which has
true in it
if i hit enter it returns true because
true in itself is a logical value
similarly
false should also return true because
it's a logical value
you can see it here then
we have is number function that returns
true if the given value is a number
numbers could be integers floating
values or whole numbers now we have a
number here which is 40.5
let's verify if it's a number or not so
i'll write equal to
then select is number
select the cell close the bracket
hit enter it returns true
similarly you have to check if 30 is a
number or not
you can use the same function which is
is number
select 30 close the bracket hit enter it
returns true because 30 is also a number
now
in the next cell we have a text value
you can see it's cnn so ideally it
should return false because cnn
is not a number there you go it has
returned false because cnn is a text
value and not a number
now let's explore a few other functions
that you can see here so the round
function rounds a number to a specified
number of digits
so suppose i want to round up 35.316
to two decimal places so i'll write
equal to
and i'll give the round function
i'll provide my number 35.316
comma
since i want to round up to two decimal
places i'll give two
i close the bracket if i hit enter
it gives me the rounded value of 35.316
which is 35.32 now the round down
function rounds a number down towards
zero
so let's see
i'll give the round down function
and i'll provide the same number that is
35.316
let's say
i want to round down to two decimal
places
if i hit enter
the result is 35.31
similarly the roundup function rounds a
number up away from zero so i'll write
round up
i'll give my number 35.316
if i give the number of digits say 2
it will return
35.32 so it rounds up this value
moving ahead
now if you want to convert a number into
integers you can do that using the int
function
so suppose i want to convert
35.316 into integers i can
give my integer function that is int
and provide by number 35.316
close the bracket if i hit enter
so you have the integer value of this
floating point number
similarly if you want to find the
integer of say
equal to int
let's say a negative number
minus
35.316
will return the negative integer value
that is minus 36
now the truncate function truncates a
number to an integer by removing the
decimal of fractional part of a number
so let's say i want to truncate 35.316
i'll write
trunk
which is the truncate function
now let me pass in my number that is
35.316
let's say i want to give the number of
digits as 2
i close the bracket hit enter it returns
me
35.31 so it has truncated the last digit
now similarly
if i
if the number of digits as one the
result will be 35.3
you can see it here
moving ahead
the ceiling function rounds a number up
that is to the nearest multiple of
significance so i'll show you what it
means
i'll use equal to then pass in my
ceiling function
i'll give my number 35.316
if i give say 2
close that returns me 36 because the
nearest highest multiple
of this number is 36
similarly if i give
let's say 5 it will return 40 because
the nearest highest multiple of this
number to 5 is 40.
now
talking about the floor function
the floor function rounds a number down
to the nearest multiple of significance
so for example if i
use the floor function
the same number 35.316
now let's say i want to give the
significance as 2 it will return 34
the nearest lowest multiple of this
number that is divisible by 2 is 34.
now if you want to change this number
from 2 to let's say we want to give as
7 if i hit enter it will give 35 because
35 is the nearest multiple of 7
next let's talk about an important
function called subtotal now subtotal
returns the subtotal in a list or
database the sub maximum minimum sum and
others
let's explore a few of this let's see
i want to use
subtotal function
and let's say i want to find
average you can see here
one is for average i'll give one
comma
i'll give my reference
this quantity column values
close the bracket
if i hit enter
it will give me the average of the
selected cells from
e2 to e4 now
let's say i want to find the subtotal
and this time i want to
let's say i want to count so i'll give 2
comma
i'll count all the values present
in the selected cells
from e2 to z4 and close the bracket hit
enter it returns me 9. you can see there
are 9 cells that are filled in here next
let's say this time i want to find the
subtotal and let's take some now so i'll
give
9
comma
let's sum up the
price per unit column so f2 to f4 close
the bracket
hit enter you can see the sum of price
per unit is 105.
now let's do one more
use the same subtotal function
now let's say i want to find the maximum
value
from the sales column select my total
sales column
close the bracket
right enter
returns me 480 because that's the
highest or the maximum value of total
sales
now
excel provides a factorial function
called fact so if you want to find the
factorial of a number you can use this
function
so find out the factorial so i'll use
the fact function
let's say i want to find the factorial
of number 5
i'll close it
you can see the factorial of 5 is 120
similarly if you want to find the
factorial of let's say the number seven
it returns me one zero four zero
moving on now you can use the max and
min function to find the maximum and
minimum values in a range of cells so
i'll use the
max function let's say i want to find
the maximum from price per unit since it
has returned me the max that is 40.
similarly you can use the min function
i'll use the same column price per unit
now you can see the minimum value from
price per unit column is 30. excel also
has a function called rand between that
returns a random number between the
numbers you specify so if you want to
generate random numbers you can use 5
square
the result should be 25 you can see it
here
now i want to find the power of 4 raised
to 4
the result is 256.
moving ahead the most function or the
mod function returns the remainder when
a number is divided by a divisor so
let's see how to use it i'll use the mod
function
and give my number 10
let's divide 10 by 3 the result is 1.
now we have a few other numbers let's
try them also
use mod 12 let's say i want to divide 12
by
4
the result is zero big nine similarly
let's see one more
i'll use the count function now let's
see i'll select from g1 to g4 if i close
the bracket hit enter it returns me
three because total sales the first cell
value is not a number it's a character
value hence it skipped the count of
total sales and it counted the remaining
cells now next moving on to count a
function the county function counts the
number of cells in a range that are not
empty so for example if i use the county
function now let's say i'll select
from l1 to l4
close the break has returned me 3
because we had an empty cell so it
skipped that count and it counted the
remaining cells that were non-empty
similarly let's use the function once
more and type count a now let's say i'll
select from
l 2
to n 4
close the bracket hit enter
it gives me 5 because we have only 5
values that are delts are empty so it
skipped that count moving ahead we have
the count blank function now as the
function suggests it counts the number
of blank or empty cells in a specified
range of so if i use count blank
and let's say i'll select
this range from l1 to l4 close the
bracket
you can see it has returned one because
we had one
empty cell
in this range of cells now let's do one
more
count blank
i'll select from l2 to n4
close the bracket it has returned four
because we you can see it here we have
three blank cells here so total four
hence it has returned 4
up next
we have the and function
the and function
checks if all the conditions or
arguments are true
it returns true if all the conditions
are true
if one of the conditions is false then
and function will return false let's do
this with an example suppose i
write the and function
so the first argument or the parameter
has to be a logical
condition let's say i'll select from
e2 to e4
and my condition will be
greater than 9 let's see my second
condition
is from f2 to f4
is less than
45 close the bracket hit it returns true
because you can see our first condition
from e2 to e4 all the values are greater
than 9
while the second condition from f2 to f4
all the values are less than 45 so since
both the conditions at one of the values
is not less than 450 you can see we have
a value 480 which is greater than 450
and
our second condition f2 to f4 all the
values are greater than 25 now since one
of the conditions is false so our and
function returns false
moving on to or function
the r function checks whether any of the
arguments are true and returns true
if all the arguments do not meet the
condition it will return false
so you have to satisfy all the
conditions
in order to return a true value and use
the r function now let's say i'll give
my condition from e2 to e4 greater than
15
comma from f2
to let's say f4
less than 25 i close the bracket i hit
enter
it has returned me false
because both the arguments are not
satisfying the condition you can see
from e2 to e4 none of the values are
greater than 15 and similarly
from f2 to
f4 none of the values are less than 25
now since both the conditions are false
our or statement false let us take one
more example i'll use the or function
again now the condition will be from g2
to g4 greater than equal to 300 comma
let's say from f2 to f4
less than equal to 40. i'll hit enter
there you go it has returned us true
because both the conditions are true you
can see if all the values between g2 to
g4 are greater than or equal to 300
similarly all the values from f2 to f4
are less than or equal to 40. now let's
get to our second tab which is character
text functions here we will learn
various character functions and how you
can use them in excel so first you can
see we have is text function so the is
text function checks if the given value
is a text value and returns true or
false so if i were to check if this
value is a text or not so i can use this
text function i'll give reference to
this cell
close the bracket it returns false
because 10 is not a text it's a number
similarly
let's check the next one i'll select
cell e3
if i hit enter
you can see it has written true
though the value is 10 but still it's a
text the reason is you can see on top we
have given an apo stop before writing 10
so i'll show it to you here in case i
write 90 hit enter the numbers by
default are right aligned now if i give
an apostol and then write 90 hit enter
it is now a text you can check that
using the x is text function select this
cell close the bracket hit enter it
returns me true so this 90 is a text
value
now similarly let's check for the next
one is equal to
is text
i'll select this cell
hit enter it returns me true because
excel is a text value now the next
function we have is the length function
as the name suggests
the length function returns the number
of characters in a string so it will
count the total characters including
spaces as well as special characters so
let's see
how many characters does this string
india has
if i hit enter it returns five
you can count india has in total five
characters
similarly
let's check
for this sentence
i'll write len which is the length
function
select this cell
close the bracket hit enter
it returns me 28
because it has counted the spaces also
now
there's a function called text that
converts a value to text in a specified
number format so suppose
i want to convert these date values into
text values in a given number format so
i can write the text function i can give
the value by referencing the cell comma
let's say i want to print the date value
in the form of a text in this format
let's say dd
m
and y by close the bracket you can see
this has converted the date value into
ddm yy
now similarly you can change the date
value to text in some other format like
dd triple m then
4y and see it returns 30 june
2015
now if this is a text value or not you
can use the same function that is text
and give reference to this cell there
you go it has returned me true which
means it has converted the date values
into text now
moving ahead next we have the replace
function the replace function replaces
the part of a text string within a
different text string so suppose i want
to replace
cell a 15 value which is a101 i'll give
my start num as one
the number of characters let's say one
and my new text i want to replace the a
value with b close the bracket if i hit
enter you can see here a101 has become
b101 because we replace the first a
value to b now let's try out a few more
examples i'll use the replace function
i'll give my old text that is
that is a102 i'll give my start num as
one
my number of characters as one
let's say the new text i want is a2
close the bracket you can see it here
from our old text which had a it has
replaced with new text that has a2 now
let's say i want to use the replace
function over adam i'll select the cell
a17 now let's say i the start numbers
one the number of characters is let's
say 2 and i want my new character as s a
close the bracket you can see it here
the first two characters from atom has
been replaced by s a that is what we did
here so we started our
start number one
then we chose the next two characters
that is a d
and a d we replaced it with s a
so the name becomes sam now moving ahead
the next function we have is substitute
the substitute function replaces
existing text with new text in a text
string for example if i use the
substitute function i'll give my old
text which has i work at simply learn
give a comma now i'll select
let's say i work which is from my old
text and i want to replace it with
he works
close the bracket
you can see
the substitute function has replaced has
replaced the second 2010 from our old
string to 2016. next
let's use the substitute function once
again i'll give the cell reference as
e22
this time i want to replace
2010 present in the old text to 2016.
you can see here at two places there
were 2010 it has replaced it to 2016 at
both the places
then we have the concatenate function
you can see it here concatenate means
combining strings so a concatenate
function joins or merges several text
strings into one text string here i have
two strings hello
and in another cell i have world i want
to concatenate these two strings
so i'll use the
concatenate function i'll select
cell e25
give a comma now i'll give two inverted
commas with a space give another comma
and select cell b25 that has world
close the bracket there you go now it
has concatenated both hello and world
now it's one word hello world similarly
let's concatenate these two cells i'll
use the concatenate function and select
my first cell that has xls
now you can use an amber sent to
concatenate as well
and then give to inverted
commas for space
give another amber send and select the
next cell close the bracket hit enter
you can see
it has concatenated
the two cells
and it has formed a sentence excel is
fun to learn up next we have the repeat
function
now repeat function or rept function
repeats text a given number of times
you can fill a cell with a number of
instances of a text string now we have
some data here so
here
let's see these are the age groups of
women and there was a survey these are
the number of respondents we got from
each age group i want to create a
histogram i can use the repeat function
or rept function
i want to give my text as a special
character
hit a comma
and i'll select
cell b32 which is the number of times i
want to repeat
that character hit enter you can see it
has repeated the special character 10
times now similarly you can do it for
the next few cells also if i just copy
paste this formula it will give me the
result so you can see it looks like a
histogram now let's say i want to repeat
hashtag and add the rate symbol for 10
times so i can write the repeat function
give my text as hashtag and add the rate
and the number of times i want is
10
close the bracket it returns me the
result which has hashtag and add the
rate printed 10 times
moving ahead next we have the type
function
now the type function returns an integer
representing the data type of a value
now here on the right you can see
suppose the type function returns 1 it
means
the value is a number or it's a blank
let's say the return type is 2 it means
the data type is a text if it's 4 it
means the data type is a logical value
that is either true or false
now if it's an error it will return the
value 16
and if it's an array it will return 64.
now let's try these examples
here we have excel
which is a text value
so if i use my type function
and select excel
hit enter it returns me true because
excel is a text value you can see it
here if it's a text it will return 2.
now similarly let's try this one
100 it has returned me 1 because 1 is a
number so it will return me 1 15.45
if i use the type function
15.45 hit enter so it has returned me
one now you can see these are some
errors now it's an error because we have
divided a 39 by a 40 you can see it here
a39 had a text value and a40 had a
numeric value so you cannot obviously
divide a text by a number so it has
returned me an error now if i want to
check the type close the bracket hit
enter it has returned me 16. you can see
it here if if it's an error value it
will return 60. similarly this one more
error here let's try this out use the
type function give this error hit enter
this also has returned 16. now let's
check one more example for an array now
you can write an array inside the type
function itself to write an array we use
curly braces i'll give one comma 2 comma
3 and 4 as my array elements
i close the curly braces and the bracket
if i hit enter
it has returned me 64. you can see it
here if it's an array it will return the
data type as 64
which is an array now
there's a function called is blank which
checks if a cell is empty or blank
if it is empty it will return true else
it will return false
now if you were to check
if this cell is empty or not
if i hit enter it returns me true
because you can see it here
cell a47
is empty and there's no value in it
now if i want to find out
if cell a 48 is blank or not if i hit
enter it returns me false
because there is a value 40 in it
now
we'll see how to use trim function so
the trim function removes all the
unnecessary spaces from a string
but it won't remove the sink all the
unnecessary spaces except
the space between angela and stephen's
i'll copy paste this value to the
remaining cells
you can see it has removed all the
unnecessary spaces from the original
string
now you can check the length once again
for the trimmed string if i hit enter
the length is 15 for defense you can see
it has removed at least six spaces from
the original string now let's copy paste
this formula it has removed the
unnecessary spaces from all the original
strings
next we have the find function so the
find function returns the starting
position of one string within another
string now you should notice that find
function
is case sensitive so
let's use the find function here i'll
write find
i want to find where capital s is
located in the cell a52 that has angela
stephens into a comma select a52 hit
enter it returns me the starting
position that is 11
now
if i were to check using the find
function this time i want to find where
small e is located within a52 which has
angela stiffens i'll give a comma and i
want my start num as one close the
bracket
hit enter it has returned me seven you
can count it here on the top so where
the cursor is is the first position so
i'll now keep shifting 2 3
4 5
cell a52 that has angela stefans
close the bracket hit enter it has
returned me 11.
so basically it has returned me this s
but since search function is case
insensitive so it did not care if it was
an upper case s or a lowercase s
similarly if i want to find where a is
located or capital a is located in
antonio miner
i'll use the search function
i want to find capital a within text
i'll give
cell a54
now let's say i want to give my starting
num as
5
close the bracket
it has returned me 19
so it has returned me this a
because the only a that exists after 5
is this
so here also since b searched for
capital a but it looked for any a that
was present in antonio myno be it small
or capital finally we have a clean
function
so the clean function returns all
non-printable characters from the text
now you can see here this cell has three
lines of text now if you want to print
this
cell in one line i can use the clean
function
it will remove all the non-printable
characters i'll select cell a67 close
the bracket hit enter there you go it
has printed the address in one line now
we have one more text which says i hope
you are doing well during the pandemic
now if i want to clean that cell
close the bracket it has printed the
same sentence in one line now there are
a few more functions let's see them one
by one we have a function called upper
so the upper function converts any text
string into upper case
so we have a string called india now if
i want to convert india into upper case
i'll use the upper function select that
cell you can see it here it has
converted india into uppercase
characters
similarly you can use the lower function
to convert any text string into
lowercase
i'll use the lower function
select that string enter
there you go
so all the letters in the word india has
been converted into lower case now
there's another function called proper
which is used to convert any string into
proper case
so i can write a vlookup function
something like this i'll give equal to
search for vlookup
now my lookup value will be stewart
comma
then i'll select my table array
so i'll take my table array from a2
to
c7
if you want you can choose the entire
table also
give a comma
my column index number is this
department column which is the
third column
and range lookup is either true or false
i'll select false which is 0 for exact
match
if i hit enter
you can see it has returned marketing
and in the table also if you see stewart
is from the marketing department so this
is a simple example how you can use
vlookup
now
if you want you can choose the entire
table
so i can select from
a2
to e7 hit enter will give the same
result now suppose i want to find from
the marketing department
so
this is the person who is from the
marketing department i want to find the
city i'll use the vlookup function again
vlookup
now my lookup value is marketing
element column
is the left most lookup column
select the remaining table
give a comma now my column index number
is 2
is the city column
and i'll give my range lookup as 0
because i want the exact match i'll hit
enter because it has returned me the
city to which this person from the
marketing department belongs to that is
kansas let's see another example
suppose i want to find the city to which
the person with the last name
davis belongs to so i'll write my
vlookup function i'll
take my lookup value as device will give
a comma
now my table array will start from the
last name column
and let's select the remaining columns
as well
now my
column index number is will be 3
as per our selection
for example let's say we want to find
the first name of the person who is from
los angeles city so we have our lookup
values los angeles and now we want to
find the first name so i'll again use
the lookup function i'll give my lookup
value as los angeles
comma now my lookup vector is the city
column
comma my resultant vector is the first
name column
close the bracket hit enter
you can see it has returned me stewart
which is actually wrong
if you see our original table the person
who is from los angeles city is not
stuart
but it's lucy
so the mistake that we did was before
applying the formula we did not sort a
lookup column so let me short this
column in ascending order go to the data
tab i'll sort it i'll click sort now you
can see it has returned me lucy and you
can see there was an error because we
sorted the table so the values changed
so be aware of this
now let's try another example let's say
i want to find the department of the
person who was hired on this particular
date which is 10th of november 2001 so i
can use the lookup function
here better first i'll sort this date
hired column in ascending order click on
sort now let's find the department of
the person with the last name as davis
so you can see
davis and
the department it belongs to is sales
so i'll use the hlookup function again
select my lookup value as davis give a
comma now my table array
i'll select from
g2 to m5 now in this selection my row
index number will be 2 which is the
department column
give a 0 close the bracket hit enter
it has returned sales so davis is from
sales department moving ahead now
let's explore the if function so the if
function in excel checks whether a
condition is satisfied or met
it returns a value if true else it will
return another value if the condition is
not satisfied
so let me use
an if function here
i'll give my logical test as
say the value in cell 11
if it's greater than 5 then i'll return
yes
10
is greater else i'll return
no close the bracket hit enter
you can see the result
it says yes 10 is greater because our
condition 10 is greater than 5
now if i change this value to 4
it returns no because
4 is not greater than 5. now we have a
question here
i want to add
values to this result column
so our condition is
if the player scores more than 50 and
average is more than 42 then he is a
good player else he is not a good player
so we'll return not so good
so we have three player names the runs
they have scored
and the average they have so i'll use
the and give my condition
i'll write equal to
if
now since i am checking for two
conditions that is
the player should score more than 50 and
the average should be more than 42 so
i'll use and
and clause here
so i'll check
if
p
22 which has the runs is greater than 50
and q
22 is greater than 42
then
will return is a good player
else
not so good
close the bracket
if i hit enter
it has returned me good player because
both runs and averages the meter
condition
now let me copy paste this formula
for this cell you can see michael has
scored 40 runs and his average is also
40
is not so good because
our condition was he should have scored
more than 50 and average should be more
than 42 so both the conditions
was not met
the next function we have is
if n a now the if any function
will return the value you specify if the
expression resolves to any value
otherwise it will return the result of
the expression so
i want to find
the department of anthony
now you can see the first name column
there's no name as anthony let's see
what happens if you want to find the
department of anthony so i'll write
equal to if n a now in value i'll use a
vlookup function i'll give my value as
r12 which is anthony and i'll choose my
column as from o2 to s7
give a comma now the department or the
column index number is 3 which is the
department column
i'll give 0
close the bracket give another comma
now if the value results in n a
will return
such as
value not
found
hit enter
you can see it here it has returned me
value not found because
our vlookup function could not find any
lookup value as anthony in the first
name column
so it returned value not found
similarly there is one more function
called if returned value not found
similarly there is one more function
called if error
so the if error function returns the
error value if the expression is an
error otherwise it returns the value of
the expression if there is no error so
these two cells you can see we have some
values 10 and 0 let's say i want to use
the f error function
and
the value i'll give is say i want to
divide
u3
by
u4 so i am dividing 10 by zero
now
if the result is an error will return
cannot divide close the bracket hit
enter you can see it has returned me
cannot divide because you cannot divide
a number by zero
hence there was an error so it returned
this value now let's say i want to
divide let's say i want to use the
iferror function again
and now i want to divide w3 which has
the value 10 by w4 which is the value 5
i'll give the value if error that is
cannot
divide
if i hit enter it returns me true
because 10 is divisible by 5 so divided
10 by 5 and the result was 2.
similarly
let's say i want to find
the city to which
again there is no
anthony try this out i'll use the index
function now the array i will give us
from
z2 to ac 7
comma my row num is 3 and the column
number i want is 2 close it returns me
davis which is this one the reason being
we skipped the header column our column
was selected from this cell so this is
our first row second row third row so
third row and second column we have
davis similarly let's check for fifth
row and fourth column i'll use the index
function i'll give my array from
z2 to
87 this time i'm selecting the entire
table
i'll give my row number as 5 and my
column as 4 close the bracket
hit enter
the result it returns is boston you can
see
the fifth row is this one and the fourth
column is city so it returns
boston now the match function
returns the relative position of an item
in an array that matches a specified
value so if you want to find
the position at which
events is located in the table so you
can use the match function something
like this
match i'll take my lookup value as
y 15 which has
evens
comma
now my lookup array
will be
the last name column because events was
from the last name column comma i'll
give 0 for exact match i'll hit enter it
gives me 5. events was present in the
fifth row let's check for boston now
i'll use the match function again my
lookup value will be boston comma my
lookup array will be the city column
comma i want the exact match close the
bracket hit enter
it returns six so if you start from the
beginning here this is the first row
second third fourth fifth and sixth in
sixth row we have boston now you can use
this index match function to return a
value in a column to the left
with vlookup you are stuck returning a
value from a i'll select my lookup array
from
z1 to z7
comma
0
i close the brackets hit enter
it has returned kansas
you can see jensen the first name jensen
belong to city kansas
similarly
let's find the city to which the person
with the last name as evens belongs to
so evens you can see from the table
belongs to los angeles let's find out
using our index match function
i'll write index
and then
array i'll give as
ec1
ec12ac7
comma
myronum
i'll give my match function
lookup value will be evens
which is ab15
comma
lookup array
is
ae 1 2 e a 7
which is our last name column
and 0.
if i hit enter you can see it has
returned
los angeles now let's find out the
department to which
zampa belongs to
so i'll use my index function
now i'll select
my array from
aa1
to
ac7
comma
i'll find the row number using the match
function
so my lookup value will be zampa which
is a b 18
comma
the lookup array will be
a 1 2 a 7
comma
0
and close the bracket
give one more comma now i'll find the
column number
i'll again use
my match function to do it
this time i want to find the
location of department
so i'll give
department that is ab1 as the reference
comma the lookup array will be from a1
to ad1 which are the column headers
comma 0
and i'll close the brackets if i hit
enter
it gives me sales so you can see here
from the table
zampa is from the sales department
so in this way you can use index match
function to find the row number the
column number
and the value you are looking for now
we'll talk about countif countifs sumifs
and average functions
so you can see i am here in a new tab
now to check these functions i am using
a corona virus data set you can see it
here
it has a date column then we have
divided the date into day month year
number of cases deaths countries from
which these cases and debts came from
we have the continent and few other
information
so first let's see
what countif function does so the county
function counts the number of cells
within a range that meet the given
condition
so we'll see these functions by taking
an example
so we have a question here we want to
count the number of times afghanistan is
present in the data set so i'll consider
my g column that is countries and
territories
so i'll write my countif function i'll
give my range
from g1 to the end of this g column
i'll give a comma
go to the top
now my criteria will be
afghanistan
if you want you can use cell reference
as well
i am typing the country name manually if
i hit enter
it gives me 446.
so in this column that is the g column
afghanistan is present 146 times
similarly let's count the number of
times india is present in the data set
so i'll use the county function again
i'll select the same range and give a
comma now my criteria will be
india you can see here india is present
155 times moving on the next function
we'll talk about is countifs so tiff's
function counts the number of cells
specified in a given set of conditions
or criteria so our question is count the
total number of days in which the cases
in india have been greater than 100 so
to do this
count eps function
i'll select
my criteria range
first i'll select the d column
comma
my first criteria is we want to check
for india
and then
my second condition is that
the number of cases has to be greater
than 100 so my next criteria range will
be the cases column
comma
and my condition is
greater than 100 close the bracket hit
enter the result is 68
so a total of 68 days india had
more than 100 cases the next example is
we need to count the number of days in
which the debts in united states have
been greater than 200 so for that
i'll use the
count if's function
i'll give my criteria so this time i'm
taking my first criteria as the cases
comma so the cases have to be greater
than 200
close the bracket hit enter
so you can see the total cases in india
till
3rd of june have been
more than 2 lakhs now i want to find the
total debts in the united states till
the 3rd of june
i'll use the same
sumif function
now my
first criteria will be the g column
comma
i'll give my second value as
united states of america i'll use the
same format using underscore
states
of
america
comma
now the second range will be the deaths
column
close the bracket hit enter you can see
the total deaths in the united states
till 3rd of june have crossed
1 lakh similarly let's now
see our sumifs function so the sumifs
function adds the cells
specified in a given set of conditions
or criteria so we have a question here
we want to find the total cases in
france
on those days where the deaths have been
less than 100
so this would be those days instead of
hers
okay so let's see our sumps function now
first we need to
give the sum range
since we want to find the total cases so
we'll give the sum range as
the column e
comma now the second criteria is the
countries column so i'll give the g
column and we want to check for france
give that criteria comma the second
criteria is i need to find only for
those days where the debts have been
less than 100
so i'll give the deaths column comma the
criteria should be less than 100.
close the bracket hit enter
this is the result so the total cases in
france on those days where the deaths
have been less than 100 is
thousand six hundred and thirty eight
now let's talk about the average if
function so the average of function
finds the average or the arithmetic mean
of the cells specified by a given
condition or criteria so our question is
we want to find the total average daily
cases in india this is till the 3rd of
june so i'll use the average function
and my first criteria i'll select is the
countries column and my criteria will be
india and then i'll give the range
that is the e column which has the cases
if i hit enter
so these are the daily average cases in
india till the 3rd of june next
let's talk about some date and time
functions in excel you can see here i am
in my date and time
sheet
so
let's start with the today function
the today function returns the current
date
or today's date
so if i write equal to
today close the bracket hit enter it
will return me today's date which is
28th of july now you can use the now
function which will return the current
date and time value
so if i write equal to
now
if i hit enter
you can see it has returned the current
date and the time
so this is basically the system date and
time you can see it here now there is
another function called time the time
function converts hours minutes seconds
given as numbers to an excel serial
number formatted with a time format so
you can see here i'll write the time
function now let's see i'll give my
hours as 20 so it's in 24 hours format
let's say a minute i'll give 40 and
seconds i'll give 20. close the bracket
hit enter the time is
8 40 pm
now you can subtract
the now function from today function to
return the time value so let me show it
to you here i'll write my now function
and i'll subtract today if i hit enter
it returns me the time this is the
system time now
there's another function in excel called
date diff function which returns the
difference between two dates in terms of
years months and days
now here i have a date of birth which is
30 december 1994
and we have today's date i have used the
today function
if i want to find the age i can use the
datedif function so i will write date
diff and
in that i'll give my
first date value as the date of birth
which is 30 december 1994
comma
my second date value will be today's
date which is 28th of july
now i want to find the age in terms of
years so within double course i'll give
y
i hit enter it gives me 25 so it has
subtracted our first date value and the
second date value to return the year now
the date the function will always return
a whole number you can see it here this
was a whole number you can use the year
frac function in excel to return the
year fraction representing the number of
whole days between the start date and
the end date so i can use the year frac
function here
right year frac my start date will be my
date of birth
now the end date will be today's day
comma basis
i'll give
one
which is actually it will
divide the actual number of days by the
actual days in a year right enter it
gives me my year fraction which is
25.5763
now let's say
i'll replace one with
let's say two
if i hit enter it gives me 25.95
you can see it here if you give 2 it
will divide the actual days by 360. now
the default value is 0. moving ahead
we have the
weekday function
now the weekday function returns a
number from 1 to 7 identifying the day
of the week of a date so
let me use the weekday function i'll
give my
serial number as today right enter it
gives me three
now
let's say
i want to use the weekday function again
i'll
use
my cell reference e2 which has the
today's date comma
now the return type
i'll give as
2
which means
it starts from monday through sunday so
the first day of the week starts on a
monday and ends on a sunday tip 2 close
the bracket hit enter it gives me 2.
the second day of the week
then you can have your day function
month function and year function
let's explore them one by one
so the day function returns the day of
the month
it will have a number between 1 to 31
so 1 means
the beginning of the month and 31 means
the last day of the month
so if i use my day function on
e2 which is today's
date
if i hit enter
it gives me 28 that is 28th of july
similarly let's check for month
i'll give the same cell reference hit
enter it gives me 7 which means the july
month
now let's find the year give the cell
reference hit enter
it returns me the year that is 2020. now
you can extract the hours minutes and
seconds from a time value
so
i'll use the r function to get the r
value from the current time you can see
it has returned 14 which means it's 2 pm
now let's find out the minute also i'll
use the minute function give my now
function hit enter
gives me 19. so it's 2pm
and 19 minutes now let's find out the
seconds also i'll give my now function
to get the second also there's another
function in excel called
days 360.
so days 360 function returns the number
of days between two dates
based on a 360 day year
so we assume that in a year all the
months have 30 days
so i'll use my
days 360 function
i'll give my
start date
as my date of birth which is b12
comma
the end date
i'll give today's date which is in b13
and the method i'll use is true which is
european method
you can see what the european method
says
says the start dates and end dates that
occur on the 31st day of a month will be
equal to the 30th day of that month
close the bracket hit enter it gives me
the total number of days that were
between
my first date that is the starting date
and the end date similarly
now let's use d360 once again
i'll give my start date let's say 25th
of june 2020 and my
end date will be today's date so get the
total number of days that is 33.
similarly we have eo month which means
end of month so end of month function
returns the serial number of the last
day of the month before or after a
specified number of months so i'll use
my eu month i'll give my start date as
b12 which is my date of birth
and then i want the number of months to
be 10 hit enter you can see it has given
us the next day when the month is ending
so it is 31st of october 1995.
coming to weeknum function the weeknum
function returns the week number of the
year so i'll use my weeknum function and
my serial number will be today's date
comma
the return type i want is
2 so i want my week to begin on a monday
so i'll give 2 close the bracket hit
enter
it gives me 31. so
today's date that is 28th of july is the
31st week of the year let's explore a
few more functions
we have network days and work days now
these are advanced functions
of date and time in excel
now
the network days function returns the
number of whole working days between two
dates so network days automatically
excludes weekends that is saturday and
sunday and can optionally exclude a list
of holidays supplied as dates now i have
listed down the list of holidays this is
from the u.s calendar
and the list of holidays are for the
current year that is 2020.
so first let's use our networkdays
function to find the number of working
days between two date values
so i'll write
network days
and let's see i'll give my first date or
the starting date as
1st of july
2020
and i'll give my second date value
as 31st of
july
2020. close the bracket hit enter it
gives me 23.
now let me show you the calendar now
this is the july calendar
if you can see
the first day of july starts on
wednesday
and it ends on friday and in between we
have one two three four five six seven
and eight so total we have eight
weekends
so our nets skipped counting these
weekends
so
since july is at 31 days month it has
subtracted those eight days those were
on weekends so 31 minus 8 is 23
so in total we have 23 working days in
july now let's say i want to include the
holiday calendar also so i'll use the
network days function again i'll give my
starting the workday function returns
serial number of the date before or
after a specified number of workdays the
excel workday function takes date and
returns the nearest working day in the
future or past it can be used in
logistics to calculate shipping dates
delivery dates that need to take into
account working and non-working days it
automatically excludes weekends that is
saturdays and sundays
so let me use my workday function i'll
give my start date as
1st of july
2020
and the number of days i'll give is 5.
close the bracket hit enter
it has returned me a serial number you
can convert this into a date value so
our next working date after 1st of july
is 8th of july if you see the calendar
we started on first of july so counting
5 days after 1st of july so 1 2 three
four and five so the next working day
after five days will be 8th of july so
it has skipped counting the weekends
4th of july and 5th of july similarly
i'll use
the workday function again this time
i'll give my starting date
as first of july only and now
i want to find the next working days
after five days and i'll give my holiday
list
close the bracket hit enter i can
convert this into a date value you can
see it has given us 9th of july because
5 days we had a holiday that is 3rd of
july which was independence day finally
let's move on to our next and the final
section in this tutorial for functions
and formulas we have some financial
functions so these financial functions
are commonly used in banking and
financial sectors let's have a look at
them one by one first we have the pmt
function now the excel pmt function is a
financial function that returns the
periodic payment for a loan the pmt
function can be used to figure out the
future payments for a loan assuming
constant payments and a constant
interest rate so i'll just show you the
arguments the pmt function takes you can
say it takes rate in pr or nper pv fp
and a type so rate is the interest rate
for the loan nper is the total number of
payments for the loan pv is the future
value of the total value of all loan
payments now fv is the future value for
a cash balance you want after the last
payment is made by default it is 0 type
it is optional when payments are due so
0 means end of period 1 means beginning
of period now let's use the pmt function
to find
the future payments for a loan so i have
my data here on the top
i have my rate as 5 percent i'll use
cell reference a2 comma
then i want my npr or number of period
so i'll give myself b2
comma
the present value
is my loan amount
that is 2 lakhs
comma
i don't want any future value it give it
as 0
close the bracket hit enter
you can see it has returned us the pmt
amount or the principal amount
now you can see it has given us
a negative number the reason being the
amount is getting deducted from our
present value so to solve this issue
you can give
a negative sign here so if i copy paste
the formula again let me put it in this
cell
equal to i'll paste it
now if i
give a negative sign now i can edit this
instead of 4 i'll give 12 because
we want to find it monthly so
we'll convert our annual interest rate
to monthly interest rate now
and i'll multiply the npr or the number
of periods into 12 and i'll hit enter
so this is our future value or the pmt
monthly moving on
now we have a table here you can see
there have been a series of cash flow
over a period of time now using this
table
i want to use my irr and x irr function
so the irr function in excel returns the
internal rate
of a series of cash flows so if i want
to find the internal
rate of return i'll use the irr function
and
i'll select my values from
b16 to b21
close the bracket
so this is my irr value that is 22
percent
if i want to find the xir value i'll use
the x irr function that returns the
internal rate for a schedule of cash
flows that occur in irregular intervals
now
for using the x irr function i'll use
this table now you can see it has
irregular cash flows
over a period of time
so let me use my x irr
function i'll give my values ranging
from
f
22
to
f 27
comma the dates i'll give from
e22 to e27
close the bracket hit enter
this is my x irr value up next
we'll see how to find out the future
value
so for using the future value use the fv
function in excel
that returns the future value of an
investment you can use the fv function
to get the future value of an investment
assuming periodic constant payments with
a constant interest rate
also so this is my table
so we have an annual interest rate of 10
percent
years we have eight and yearly payment
we have one lakh now to find the future
value i'll use equal to fv
rate i'll give g4
which is 10 percent comma
nper i'll give g5 which is the number of
years that is eight
and yearly payment i'll give one lakh
which is g6
comma
present value
zero type is also zero
hit enter
so this is my future value which is 11
lakhs
43 588
similarly if you want to
find the present value so you can use
the pv function which returns the
present value of an investment that is
the total amount that a series of future
free means is worth now
so let me use the
pv function
i'll give my rate as 8 percent which is
g13
comma my number of periods is 5 or you
can assume 5 years
comma my pmt or payment per period is
10 000
comma
future value 0 type is also 0
so this is my present value
up next we have the net present value or
the npv function
so the npv formula or the function
calculates the net present value of an
investment based on a discount rate and
a series of future payments having
negative values and income having
positive values so you can see in the
table here
our investment has a negative value
and our incomes have positive values and
we have a discount rate of 10 percent
now let's find the net present value
we use the npv function now the rate
i'll give is 10 percent comma rules and
we could just say greater than that's an
easier way i could also go ahead and
create a new rule but then i can use one
of this option i can say greater than
and let's give some value might be we
would be interested in looking at
any value greater than 12 000 so let's
choose
12 000
and here it says what color would you
want to select so for example
i would say
something like
yellow filled with dark yellow text
and let's say okay
so right now what i'm doing is
i have all the values where the revenue
generator was greater than 10 000
but then i have also selected all the
sales
people who have made or who have
generated revenue greater than twelve
thousand
so i can just wait ctrl z to see the
previous result now here
i had the values which were greater than
10 000
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than 12 000. so this is one simple
example now we can look at some other
examples say for example you want to
format cells using three color scale so
if you look at the values here i have a
three color scale mainly in green yellow
and red and how do you do this so for
example i can go in here
and i can go to conditional formatting
so i would want to
go for color scales and here
you can create different rules so
we can set up a two color scale so we
can say format
only values that are above and below
average i can format only cells that
contain something
i can get the top and bottom values so
these are different ways in which
i can
have a three color based scale now what
i will do is i will select this
and let me show you the rule which i
have so for example i can go into manage
rules and if you see here there are
certain rules which have been specified
now what does that mean
so you would want to specify a three
grade scale
so for example if i would want to look
at my first rule
it tells me that i am choosing three
color scale i can choose lowest value
percentile and highest value and that
basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is i can
basically
use one of these values i can delete
these rules which i have created
so for example
i have all these rules
but you should always carefully remember
that the rules will be applied in the
order shown so for example if i just
delete these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now
it does not have any highlighting now i
can go in here
i can say condition sorry conditional
formatting i could go for color scales
or i could basically go into
new rule
so i would want
the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red
i can say midpoint is percentile 50
and then the highest value is green and
if that looks good let's say okay and
now if you see the lowest values have
been highlighted as red
you have mid values and then
you have the positive value so this is
the three color scale and that
easily helps me in identifying the data
based on the cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can
basically color the cells based on their
value so what we are seeing here
is if the revenue
generated
is greater than average
then that shows in green
and if the revenue generated is lesser
than average that's shows in orange now
how do we do that so we can basically
again manage some rules so i can
basically create a new rule
now here i can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option i would want to select now i can
select this and it says format values
that are above average
so
in our case we had it in green so for
example i'll say above average and then
here i can go for
a particular color
so you can go for a particular size
so
let's go and look into
the formatting
so for example let's choose yellow
say okay now i'm saying
wherever
the cell values are above average it
would be yellow instead of green
and let's go in here
let's go and look into manage rules so
this is
basically the rule which we are applying
now we can also add a new rule
and
i need to
select the values so for example i will
say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for below
we'll go for format we will choose red
we'll say okay we'll say
now
these are basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now it has not been applied so for
example if i select this and then
i could basically
choose my area just hit on enter
and similarly you can go in here and
then select your area
hit on enter and say apply say okay and
now if you see
i have really chosen bright colors but
then i have said wherever my revenue
generated is above average
it should be in yellow and below average
should be in red so we wanted above
average to be in green and below average
to be in orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up now
similarly you can also
find the top 10 and bottom 10 values and
that's pretty easy
so you can just select this
and then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items
or you can go in for more rules so you
can say format only top or bottom ranked
values so you have top 10
now you can choose the color
and for example i'll go for
blue
and
i'll say okay
so now if you see my top 10 values are
blue now similarly i can add one more
rule so i can say new rule and i can say
let's go for top or bottom
let's go for bottom let's go for format
let's say orange
say okay
say okay and that's it so now you have
your values which are top or bottom 10
values
so you are using conditional formatting
where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors
and here
easy conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also
have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing
so what
we can do is we can select our columns
either you could apply this to all the
columns now here i have applied this
only to jan and april now i could apply
this for june so let's say june so you
can go for gradient fill you can go for
solid fill
you can obviously just select the color
and that takes care of the things
you can say for example select this and
now this is selected but i would want to
might be format this so i can go in here
i can go into manage rules now that will
tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so i can just do a edit
rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill
which is color
you have no border this is basically
color as black now i can go for
something like gradient fill
and i can say okay and now if i say
apply and okay so this basically is like
your first column so you can use
conditional formatting for various use
cases
and you can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be
here the revenue is getting generated or
was getting generated but did not grow
beyond a particular value
and so on
now similarly you can also go in for
different options
say for example here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased
or say for example if the revenue was
going up for this particular sales
person so here we are looking at carol
so in jan the revenue generation by
sales was very high
then in feb it was falling down
in march it was kind of stable
then in april it went way below so we
can obviously work
on this wherein we can grade our cell
values so what we can do is we can
go in for
highlighting the cell values now
you can go for color scales you can go
for icon sets
and this is where you can choose your
different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example
i would be interested in looking at the
indicators like directional i could go
using this three arrows i can go in for
this color i can choose directional and
then
my values are
automatically
using directional now what we can also
do is we can then go into manage rules
and that basically tells me what rules
have been applied
so for example the latest one is the
icon set which i have chosen it shows
the selected columns i can obviously do
a edit rule and then i can choose so i'm
saying the format style is
icon sets
i'm not using a data bar i'm not using
color scale
now here
i have chosen the style of icons
and then here
you can basically give some values so
you have icon which is green
when the value is greater than or equal
to 67 percentage
when i say
hyphen or minus it is less than 67
it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily
highlight your cell values based on this
icon set so i can apply this and that's
how i use conditional formatting so
conditional formatting can be very
useful if you would want to use icon set
if you want to use your data bars if you
would want to
highlight particular values
if you would want to color code based on
some calculation
if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts
or people who are working business
intelligence teams or people who would
want to use excel
to easily identify the data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value
or finding out less significant or more
significant cells
to then pull out values and carry out
your computations calculations
or analysis
let's learn one more feature of excel
and that's basically your data
validation now this can be very useful
when you would want to work on
validating the data which is being fed
in the cells so you could limit it to
basically a number between a particular
value you could also add some messages
to it
if you would want
or you could even
circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered
you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed now
that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict
that the name should accept only 15
characters now how do you do that so you
can basically select the cells
or
you can just select a particular cell
and then we can later drag the property
to other fields now here
once the cell is selected so for example
let's try this out and let's see if that
works so for example i will say peter
johnson
okay and that is basically five and nine
and twelve characters so let's say
junior
and if i do this it says
input length is greater than 15 do you
want to continue if i say yes
right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then it has
basically violated the rule
now this is giving a message to the user
that the user name should be entered
less than 15 characters now how do we do
that
so for this
we can basically
select the column and then we can search
for data tab and get into data
validation so this is where you can
create or select different kind of rules
so for example i can go into data
validation i can go into settings and i
can say the text length
and
that should be less than 15 now this is
the maximum i'm giving and it says apply
these changes to all other cells within
the same settings
so i can do this or i can just drag and
drop so i can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell
is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
control data validation in this
particular column and that will allow
only 15 characters
it will pop up a message
if the user really wants to go beyond
the particular limit
now you also have similarly date of
birth
so the restriction is date of birth
should be between 10 jan 1990 to 30
december 1998.
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here i have selected date
and then date is between and then
obviously you can give a range
that is 10 jan date
1990
12 30 1998 so that's the start and the
end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up which says
enter a valid date now i can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so i can say stop
i can say invalid
entered
and this is how i have set a rule so for
example if i just do
something like this
and that says invalidate entered i can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until
i did not
give the right format the date will not
be accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well i
would want to apply this rule to
all these rows starting from c2 to c14
so let's get into data validation let's
look in settings and here
we are choosing custom
now within custom i am choosing
what is the formula so i am saying is
number
and then i am saying find
at the rate
for the rows c2 to c14 so the only thing
we are concerned about here
is the value should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done
for
error alert so for example we can
basically go in here and we can say
invalid
email
that's the title i'm giving and we can
say
email
should
contain
at the rate
so if i do this and if i say okay now
you can test it so you can say abcd
and that says email should contain at
the rate and basically that will not
allow me to add the values
so now you have the field called salary
it says salary should be greater than 50
000. now we can limit the values by
choosing
a whole number so for example for salary
i can go into data validation i can go
into settings so here i can say
something like
decimal or i can go for whole number so
both of the things are fine it depends
on what kind of values get into this
particular field so if i say whole
number and if i say it has to be greater
than 50 000
so i'm saying the minimum is 50 000 or i
could have given a decimal and then i
can say greater than less than equal or
anything or even between so i can select
it then and then i can just say okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200 so again we can use
a whole number so ranks will
generally not be decimal so this would
be whole number salary
is
can be a whole number or it could be
decimals so we have chosen decimal here
and in rank if you click on data
validation i have chosen whole number
i have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends i can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand how we can restrict the
values in a particular cell
which might be
based on a list of items
now for example here if you see i have
two columns
so one column basically has the values
of city
names and then you have places within
that particular city so if i would want
to
implement a data validation based on
this so for example if you see here city
and that basically shows me
only the four values which can be
entered and if i go to place then it
tells me for maharashtra i can only
enter pune mumbai nasik now how do i do
this so say for example you take an
empty field and you want to restrict the
values of city names
so i could
select data validation i could basically
select list
and then it tells me you need to enter
the list values that is the source so
you click here and then i can just
select these fields now if i do this and
if i say ok
it has implemented a data validation but
if you look into this
it will show me the same thing but then
it shows me some empty cells
which did not have any value so this is
fine but it would be better if we
do it in a different way so i can select
this and i've already given my city
names here so i can just do a data
validation
and here in the source let me get rid of
this
now
i can just
have my cursor here
i can select these values and then if i
say okay so now if you see my city names
have been restricted to these values and
that's how you can implement your data
validation so i have
this data validation here but i will get
rid of this one by just doing a control
z now i'll come here
and say for example i would want to
implement the same data validation now
the easiest way would be
in
doing this for all my four cities now if
you see here i have
data validation i could choose bangalore
and if you come and check here there is
no data validation but we have
implemented data validation here now how
is that done so i could select this or
for example i can go in here i can
select data validation
i can select list and then here in the
source
i will say for bangalore the value
should be these
and then
if i basically say ok
now
if we see these are the values which are
fed into bangalore
so we could do this or like what we have
done here so if you can check the data
validation rule
i have used list and then i have said
indirect f2 so basically i'm giving in a
formula which relates to the value which
is in
for the city maharashtra so we could do
this or in a simpler way we could do
this and then just drag and drop here so
we could check for maharashtra what are
the values
let's choose a different city so for
example kolkata and here i will choose
now since we did a drag and drop it has
basically taken the values of bank load
so that's not right so we select this we
go into data validation and here i can
either
feed in the values that is such as
bangalore i could basically say
something like this kolkata
and i could say okay so now if you see
it shows me the places in kolkata
now here
we have let's choose a different city so
for example let's go for delhi and here
i can go to data validation and i can
just say delhi
so this is an easier way of doing it or
if you remember the formula
then what you can do is
you can just give in
indirect
and then basically
give the
value of the cell for which you would
want to
keep in the values so this is how you
can do list validation so you can
provide a list of values and then you
can restrict the values in a cell
which should be
belonging to a particular list
so this is how you do a simple data
validation by restricting the
data in the form of a list
excel is a really powerful tool for data
analytics and reporting and pivot tables
are one of the features that excel
offers for creating tabular reports to
summarize our data
let's begin by understanding what is a
pivot table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in a spreadsheet to obtain
a desired report
it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives pivot tables are specially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually
now
let's understand the different
components of a pivot table
so there are four main components first
we have rows when a field is chosen for
the row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table
similar to the columns all row labels
are unique values and duplicates are
removed
columns
is the second component when a field is
chosen for the column area only the
unique values of the field are listed
across the top
then we have values each value is kept
in a pivot table cell and displays the
summarized information the most common
values are sum average minimum and
maximum
finally we have filters filters apply a
calculation or restriction to the entire
table
so let's jump over to microsoft excel
and let me show you the data set that we
will use in this demo so with india
being ready for its 16 census in 2021
that is next year it is a good time for
us to analyze india's last census data
from 2011 and see where different states
and cities across india stood in terms
of population literacy and other
socio-economic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin
first i'll show you one of the features
that excel offers us so suppose i click
on any cell and hit control plus q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis
now you can see by default
excel has prompted certain
features such as formatting we have
charts totals and there's one more
called tables
now excel by default has created some
pivot tables for us now the first one
you see is sum of district code by state
names
next we have sum of sex ratio by state
name
then we have sum of child sex ratio some
of male graduates and some of female
graduates by state name and there are
others before creating our pivot table
so let's have a final look at our data
set
so first column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of india
then we have the state code we have the
state name district code we have the
total population followed by male and
female population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each city
then we have the male and female
literates
next we have the sex ratio sex ratio
next we have total number of graduates
and finally you can see we have male and
female graduates so using this table
we'll create several pivot tables
now first of all let's create a pivot
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here
we have the problem statement
so our first pivot table will have the
total population
for each of the states in descending
order
so to create a pivot table you can click
any cell
in your data
go to the insert tab and here
left you can see we have the option to
create a pivot table so let me select
pivot table
now
my range is already selected the entire
table
and here i'll choose existing worksheet
because i want to place my pivot table
in the same worksheet
and i'll give my location i'll point to
cell q5
now let me click ok
you can see the pivot table fields
appears here on the right
now since we want to find the total
population for each state
so what i'll do is
i'll drag my state name onto rows
so here in our pivot table you can see
we have the different state names listed
now
we want
the total population for each of these
states
so
in the field list i'll search for total
population which is this one and drag it
under values
you can see
we have a sum of total population for
each of these states
by default
excel will sum any numeric column you
can always change it to average minimum
maximum anything you want
now we want to sort this column in
descending order so i right click
go to sort option and choose z to a
that is largest to smallest
you can see here
in 2011 maharashtra had the highest
number of population
or the total population in maharashtra
was the highest then it was uttar
pradesh we had andhra pradesh
and if i come down we have nagaland and
andaman and nicobar islands towards
the end
so this is a simple pivot table that we
created
now the next problem we have is we want
to find the total sum of literate city
belonging to a certain state so let's
see how to do it
i'll click on any cell go to insert
and here i can click on pivot table
my range is selected
i'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location which is q5
i click on ok
now here
we want to find the total sum of liters
so what i'll do is
first let me drag
total literate's column to values you
have the total sum of literates from all
the states
next i want to see the sum of total
literates based on states and cities so
let me first drag
state name onto rows and then we'll drag
city
onto rows
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
you can see we have the state names and
the cities
per state
and on the right you can see the total
number of literates from each city if i
scroll down we have assam then you can
see we have bihar
and if i keep scrolling we have all the
states haryana himachal pradesh there's
jammu and kashmir which has now become a
union territory
we have jharkhand karnataka and other
states as well moving on
okay so the next thing we want to see is
what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state
with that we also want to find the
states that had the highest and lowest
sex ratio in 2011.
so let's create a pivot table for this
i'll click on any cell go to insert
choose pivot table
click on existing i'll select cell q5
and click on ok
now
since we want
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio so first i'll drag those columns
either you can manually scroll and
drag it or here you have the option to
search for it
so if i look for child
you can see we have
the same
column listed
and just drag it from there let me
delete this
and i also want the sex ratio
so i'll place it on top of child sex
ratio
next
we want to see it based on
different states so what i'll do is
i'll take
state name and put it under rows
so here you can see we have
on the left you can see we have the
different state names
you can see we have our
column sorted now
so in 2011
kerala had the highest sex ratio
and if i scroll down to the bottom you
can see himachal pradesh had the lowest
which is around 818.
up next
let's explore one more feature of pivot
table so suppose you want to see the top
or bottom few rows
of a pivot table
you can do that as well
so here we have a question at hand
we want to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates
so let's see from the entire pivot table
how we can filter the top three cities
so i'll go to insert
click on the pivot table option
go to existing worksheet
click on q5
and hit ok
now since we want to find the top three
cities i'll drag
city column onto rows and then
we want the female graduates so in the
search bar i'll look for female
and i'll choose this column that is
female graduates and drag it
here on to values
so i have
the sum of female graduates for each of
the cities
now since we want to find the
highest in the top three cities so let
me first sort this column
i'll sort it in descending order
now we have it sorted now from this you
can say that delhi greater mumbai and
bangaluru
are the top three cities
but it's displaying all the cities for
us
so let's filter
only the top three so what you can do is
click
and go to filter
under filter you have the option of top
10 i'll select this here i only want the
top three
so either you can
go
or you can directly
type 3
your column is already selected let me
just click on ok there you go
we have the required pivot table ready
and it only displays us the top three
cities with the highest number of female
graduates
now the next thing we want to see is how
to use a slicer in a pivot table so we
have a question here
what's the total population for all the
cities in rajasthan and karnataka
so let's create a pivot table for this
and see how you can use a slicer to
filter the table
click on existing
i'll click on a location this time q6
click ok
now since i want the total population so
i'll drag total population onto values
and then
i'll select
the city
onto rows and then the state name also
as cities
but our question is we want to find only
for rajasthan and karnataka
now for that what you can do is
go to insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivot table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer i'll click on this
and since we want to slice the table
based on
state that is rajasthan and karnataka i
will choose state name
as my slicer field
you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want
the data for rajasthan and karnataka so
i'll search for
these two
so here we have karnataka so let me
select karnataka first
and i also want for rajasthan
so let me select rajasthan also
you can see in our pivot table we only
have
data for rajasthan and karnataka
so this pivot table
shows you different cities from
karnataka and the total sum of
population from each of the cities and
similarly we also have for
rajasthan
moving ahead
now we will see another very interesting
feature of pivot that is how you
can create percentage contribution of a
table
for example we have a question here
what's the percentage contribution of
male and female literates from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that
i'll create my pivot table
click on existing
and i'll select an empty
cell okay
now here since we want to find the
percentage contribution of male and
female literates
so first i'll drag
male literates
onto values
followed by
female literates onto values by default
it has summed up the main literature and
female literate's value
and also
i want to drag
state column
to rows
so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
i want to convert this as
percentage contribution so
what we can do is
i'll select any cell
and
i'll right click
and i'll go to so value as
and here i have the option to select
percentage of grand total so i'll select
this
you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates to the
total
now if i sort this you will get to know
which state
contributed or has the highest
percentage contribution
so we have maharashtra for male
literature
then we had uttar pradesh in 2011.
if i come down
we had meghalaya nagaland and andaman
and nicobar islands
as those states which had little or
minimal contribution to male literates
similarly let's do it for female
literates
i'll go to show value as and select
percentage of grand total
so you can see here also maharashtra
uttar pradesh
then gujarat and all had the
highest percentage contribution to
female literature
so this is another
good feature
to convert your data and seat in terms
of percentage
now moving ahead
let's say we want to find the bottom
three cities from each state that had
the lowest female graduates
we can do that as well i'll go to insert
click on pivot
go to existing worksheet select an empty
worksheet and click on ok
now since i want to see based on
states as well as cities so let me drag
the state name first onto rows
and let's drag the city column on to
rows
next
we want female graduates so let me look
for female graduates in the field list
i'll drag it on to values
now we have the list of
states and the respective cities
and to the right of the pivot table you
can see the sum of female graduates from
each city
now
first i'll
sort this column
i'll right click go to sort
and click on
shortest to largest
now we have sorted our female graduates
from
shortest or smallest to largest
now since i want to find the bottom
three cities from each state
i'll come to the cell
right click go to filter
and select top 10
now i'll
replace to opt-in with bottom
and i want the bottom three
cities from each state
i have my
column selected that is some of female
graduates
if i click on ok
you can see here
some of the states don't have three
cities so you can see andaman and
nicobar islands has only one city that
is port player
while the remaining you can find
the bottom three cities with the lowest
number of female graduates so andhra
pradesh had these three in assam we had
nagao then there was debrucker and
celcher
similarly if i come down in haryana we
have palval cathal and zind
if i come further here you can see for
karnataka this gangavati this ranibenur
and the scholar similarly you can see
for kerala as well
now moving ahead
now in the next example i'll tell you
how you can create a calculated field or
a calculated column in excel with the
help of a pivot table
so in a pivot table you can create or
use custom formulas to create calculated
fields or items
calculated fields are formulas that can
refer to other fields in the pivot table
calculated fields appear with other
value fields in the pivot table like
other value fields a calculated field's
name may proceed with sum of followed by
the field name
so here
we have a sales table that has columns
like the items which has different
fruits and vegetables
and those have been categorized as
fruits and vegetables we have the price
per kg and this is in terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see
if you want to find the sales for each
item in the table you can create a
calculated field
so your sales column is going to be
the product of price per kg
and quantity so let me show you how you
can do that with the help of a pivot
table
i'll create a pivot table first
click on an empty cell
hit ok
now
if you see on the top
under pivot table analyze
and under calculations we have the
option fields items and sets
if i click on this drop down i get the
option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field i click on this
i'll give my field name as sales
and
i'll select my formula
i'll first click on
price per kg and hit insert field
i'll give a space hit shift 8 to give
the product symbol
and then i'll double click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
i'll click on add
and i click on ok if you see here
there's a calculated field that is
present in the pivot table fields which
is sales but it did not add it to our
original table our original table is the
same but here we have added
a calculated field which is present only
in the pivot table list now we can use
this it has already taken it under
values
now let's say i want to find the sum of
sales for
each item
under each category
you can see it here
we have our category fruit and we have
our category vegetable
and under that we have different
items like apple apricot banana
similarly in vegetables we have broccoli
this carrots corn eggplant and others
so this is how you can create
a calculated field in a pivot table
now this one more good feature that
excel offers us in pivot table is to
create a pivot chart so you can use your
pivot table and create different charts
so i'll show you how to do that
if i go to insert
here i have the option of recommended
charts
click on this
excel
gives me some default charts which you
can use
let's say
i'll select this
let me drag it a bit to the right
here you can see i'll close this pivot
field list
this is a nice
bar chart that excel has created this is
called a pivot chart now here you can
see the category fruits and vegetables
and the different fruits and vegetables
or the items
in the y-axis you can see the total
sales
if you see
from the graph
guava made the highest amount of sales
now if i sort this
let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava made the
highest amount of sales now since i
sorted and changed my pivot table
the pivot chart also automatically gets
updated
similarly there are other charts also
that you can create let's go to the
insert tab
and
let's click on recommended charts again
let's look for a pie chart so this is a
pie chart that you can create let me
click on ok
so here is our pie chart and each pie
represents a certain item
and the pie that has the highest area
represents
it had the highest amount of seals in
this case you can see
it is guava and similarly we have other
items as well this is fruit banana
that's corn
and we have spinach and
others let's explore a few other charts
so first i'll
click on my pivot table go to insert
and under recommended charts let's now
select a
line chart
if i hit ok
move it to the right
so this is a line chart
you can see it starts
from guava
which had the highest amount of sales
then it
drops
and in the x axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables
broccoli made the highest amount of
sales with 2
800 rupees
and our lowest was
eggplant at 900 rupees
for fruits papaya sold the least at 700
rupees
let's take another chart i'll go to
insert
under recommended charts let's see
this time we'll see a bar chart now this
is
a horizontal bar chart and not a
vertical one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this
this is an horizontal
bar chart now you can always increase
and decrease the size of these charts
let's
explore
a last chart let's take
the area chart for now
so this is an area chart again it looks
similar to the
line chart it starts with guava which
had the highest amount of sales
similarly
papaya under fruits had the lowest
amount of sales under vegetables it was
broccoli
and finally eggplant made the lowest
amount of sales under vegetable now
let's go to our first sheet and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for people tables in excel so we had our
data
this is
2011 census data from india we had the
different cities the state names
and we had the total population total
literates female literates male
literates we had the sex ratio total
graduates and other information
so we began by understanding how to
create a simple pivot table
where we calculated the total population
for each state and sorted it in
descending order we found that
maharashtra uttar pradesh
had the total population in 2011.
then
we saw
another pre-vote table where we
calculated the total sum of literates in
each city belonging to a certain state
so you can see we had the
different state names and
the cities under each state
then
we saw another feature where you could
calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex ratio
after that we saw
how you could find or filter tables
we saw how to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that delhi
greater mumbai and bangalore were the
top cities with highest number of female
graduates
next
we saw how to use slicer in a pivot
table so we sliced our table based on
rajasthan karnataka state and saw the
total population for all the cities in
rajasthan and karnataka
in the next sheet
we
explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literature from each state
then
here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates and one
thing marked that some of the states did
not have three cities for example
andaman had only one city that was sport
player but the others we found out the
bottom three cities
that had the lowest female graduates
finally we looked at how to create a
calculated field in a pivot table
so we saw
how to create a
calculated field called sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw
there's a column chart we also saw or
looked at
a bar chart that was a horizontal bar
chart similarly we saw how to create a
pie chart as well
in this video we will learn some of the
important features and functionalities
of power query in excel
also we'll be doing an extensive
hands-on demonstration using various
datasets
so if you want the datasets and the demo
files then please put your email ids in
the comments section of the video
i'll team will send you the files over
email
let's begin
so what is excel power query
power query is an advanced feature of
microsoft excel that allows you to
prepare your data for analysis
you can perform numerous text
computations and numerical analysis to
make your data more powerful and
informative
excel power query is a data preparation
and transformation engine
it allows you to carry out the extract
transform and load operations on the
data sets from multiple sources
now
let's look at the challenges solved by
power query
earlier in excel there was difficulty in
data connections
now using power query you can connect to
a broad range of data sources such as
relational databases web files text csv
json files and even fetch data in the
cloud
volume variety and velocity are the
characteristics that define big data it
was a major problem to handle such data
now power query enables you to transform
your data to an appropriate size it also
allows you to work on any shape of data
from any source
earlier updating your data and
refreshing it in real time was an issue
using power query a repeatable process
query is adopted to update the data in
real time and in the future
in excel
it was not so easy to reshape transform
and manipulate data
but using power query provides a highly
interactive experience and sophisticated
tools to prepare your data now
from excel 2016 onwards power query on
windows has been fully integrated into
excel
but in excel 2010 and 2013 for windows
power query is a free add-in
you can go ahead and download the link
once installed the power query tab will
be visible in the excel ribbon now
coming to the
features of power query so excel power
query allows you to clean transform
manipulate and process your data for
analysis it helps you to automate
repetitive tasks that you want to do it
over and over again you can search for
data sources and make connections as and
when you want power query helps you to
prepare and shape the data in the right
format for performing analysis
and finally
once your data is ready you can share
your findings or use your query to
create interactive reports and
dashboards
now let's have a glance at the demo that
we are going to work on in this video
so we look at how to load data from
different sources
you will understand how to extract
tables from web files so we'll extract
tables present on wikipedia pages
then you'll learn how to sort and filter
data
up next you'll see how to group your
data how to split a column into multiple
columns and then pivot and unpivot your
table
then date columns and make some
transformations
understand how to append tables and
merge tables vertically and horizontally
now let's open ms excel and start with
importing a simple text file
so you can see here i have my excel file
opened
and in the middle you can see i have my
employ txt file
now this is a comma separated file
meaning that the values are separated by
commas as you can see it here
the columns have been separated by
commas and all the values have a comma
between them
now
this
text file has information about
the name age company and the city to
which the employee belongs to
let's see how easily you can import this
emp text file into ms excel
here
i am using excel 365 or office 365 where
power query on windows has been fully
integrated into this version of excel
so what i'll do is first
let's go to the data tab
you have this section called get and
transform data so i'll click on get data
under get data i'll go to from file
and select
from text slash csv
once i click on it it will ask me to
give the location where the file is
there
so my file is on desktop i'll click on
power query files and here you can see i
have my employee txt file
you can see the type here it says text
document
click on emp
and hit import
now this will take some time to import
the file onto excel
it's a stab areas and connections so we
have made
one query and have loaded
the employee data
it gives a preview also you can see it
here
and if needed later you can go to edit
and change some values that we'll see
later
now you can use this data to create
simple visualizations
so let me show you how to do it
so let's first select the data and
we'll go to the insert tab
under insert tab i'll click on
recommended charts
let's say
i want to know how many employees belong
to a particular city
so i'll click on the second chart which
says the count of name by city
and i'll click on ok
here you can see
we have a nice clustered bar chart
and you can see
in bangalore there were
five employees in hyderabad we had two
and in nasik we had one
you can see the count here this is a
pivot table
if you go back to our actual data here
you can see
in bangalore we had vidya
and there were
two more people from hyderabad and one
from nasik
so you can use the excel power query
feature to import data onto excel and
make some visualizations
now
if you want to fetch some data that is
present on the web or on the internet
excel power query features and
functionalities can help you import
those data as well
we will now see how to import data
specifically a table that is present on
the web
here
i'll be using a wikipedia article on the
list of european cup and ufo champions
league finals let me show you the page
first so this is my wikipedia page on
the list of european cup and ufo
champions league finals
if i scroll down you can see all the
details here
and i would like to import
this table
which has the list of
all the finals so we have columns like
season
winners score line runners up venue and
attendance
let's import this table on to excel
so i'll copy this url first
now let me open a new sheet i'll go to
sheet1
and then on the data tab
under the get data section
i'll go to from other sources and here i
have
from web which allows me to import data
from the web either you can follow this
path or
if you see here there's an option to get
data from the web if i click on this
it is asking me to enter the url so i'll
paste the url of the wikipedia page here
and let's click on ok
now it's navigating and
okay
you can see power query feature in excel
has given us a list of tables which you
can see here
we have something called as document
there's a key table and here you can see
there's one table which is extracted
from the
wikipedia page
and the table which i am interested in
is this table which has the list of
european cup
finals
you can see it here
excel power query feature has
automatically detected
these rows and it has given a
list of columns as well you can see
these are the columns
now we'll explore the transform data tab
present in the
power query
now if i click on transform data it will
take me to the power query editor
let me just
click on refresh
now this is the most important section
using the power query editor you can
clean your data filter your data
manipulate your data
and make it ready for analysis
now let's explore a few tabs available
here so we have a home tab that has
a query section
you can see you can reduce rows manage
columns sort the data transform the data
combine different tables
now there's another tab called transform
which allows you to select your data
type transpose your rows and columns
pivot and unpivot your columns
and here you can see
you can find out some summary statistics
and you can manage your date values as
well
now if you want to add some new columns
to your data you can do that as well and
you also have a view tab
now here
if you see the first two rows
the values are the same you can see
season season these are all repeated
which we actually don't need
and these are pretty similar to our
column names
similarly if i scroll down
you see there are some rows
which have null values
so actually these
rows do not add up any value or do not
add any value to our data so we'll clean
this data first
so let's see how to do it
now if you want to remove certain rows
in the table
what you can do is
go to the home tab
and under reduce rows click on remove
rows
and then choose
remove top rows
if i select remove top rows it will ask
me how many rows do you want to remove
from the top
you can see it here
i'll give i want to remove the top two
rows
now let's click on ok
you will see
that
the excel power query editor has removed
the first two rows
and on the right you can see the steps
that were applied
you can see it here
previously we had these two
rows which were redundant
and once we applied the step
it has removed the first two rows
similarly
let's go down and remove the last
one two three four five so we are going
to remove the last
seven rows from the table
so again
i'll go to reduce rows and click on
remove rows now this time i'll select
remove bottom rows
and here i'll choose
i want to delete seven rows from the
table
from the bottom
i click on ok
if you see
the last seven rows have been deleted
now let me show you the last row which
is this one
so the last season of
ufo champions league was held in 2020
which is this year
and bayern munich won the champions
league against
a french team that was paris
saint-germain by a score of 1-0
now if you see the last value that is
the attendance
q is zero which means there were no
spectators in the stadium it was because
of the covet conditions
now let's do some more manipulation to
our data
suppose this time i want to add a new
column let's say a stadium name by
extracting values from the venue column
so let me just show you the venue column
so this is our venue column
so the first value
is the stadium name
then we have the city in which the
stadium is there
and finally we have
the country name
so i want to extract only the stadium
name so you can see we have some
stadiums like santiago bernabeu
there's wembley san siro
and other stadiums so i want to extract
only the stadium names
so let's see how to do that
i'll click on the venue column and go to
add column tab
under add column here you can see we
have
extract
if i click on this drop down there is an
option to select
text before delimiter
so if i choose text before delimiter
here
i'll give my delimiter as comma
so everything before the first comma
will be considered as the stadium name
now let me click on ok
now here you can see under applied steps
it says inserted
text before delimiter if i scroll to the
right you can see the last column
has our stadium names
let me double click on this and change
this to
stadium name column
and hit enter
even this step is applied
here you can see renamed columns
similarly
let's explore a few more features
now i want to add a new column called
stadium city
so
if you consider this venue column
whatever is there between the two commas
is the stadium city
so for example santiago bernabau is in
madrid similarly
wembley stadium is in london
san siro is in milan
so these middle values i want to extract
into a new column called as
stadium city
so let's see how to do it
so i'll click on the venue column
and go to extract
and again
i'll select
the extract tab
and here now i'll choose
text between delimiters
and my first delimiter i'll give is
a comma
and a space you can see here
all the values
have a comma and a space
and my end delimiter will be another
comma
then i'll click on ok
this will add a new column
to the extreme right of the table you
can see here we have text between
delimiters
and it has extracted the stadium city
let me go ahead and rename this
column as stadium
city
and hit enter
you can see the applied step here
now
i want to split the score column into
two columns so here we have the score
column
and
the left value presents the number of
goals that were scored by the winning
team
and the right value presents the number
of
goals that were scored by the losing
team
so here i'll split the column into two
columns as winner score and loser score
so what i'll do is
select this column and go to the home
tab
under the home tab we have
split column
i'll select split column
and then choose
by delimiter
so automatically excel power query
detects that this dash is my delimiter
and i'll split at each occurrence of the
delimiter
let's click on ok
now you can see
the score column has been split into two
it has renamed the column as score dot
one and score dot two
what i'll do is i'll go ahead and
we'll rename this column as winner score
and this will
rename it to
loser score
i'll hit enter
and i have renamed it successfully
next
let's change the winners team and the
runner sub team values to upper case
so suppose
i want to change all the values or the
club names of the winners team to upper
case so what i can do is
i'll select this column and go to the
transform tab
under transform tab i have this option
called
format
so here i'll click on format and then
you can see
i can change the case to lowercase
uppercase capitalize each word
so here i want to make all the winner
teams as uppercase i'll select uppercase
there you go
we have successfully converted all the
winner team names to uppercase
similarly let's do it for the runner
subteam as well
so here i have my runnersup team
i'll go to the transform tab
click on format
and select uppercase
now we saw
how to do some simple
manipulation of our data so we created a
few columns split a few columns
now to save all this i have to go to the
home tab and then click on close and
load
this will take some time and load our
data onto this excel sheet
you can see here it's loading the data
this will take a bit of time
there you go
excel power query feature has
successfully
performed some manipulations on our data
some calculations on our data and then
it has
saved the final version
and loaded it onto excel now using this
clean data we can do some analysis
let's say i want to find the seasons in
which the winners team scored more than
three goals so we have a problem
statement at hand we want to find the
seasons in which
the winner team had more than three
goals scored
so what you can do is select any
cell in this data and go to the insert
tab
and click on
pivot table
here i'll click on existing worksheet
and then
i'll give my location
i'll place my pivot table somewhere here
and click on ok
all right
now
since i want to know the seasons i'll
drag season on to row
and i'll also drag
the winners team column on to rows
then i'll choose my winner score
under values
here you can see we have the pivot table
ready
now we need to filter this table to see
all the winning teams that scored more
than three goals so what i'll do is
i'll select this winner score column and
place it under filters
and here you can see i have my filter
let me click on this drop down
and i'll select multiple items
from this multiple items i'll choose
4 5 and 7 because these values are
greater than 3
and click on ok here you can see i have
filtered my pivot table and
left you can see the season
and the winner team
that had scored more than three goals in
the finals
all right
similarly you can perform some more
analysis suppose
i want to know how many times real
madrid won the championship so let's see
i'll click on one cell in the data set
go to the insert tab and click on pivot
table
i'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location here
let's say i want to place my table here
i click on ok
all right so the question we have is how
many times have real madrid won the
championship
so i'll choose
the winner steam column and place it
under
rows
and
let's say we'll select the winner score
as well
and let's convert this winner score from
sum
to let's say count and click on ok
and
since i want to check only for real
madrid
so what i'll do is i'll go to
the insert tab
and i'll insert a slicer
here i'll choose
winner teams as my slicer and click on
ok
and out of this
i want to choose only
real madrid so i'll select real madrid
you can see it here
real madrid have won the championship 13
times
okay
let's say you want to compress your data
and remove unnecessary columns without
losing any information you can do that
using a feature in the power query
editor called unpivot to perform this
task we'll use a census data of india
from wikipedia so let me first show you
the wikipedia page
so this is my wikipedia article which
says list of states in india by past
population
and if i scroll down
you can see it here there's a table
which says by past population from 1947
to 2011.
so there are a few columns like rank
this state or union territory and we
have population starting from 1951
till 2011 which was our last census
here you can see if i scroll further
there are
nearly 29 states and we have
seven union territories so we will
extract this table and load into excel
first
okay so let me click on a new sheet
and we'll follow the same drill i'll go
to my data tab
and click on get data
under get data i'll go to from other
sources and click on from web
here it will ask me to provide the url
link of the wikipedia page so i'll paste
the url here
and click on ok
now once i have done that
it will load a few tables
onto excel you can see there are a few
tables here i'll click on the first one
so we have
our table here
now let's do some transformation to this
data
this opens in the power query editor
okay i'll click on refresh first
this will take some time to refresh the
entire data okay we are done now if you
see this data
clearly
the first
row in this table is not necessary at
all because these are our column names
so we also have our column headers
already present
so let's go ahead and delete the first
row so we'll go to the home tab under
remove rows i'll click on remove top
rows
now i'll give my
number of rows as one so we want to
remove the first row only i'll click on
ok
you can see the first row has been
deleted
if i scroll further
i actually don't need the last row as
well which is the total
so what we can do is we can also remove
the last row from the bottom
so i'll
select one
click on ok
you can see the step has been applied
and
you don't see the last row that was the
total row anymore
so the task that i want to do here is
i want to compress
all these columns which are basically
the population columns
so i'll
select my
state or union territory column
and go to the transform tab and here i
have the option to unpivot columns so
i'll click on this drop down and select
unpivot other columns
you can see here the step has been
applied and
all the population column from 1951 till
2011 have been unpivoted if you want you
can go ahead and
rename these columns let's see i'll
write it as population column
and
let's say this is
i'll rename it to total population value
all right
now we are done with our
preparation of data let's go to the home
tab and click on close and load
now this will take some time to load the
data onto excel
all right so we have
our census data here so first you can
see
rank one is uttar pradesh and we have
the population starting from 1951 till
2011. then we have for maharashtra
if i scroll down you can see the other
states we have tamilnadu rajasthan this
karnataka if i scroll further
we have odisha there's telangana kerala
now if you see here
the population values from 1951 till
2011 for the telangana state are all na
which means there was no data available
now this is because telangana was only
formed in 2014 so there was no census
for this state
let's continue with our demo and let's
explore a few more
features and functionalities of our
query editor
now the next table we are going to use
is an adventure works customer table
now this data set is provided by
microsoft for practitioners who want to
learn power bi excel or similar
technologies and want to do some
manipulation some calculation some data
analysis stuff
so let me go to a new sheet and let's
import the adventure works customer data
set it's a csv file onto excel first
so i'll go to my data tab
and click on get data from here i'll go
to
prompt file and choose
from text slash csv
you can see it here in my power query
files folder i have my
adventure works customer table
i'll select this and click on import
this will take some time to load the
data set
you can see the preview of the data set
here so we have
columns like the customer key we have
the prefix of the customer name the
first name the last name of the customer
date of birth
marital status
if i go to the right we have annual
income total children education level
occupation and homeowner column as well
so let's click on transform data
here we'll learn a few more
features of power query
okay we have our data on our power query
editor
so first what i'll show you is
let's change the prefix column the first
name column and the last name column to
proper case
so you can see it here the prefix first
name and last name columns are all
in upper case
now if you want to change the values to
proper case
just
hit ctrl and select the three columns
and
go to the transform tab
under transform tab you have format
so click on format here you can see we
have lowercase uppercase now proper case
is to capitalize each word so i'll click
on capitalize each
word you can see it here now
we have converted the prefix first name
and last name column
into prop case
the next step i'm going to show you is
let's merge all the three columns the
prefix column the first name column and
the last name column into one full name
column
so
what i'll do is i'll select the three
columns
and then let's go to add column
and under add column we have this option
called merge columns
let's hit merge columns
okay
now it's asking you to give the
separator i'll select my separator as a
space
and click on ok
ok so before click on ok i want to
change my
new column name from merged to let's say
full
name and now let's click on ok
you can see here it says inserted merged
column and if i go to my
right
you can see it here we have a full name
column
now if you want to shift the location of
the full name column you can do that as
well
just
hold this and
keep on dragging to the left
this will move the entire
table to the right and you can place it
wherever you want so i want to place it
let's say here
okay
now actually i don't want all these
columns so let's delete it
so click on this and
i'll right click
and click on remove
you can see we have removed the prefix
column similarly let's remove the
other two columns you can either right
click and do or go to the home tab
and then select remove columns
all right
now
let's say we want to add a domain name
column from aws customers by extracting
the characters between at the rate and
dot com
so actually i'm talking about the email
address
from this email address we want to
create a new column called as domain
name for that we'll extract characters
that are present between at the rate and
dot com
so let's see how to do it
i'll select the email address column
and then i'll go to add column
under add column i'll click on extract
and this time we want to extract
between two delimiters and so i'll
select
text between delimiters and i'll give my
starting delimiter as
add the rate
and
my end delimiter would be dot com
now let's click on ok
so this will
insert a new column to the extreme right
you can see we have our domain name
let's go ahead and
change the column name to domain name
and hit enter
all right
you can see the step has been applied
now we are done with
our preparation of customers table let's
just go to the home tab and click on
close and load
so all the transformation that we did in
the power query editor
will reflect here so you can see we have
our full name column
and if you see
we have our domain name as well
okay
now using the power query editor you can
perform some statistical analysis
now let's explore those statistical
features
for this we'll be using another data set
called adventure works product data set
again this data set is also provided by
microsoft
so let's go to the new sheet and here
i'll go to the data tab
click on get data
under from files i click on text slash
csv
here you can see we have
adventure works products i click on
import
let's click on transform data
so we have our data
loaded on to the power query editor
the data is mostly clean
alter this data let's straight away go
ahead and explore some of the
statistical features that we have here
now let's see
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the product table
we have this product name column and say
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the table
how to do it
so what you can do is click on this
product name column
then go to the transform tab
now in the transform tab you have an
option called statistics
click on this drop down and select count
values
now this will open another window
that will return the total number of
products in the table you can see the
value here it says 293
now to move back to the query editor so
let's just click cancel or close
we are back again
all right
now let's say you want to calculate the
average product price from the product
table so if i move to the right
you have a column called product price
so let's see
what is the average product price from
the product table so i'll select this
product price column go to the transform
tab
under statistics i'll select average
so this will give me the average product
price which is
714.43
you can consider any unit you want let's
say this is in dollars
now then we have to cancel this step to
move back
okay
now if you want to find the maximum
minimum product price you can do that as
well
so
let me select my column
product price and go to the transform
tab
under the transform tab
will click on this status drop down
and let's say i'll select minimum so
this will give me the minimum product
price which is 2.29
similarly
if you want to find the maximum product
price so select this product price
column go transform tab
and then choose maximum
so this is the maximum product price in
the product table we have
let's cancel this step
okay now you can also round the product
cost and product price column to two
decimal places so if i show you both the
columns you have your product cost
and you have the product price column
you can see the floating values of the
decimal points are not constant it's
varying
so let's limit it to two decimal places
what you can do is select both the
columns and then go to the transform tab
in the transform tab you have here
rounding
i'll click on this drop down and select
round
now here i'll give my
decimal places as 2.
if i click on ok you can see here
both the columns the product cost and
the product price column have been
rounded up to two decimal places
i can scroll down you can see
all the values have been rounded up to
two decimal places
all right
now
let's say you want to add a column
called discount price column
by multiplying 0.9 to the product price
column
and let's see you also want to round
that new column to two decimal places so
how to do it
so we want to give a discount of
10 percent so i'll select this product
price column
goatlum
and then i'll choose custom column
here we'll write a formula
so i'll give my new column name as
discount price
and
my formula would be
i'll select product price
i'll click on insert
and then i'll multiply this product
price by
0.9
so this will give me my 10 discount
on the product price and click on ok
you see here we have our new column
added which is discount price
so
if the product price is
34.99 if you give a 10 discount
it's 31.491
all right
now the next question was to change the
or round the decimal places to two
so i'll go to the transform tab under
rounding and click on round
let's say i'll give two and click on ok
so even this has rounded the discount
price column to two decimal places
now we are done with our math before
making any english united states instead
of english india
so i'll just scroll down
and
here we have i click on ok now once this
is done
i'll go to my data type and i'll select
date as my data type
i'll choose replace current
okay now you can see
my date column has been formatted the
date tab you can see i have access to
all this
operations on this date column column
go to
add column
here under add column i have
cylinders so i'll click on this
day
let's say i'll click on close and load
now this will load
the data set on to excel you can see it
here we have the data ready now you can
use this data to make some
analysis
draw a pivot table draw a pivot chart
and do a whole lot of things now while
working on a project it is possible that
not all your data will be in a single
file it could be stored in multiple
files so it's important to combine and
bring all your data together
now we will see how to join your data
vertically
i have my data present in a csv folder
so let me show you the folder first
so this is my csv folder let me open it
and
i have some files these are named as
project one two three four and five
let me open just one of the project
files
it has a very small quantity of data
you can see it has a month column and an
amount column let me close this
and
let me show it to you again let's open
project 4.
all the files have the same number of
columns you can see this also has a
month column
and an amount column
now we'll combine all this data together
and load it into excel let's see how to
do it
so i'll open a new sheet
and i'll go to my data tab and click on
get data
then i'll go to from file and this time
i'll choose
from folder
now this will ask me to give
you can see it here it says sheet1
okay
now it's processing all the
data files present in that csv folder
and this will be uploaded onto our power
query editor
now you can see here on the power query
editor
all my
data files have been
combined vertically
here you can see
the month column
on the extreme right it's the amount
column
and to the extreme left we have the
source name or the
source file where the data came from so
first is project one
then we have project two
if i scroll down we have project three
files project four and similarly we have
project five
now this is one way in which you can
merge your
tables vertically
so we are done with it let's just go to
the home tab and click on close and load
all the transformations that were
applied you can see it here we have our
final table
and we have successfully
combined
five excel files
again
you can also join your data horizontally
this would be like an sql join where the
data is present in multiple files or
sheets
based on a common key column you can
join the tables
so you can perform a left join a right
join and inner join based on the problem
that you are trying to solve
so let's merge two tables based on a
column
i'll show the data set first it's an
excel file which has three worksheets
so here is my excel file which will be
using to
merge our data horizontally you can see
there are three worksheets
the first one is year 11 which has data
regarding the student name the gender of
the student and the course the student
had opted for similarly we have another
for 2012 or year 12 we have the student
name
gender as well as the course
and finally we have a courses
table or a courses sheet which has all
the details regarding the course
so we have the course name the teacher
who teaches or teacher who taught that
course we have the lesson type the
number of credits and the assignment
type
now we'll use this
data sets
to load it onto excel using power query
so i am on my excel sheet let's just
open a new sheet
i'll go to the data tab
and here i'll click on get data and this
time i'll choose
from excel workbook
and i'll select my file which is
students and courses i click on import
so we'll just see how to import two
tables and join them horizontally so let
me first select
the courses sheet
and i'll click on transform data
now this has loaded the courses table
onto power query editor
the table looks fine we have the course
column teacher everything is fine
now let's load
one more table and then we'll merge it
so here under the home tab you have
a section called new source
i'll click on file
i'll again select my students and
courses and click on import
and this time let's choose
another table let's say year 11 which
has the column name as student gender
and course
i click on ok
it has successfully loaded this table
onto power query editor
now if you say this
the first row is actually our
column names so i'll go to the home tab
and select
use first row as headers
so this will push the first row
to the column names you can see we have
done it successfully we have my student
name
the gender column and the course column
now let's merge it so
if you see here in the home tab we have
a section called merge queries
let's click on this drop down
and select merge queries
here
i have my table which is year 11
and let's
choose one more table
that is
courses
the kind of join
i'll choose as left outer join which
means it will take all the
rows from the first table and matching
records from the second table
here i need to select the common key
column so if you see both the tables we
have the course column as the common key
column so i'll select
this and now you can see there's a tick
mark which means it has selected the
rows and the column successfully you can
see it says the selection matches 175
175 rows from the first table
and let's click on ok
let's just expand this
and click on ok
if i scroll to the right you can see i
have successfully merged
both the tables
now if you want
you can remove unnecessary
rows or columns
suppose if you see i have the course
column
from the year 11 table and here also i
have
the course column
now this is
redundant let's just remove one of the
columns i'll just select this column
i'll go to
remove columns and i'll select remove
columns
okay
the rest looks fine we have successfully
merged both the tables by using a left
outer join
let's just click close and load
now this will take some time to load our
data onto excel you can see it here
we have successfully loaded it onto
excel
now we are done with our demo part
now let's just see
what all we have done in our demo so
i'll
go to my first sheet
here you can see
we had
imported a simple
text file first and then we plotted a
graph which is a pivot chart
then you saw
how to upload
a file from the web so here we
imported a
ufo champions league table which was
present on wikipedia and then we plotted
some
graphs and charts you can see we made
some
analysis using pivot tables
and then we imported another web file
which was based on a population data and
we used the unpivot option or the
unpivot feature in the power query to
reduce the number of columns
then
we made some calculations to our
customer table which was from adventure
works
then we used another table
called the products table here we saw
some statistical calculations and we
added a column called discount price
where we used conditional operations
and then
you saw how we manipulated
a date column
and then we saw how to append and merge
multiple tables in this video we'll be
creating two dashboards using a sample
sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email ids
in the comments section of the video our
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards
an advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding
let's jump into our demo
for creating our dashboards we'll be
using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo
so this data set was actually generated
using a simulator and is completely
random
it was not validated though we have
applied certain transformations to the
data using power query features
so this data as you can see has
thousand rows so using the simulator we
had generated thousand rows of data
similarly
if i go on top you can see
this data set has
17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have middle east and
north africa there's north america
asia
sub-saharan africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits etc
then we have the representative's name
or you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales channel column so
there are basically two channels
whether the item was sold offline or
online
next we have the order priority column
now here c stands for critical
then we have h which is for
high priority orders then we have m for
medium priority orders and finally we
have l which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column
then we have the order id the ship date
next we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which
each product was sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column
now the total cost column is actually
the product of units sold and the unit
cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally
we have created two more columns that is
order year and then we have
order month now these two columns were
actually generated using the power query
features
so we use the order date column which is
this column and extracted order year and
order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we will focus on
generating reports for revenue by order
year revenue by year and region revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate pivot tables and
po charts and format them to make them
look more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this
i'll click on a cell in my data set
and then i'll go to the insert tab
here we have the option to select the
pivot table
i click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next i want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on ok
there you go
so we have a new sheet where i can place
my pivot table
so first
i need to find the total revenue
generated by each year so what i'll do
is
i'll drag my order year column
under rows
and then
i'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see i have my pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order year from 2010
to 2017.
now
based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so i'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts i
click on this
now actually i want a line chart so i'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go
so we have successfully created our
first pivot chart
now
let me show you how you can format this
chart to make it more readable
so first
let me delete
these so i'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the
buttons present on the chart
now let me go ahead and
edit the chart title
so the title i want is total revenue
i'll type it down
by
year right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if i click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines legend and others
okay
so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total legend is gone now
let me
add access titles so we label our x axis
and y axis
so here under x axis
i can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis i'll put
revenue
okay now you can move
a bit
all right
now
let me select this chart style option
and go to colors first
here i'll select
yellow color
okay
and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this list
i want
this style
okay
now
you can also add
data labels so i'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all
so we'll format this a bit
if i click on this arrow here i have
more options
if i scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
i'll expand this
and under category
i'll select custom
now here
we'll give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so i'll write if my revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
99 000
let me make sure there are six nines
here so one two three four five and six
okay we are good to go
i'll close the bracket
i'll give a hash
give to commas
so if the revenue is greater than
9 lakhs 99 000
i'll put it in the format of millions so
within double quotes i'll write m
i'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be
0 million
let me click on add
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data
and you see here we have i'll select
custom
and
we'll use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go we
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can
reduce the font size or increase the
font size let me just show you suppose
you want to increase the font size of
the chart title so you just select it
and from here you can either reduce or
you can increase you can see now it's 12
if you want you can make it 16.
similarly you can also edit the
access labels also
by selecting the chart title you can
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as the time being
let me just keep it to the left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region and will create a combo
chart for this
so let me show you how to do it
i'll go to my data sheet
i have my cell selected
i'll go to insert and click on pivot
table
let me just click on ok
all right
so for this
i'll select
my region onto
rows and then
i'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column
all right so here we have the pivot
table ready now based on this pivot
table
let's create our pivot chart so i'll go
to recommended charts and if you see
below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the
preview of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on ok
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is the bars
represent the total revenue which is
this column
now
the line represents
the total
cost
so
let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next
we'll add
data labels so i'll click on data labels
here
okay so these are the
data labels for
the bars or
the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so i'll click on this arrow go
to more options
if i scroll down
i have number
from here i'll select custom and
i'll choose
my type that is
in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our
data
next thing we'll add
a chart title
so here i'll write as
revenue
by
region
it's actually
revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well i'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet3 also i am going to rename it as
revenue
go to the data sheet
and create our pivot table first
i click on ok
now i'll select order priority under
rows
and under values i'll select
total revenue
so this is a
very simple pivot table so you have your
order priority so c is for critical h is
for high l is for low nms you can see
the different country names and we have
the
revenue
cool
now let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally
we'll create another report which is
going to be part of our revenue
dashboard and this is
revenue by items so we'll visualize our
revenue for different items present in
the table
so if you see this
we have
cosmetics vegetables cereal fruits this
cloth snacks households and other
products as well
so let's check the revenue for each of
these items
so we'll continue the same drill i'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time i'm going to drag
item type under rows
and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different
item names and then we have the
total revenue
so let me just short this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so
you can see here office supplies made
the highest amount of revenue
followed by household then cosmetics and
fruits
meet the lowest amount of revenue
i'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts
this time i am going to create a bar
chart so this is how my bar chart is
going to look like
i'll select ok
all right
now let's format this chart a bit
i'll delete the field buttons
and i'll delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
revenue
by
items
cool
we also want to
change the
color of the bars so i have selected all
the bars i'll go to my home tab
and here let's say i want to select
green color
all right
i've edited my chart a bit now
let's
make
it 14
and i'll remove the
bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
i'll create a new sheet
and first thing i'm going to do is
i'll click on the view tab and
uncheck grid lines so this will remove
the gridlines present in the worksheet
next
i'm going to insert an image
so we'll have a background image
on our dashboard
so the way to do is i'll go to the
insert tab and under illustrations
i have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so i'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
i'll go to desktop and here i have a
folder called
excel dashboard files
and i'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image
now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so i'll hit shift and i'll drag it
all right
so you can see i have successfully
added a background image if you want you
can still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so i'll click
on insert and here
i have the option to select
a text box
so
i'll click on a text box and
i'm going to place a text box
in the middle
and i'm going to name this text box as
excel
revenue dashboard
on
sales
i'll
centralize inet
let's do some more formatting so i'll
select this text box on the top you can
see
shape format
here
i'm going to expand this
shape fill
and i'll select no fill
so
my text box is transparent now
and i'll also remove
the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and i'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to
britannica bold
and i'll increase the size to let's say
30
all right
i'll just
drag the
text box
i'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now
if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so i'll go to
insert and i'll click on illustrations
again
and select
pictures
i am going to add
this two pictures which is of a store
and a cart
to make it look
visually appealing so i'll
place the icons
here
and similarly let me just copy it
and i'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so i'll
hit
ctrl v to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see i have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have our line
charts our
column charts the combo charts this pie
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and
format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered
so let's adjust the
labels let me bring this down
similarly i'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right
this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the
white background from each of the charts
and make it transparent so let me show
you how to do it so i'll select this
chart
then i'll right click
and go to
format chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called no fill so if i select no
fill you can see the white background
is gone now
similarly let me also remove the grid
lines so i'll select the gridlines and
hit delete so i've also removed the grid
lines from here
now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so i'll select this chart
go to format
and here
i'll go to shape outline and i'll select
no outline
you see this
so we have our total revenue by year
which is a line chart
and this is completely transparent now
now what i'm going to do is
i'll place this chart over a box
so i'll go to insert and in insert we
have the option to create a shape
so i'll
click on illustrations and here
i'll choose a shape
and let me select a rectangle
so i'll just
create a rectangle
here all right
and now
what i'll do is
i'll select this and bring this to front
i'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and i'll place this
shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first i'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color and
and let me increase the transparency so
i'll
right click and go to format shape
here i'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25 percent
or let's say
20 percent
all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the access labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better
now we'll just adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so i'll go to shape
outline and i'll select no outline
you see
we have now formatted our chart
let's just
pull this a little up
all right
now we'll add
this blue background to all the other
charts so we'll first add the background
make it transparent and then we'll
convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible so
for the time being i'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens
we have nicely formatted our dashboard
so
i've added a few logos for
each of the
charts you can see the logos here so for
revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the
labels in terms of millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year and region are all
formatted in terms of millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by revenue in terms of
millions
so the way to do is you can select this
graph
right click and go to format access
here if i scroll down
you have numbers
and
under category i'll select custom
then i'll select my type as
this format which is in millions
and
you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to our
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add
date columns so if you want to see what
was the amount of sales or revenue
generated on a particular year or a
particular month you can do that using a
timeline
so
i'll select one of the charts
and then
either you can go to the insert tab and
here you can see under filters we have
slices and timeline
or
if you go to the
pivot chart analyze tab
here also you have
insert slicer and timeline option
so i'll select insert slicer here first
now it's giving me the list of
fields present in the
data set
so i'll select country
region
and let's say
we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers i'll click on ok
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have asia
this europe north america and others
similarly we have the different country
names for country slicers
and then for item type also we have all
the items that were present in our data
set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slicers to a dashboard so what
i'll do is
i'll right click
on this option
and i'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables so let me
check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on ok
all right now that we have connected
one of our slicers we'll now connect the
other
remaining slicers
so i'll right click on this go to report
connections
and i'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on ok
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer
i'll go to report connections and let me
select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have
the item type so i'll right click
go to report connections and then i'll
select
all my pivot tables
and let's hit ok
all right now let me just
organize this a bit so i'll
place my pivot tables
to the right
i'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
i'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
i'll add my final slicer that is sales
channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be
the profit dashboard i'll show you how
to add a timeline
all right
now i have arranged all my slicers
so let's see you want to find the
revenue that was generated for
an item type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
show the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for
beverages only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for
beverages item type
if i scroll down
now this chart represents the
revenue that was generated in each of
the countries only for item type
beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
india
so i have selected india here
and now you can see
my graph has changed only for
country india
you can see here it is showing only for
india now
now similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to
know the revenue generated
based on sales channels so we have two
sales channel that is offline and online
suppose you want to know the revenue
generated offline so i'll just
select
offline you can see
the values have changed so these were
the revenues generated for each of the
items only for offline
if you
see here
now these were all the
offline seals for the different regions
so
this is
our entire
excel revenue dashboard on sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied
different formatting we added
different icons then we formatted the
labels also
next we added
slicers
and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this
sheet as
revenue dashboard i'll write rev
dashboard
okay
now
we move to our data sheet and
start creating your pivot tables and
people charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table
so
i'll create
a new worksheet
this time i am going to create a line
chart
to visualize the profit for each year
so i will drag my
total profit column
to values
and
my order year to rows which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table
you can see since i have sorted this
data in
descending order so 2014
had the maximum amount of profit
and 2017 had the least amount of profit
i'll just do ctrl z to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my po chart so i'll go
to recommended charts
and click on a line chart so this is the
preview of the chart
i'll click on ok
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first i'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart
and i'll
rename the chart title as
total
profit
by year
next i'm going to remove the legend so
i'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
i'll go to style
and
this time
i'm going to select
my style type okay
and if you want you can
choose the colors as well for the timing
let's having let's have
this yellow color
next let me add the
data labels so again if you see here
this is not formatted properly
so let's go ahead and format the
data labels
so i'll click on number
and i'll select custom here
and the type i'm going to select is in
millions
and i'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right now let's move back to our
data sheet again
next
we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this i am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table so i'll
go to insert and i'll click on pivot
table
let me click on ok
since i want the country name so i'll
select country under rows and then i
have
my total profit under values
the next thing i'm going to do is i'll
just rename the row labels as
countries
and then
i'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so i
am going to select this pivot table
go to the design tab
here we have subtotals and grand totals
i'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again i'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right
now
we want to create a
map out of this the way to do is
i'm going to
select my data
copy it
i'll go on top
and i'll paste it here
using this data i can create my field
map now so i'll go to insert
here we have the option to create a
field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
i can expand this
as you can see
our map has a color scale which comes
from light gray color to dark blue color
so the countries that are in gray or you
can say light blue
have the lowest amount of profit
while the regions or the countries that
have been shaded in
dark color
a dark blue color have highest amount of
profit
i will go ahead and delete this
scale
okay
next
we need to connect this
map to the original data source so what
i'll do is
i'll right click on this map and i'll go
to select data
here instead of the previous range i'll
give my
new range now so
my new range
will be my original pivot table that i
had created
i'll go on top and click on ok
so we have our
map ready now
now if you want you can change the
color of the shade so i'll just go to
colors
and let's say we'll keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made
least amount of profit
okay
now moving on
next
we want to create
a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales channel
so for this we are going to create
another line chart
so i'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so i'll select
new worksheet
here
since i want to know the profit by year
first of all i'll drag my order year
column to rows
and then
i'll choose my total profit column under
values next i'm going to select my sales
channel under columns
there you go so we have our pivot table
here
now based on this pivot table let me
create my pivot chart so i'll go to
recommended charts
and i'm going to create a line chart
i close this
you see here
based on this
chart you can tell
the profit generated with
online
sales were actually
lower than that of offline so here the
blue line represents offline profit and
the orange line represents online profit
if you mark clearly
in year 2012 the online profit was
actually higher than the offline profit
so
let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
i'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and
add
a chart title so i'll write
profit
by
year
and
sales
channel
okay
so this is my
second report
before moving ahead let me just
rename this sheet so i'll write profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say sc for sales channel
okay
moving ahead
now i want to
create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
the profit by sales channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
i'll first
go to insert click on pivot table and
click on ok
so i'll drag my sales channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table
now let's create our pivot chart which
is going to be a pie chart
let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so i'm going to select a donut
chart here i click on ok
let's
edit this chart i'll remove the field
buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
i'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
i am going to
format this label
i'll select the category as custom
and my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
i'll write
profit
by
let's say c which stands for sales
channel
cool
finally
i'm going to create a report that will
show the revenue and profit by items
so i'll go ahead and create my
pivot table first
this time i'll choose my
total profit under values
and will also have
the revenue column
so i'll put my revenue at the top
then
i'm going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table
let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the orange line represents
the total profit
i'll click on ok
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title
i'll name it as
revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay if you want you can also go ahead
and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use
for our profit dashboard
next let's create a new sheet
and we'll get started with building a
dashboard
so i'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
we'll continue with the previous drill
so
first of all let's go to the view tab
and remove the grid lines
now
we'll
insert a background image
like we did for our revenue dashboard so
i'll go to insert
under illustrations i'll click on
pictures and select this device
i'm going to have the same background
i'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization
let's just
drag this
a bit to the right
we'll adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard
so here you can see i have brought my
revenue dashboard
and i'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
i'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right
the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
excel
profit dashboard instead of renew
now
we'll copy each of the charts that we
just created for example the revenue and
profit by items then we had
profit by sales channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard
so let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
copy this as well
similarly i'll bring the other three
charts on to my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard i have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
i have also
made some formatting for example i have
reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so i'll
select the first chart i'll right click
and i'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill i'll select no fill
next i'm going to remove the grid lines
so i'll just delete it
let me close this now we also have a
outline so i'll go to design
actually format and i'll remove the
outline
next i'm going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and i'm
going to paste it here
okay
and let me just select the chart and
i'll bring this to front
and i'll move this
to the back
next i'm going to change the font color
all to white
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
i'll do it for the x-axis as well okay
so here
i have my first
chart ready
the same i'm going to do for the rest of
the charts
ok so now you can see here
i have formatted all my charts i have
also added
a blue background
you see here i have also formatted the
y labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit
similarly here i have added the data
labels this is for revenue
some of the charts also have the data
legends so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
i've also formatted the
map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our
slicers as well as timeline
first let me show you how to add a
timeline
so i'll
select one of the charts
and i'll go to insert
under insert i have the option to create
a timeline
so i'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so excel has only
shown us two columns so i'm going to
create my timeline based on order date
so i'll select my order date column and
i'll click on ok you can see here this
is called a timeline i can expand this
now this timeline is based on months now
and if i
scroll this timeline you can see here i
have
my
order year 2010 and i have all the 12
months similarly we have for 2011 then
we have for 2012
all the way till 2017.
now you can filter this in terms of
years quarters months or days let me
just select year now
so i have
years from 2010 till 2017.
let me just squeeze this
and i'll place it somewhere here
on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so i
have selected one of the charts
under insert i'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which i want to create
slicers
so i'll create a region
let me also select
country
let's say i want
the representative's name or the
customer's name and i'll click on ok
so here i have created three slicers
let me
first
resize it and
i'll place it
on the right
support so i am going to click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here
i am going to select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here i have selected four and i need
one more which is
pivot table number 10 right click on ok
similarly let's create
or connect my region filter to all the
pivot tables so i right click
go to report connections
here i'll
choose all my pivot tables which are
based on profit
i'll click on ok
let's do it for the contract
all the pivot tables related to profit
then i'll click on ok
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so i am
selecting one of the pivot charts i'll
go to insert click on slicer
and i'll select
sales channel and hit ok
so i have my sales channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on ok
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing i want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017.
now suppose you want to know the profit
that was generated in the year 2012 so
i'll just click on
this range and now you can see our
charts only show information for 2012 so
this dot represents there was
51 million profit in the year 2012.
similarly you can see here
the profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit
each of these countries made in 2012.
if i scroll down you can see
the revenue and profit by items
now
if i select
another year let's say 2013 i can just
drag this to the right and
now you can see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online and will map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it
went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
excel has prompted
all right so this is how you can use a
timeline
now as i said
we checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
i'll send it back to the place where it
was
and i'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose
you want to check the profit made by
different representatives you can select
them one by one
let's say adam churchill
this is the
profit generated by
adam churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
now suppose you want to see the profit
by different countries so you can use
the country slicer
let me just bring this to the middle
and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart i'll
just
bring this to the front so that you can
see it clearly
okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say united kingdom you can
select united kingdom so this is the map
of united kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
united kingdom and
below you can see
the revenue and profit
for all the items that was sold in
united kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item made the highest
amount of profit in
united kingdom
now you can also select
multiple countries let's say
i want to know for france as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now i
have
united kingdom and france selected and
the other charts present
in my dashboard change accordingly now i
have my
country selected as india you can see
the map of india here
and these were the respective profit
values
now one thing to note here is this is
actually
not millions that should be in k that is
thousands so please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually k and
naught million all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is
on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables in
pivot charts and then we formatted our
pivot charts based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing
you can also change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select
another theme let's say facet
you see
the colors have changed and it looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic
you see
our chart has changed let me just delete
this okay so now once you change the
theme the
text also change a bit you can see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore one more theme let's say
this time i am going to choose
depth
and
this is more
of a
green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my revenue
dashboard and see how it looks
there you go
so since we changed our theme even our
revenue dashboard is also impacted
so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and
play with different themes colors fonts
and effects
all right
so in this demo we saw
how to create a revenue dashboard so we
created line charts this combo chart pie
chart
horizontal and vertical
bar charts
and then we learnt how to add slicers
and connected to different pivot tables
and we filtered our data to see
revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales channel
we learned how to create
a map
and lots more
let's quickly see
some more examples of doing data
analysis using excel
and for that we can
use
some inbuilt add-ins which can be added
to our excel sheet so for example if you
would want to do a descriptive
analytics or descriptive analysis on
your data say for example getting your
descriptive statistics such as your mean
median mode and so on so we can do that
and we can use excel for it so for
example you can if you are given some
data say i have temperature price of ice
cream units sold and i would want to
have descriptive statistics on this what
i can do is i can click on file
and here in file you can click on
options and within options click on
add-ins
now within add-ins you have excel
add-ins which are selected here so click
on say go for example and that shows
what add-ins are available and you can
choose which ones are you interested in
so for example i have chosen analysis
tool pack
and solver add-in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your excel so if you click on data
so here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis and here it says what are you
interested in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance
descriptive statistics you have
histogram so let's click on descriptive
statistics click on ok
now this one basically asks your input
range so while your cursor is blinking
here
also it is said
grouped by so let's give it a range so
for example i will say say temperature
now if i do this and i have selected the
heading just look at that
and now you need an output range so
let's just select this
and then you can have your cursor
blinking here
let's
select save fields here
and this is where i would want the
output now it also said what options do
you want so it has output range we can
then select summary statistics
confidence level so i will say summary
statistics is what i'm interested in say
okay and this says input input range
contains non-numeric data now why is
that because we chose temperature the
heading also so click on ok and here we
will alter the range
so this one
is our range should be
only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on ok
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here
i could basically
given a value for this so i can say
temperature
and that's my descriptive statistics for
temperature might be i can just do some
formatting
and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here
now similarly we can do it for price of
ice cream
so what we need is
we need to basically
go for data
data analysis
descriptive statistics say okay
now you need to give a range so here i
will
change my range to these values output
range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on ok
and this says output range will
overwrite existing data press ok to
overwrite data in range i will say
cancel no that's not what we want to do
we need to give a new range so let's
select our new range which is here
and now click on ok
so now we get the values which is for
your price of ice cream so again we can
basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier i can select this i can
basically do a merge and center and that
gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this
now i can go into data and i can go into
data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this b2 to b8
and this one which is h6 to h19 we would
want to shift it
might be two columns up so might be i
can just say h5
and i can manually change it to at 17
and let's say okay
and
we will basically get this and i can get
rid of this
so i can have it in the same range
so similarly so this one will have to be
renamed and i can basically say price of
ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for
my price of ice
cream and similarly we can do it for the
third column which is units sold
so we would want to have this now let's
see we can click on data we can click on
data analysis descriptive statistics so
we need to give the range correctly so
this time our range changes to units
sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if
we were selecting the heading so let's
do it in this way so in my range
in my range
let me empty this
i can basically select this which we
know
has non-numeric data in the first row
say for example i'll say labels in first
row i'm interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from h
to basically something like
j
so let's say j
and let's select these values so that
should take care of things and now you
see you have your units sold you did not
have to manually rename it
and you have basically got the
descriptive statistics so this is how
you can simply perform analysis
using data analysis here
you can basically get your descriptive
statistics for your columns and then you
can do whatever needed formatting you
need
to basically make your data look
in a
good way
now let's look at one more example of
data analysis
where we may want to look at the
frequency of values or frequency of
values occurring in a range of values so
for example if you have been given
temperatures you have been given some
pins where you would want to identify
how many values fall into the range of 0
to 20
20 to 30 30 to 40 40 to 50 and the
easiest way to do that would be creating
histogram now histogram is usually used
for data analysis where you would want
to look at different variables or say
features for example temperature is one
such feature might be there might be one
more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see
if
the increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find a relationship
between two variables whether they are
positively or negatively related or you
would want to do different kind of
analysis and in certain cases we may
want to
first do analysis on one single variable
look at the frequency of values might be
also look at the defects and for which
we can use something like pareto chart
so we can go for histogram and that
basically gives us the frequency of
values now how do we do that so we have
already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay
now i have already selected input range
so if you see here my input range is
temperature
which is also with the headings
and i have bin range which is basically
the range of values so for example i can
select this and that's my pin range i am
selecting or the option labels because
i'm using the first
row which has the heading such as
temperature and bins now we need to give
an output range so for example let's say
i would want my data here
and that becomes my output range so you
can have a sorted histogram or basically
a pareto chart
so if that's what you're interested in
looking at the frequencies for your
different ranges and here i'm also
selecting chart output because i would
want to have a visual histogram which
gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on ok
and now you get your bins
so it basically tells you frequency of
values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the value is 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20
so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we can
basically say there is 120 here
with the 20 being the maximum value and
then there is one more 20 so that's your
0 to 20 then you have 20 to 30 which
shows three values so might be in that
case i can say 26
is one thing then i can say 30
that's the second one
and then basically i can look at 22
so
basically this one does not select 20 as
the lower range but it basically selects
30 as the higher range so i do see 20 to
30 there are three entries similarly we
can see values for 40 and 50 and since
we have selected pareto or sorted
histogram that shows in a descending
order what is the highest frequency of
values within a particular range
so that shows me highest frequency is
five and then you have three and three
and then two so this is how we can
create a histogram and we can perform
analysis on a single variable
now
as discussed earlier as i said sometimes
we may
be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables
are they linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on and for that we can use the
correlation
of your data analysis add-in so for
example you want to find out correlation
of temperature and units sold and what
we can do is
we can find out that using a formula so
for example if i search for something
like
co
relation
and let's search so there is a function
called correlation which we can use and
we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me an first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select
the range of values for temperature and
then i am interested in finding out the
correlation of temperature in units sold
so let's select this
and that basically gives me a range of
values it gives me the correlation value
which is 0.2859
say ok and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation so that's the function we
are interested in you need to give a
range of value so here we are interested
in temperature and price of ice cream so
let's select temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that
let's close our bracket and here we have
the correlation value of temperature and
the price of ice cream similarly you may
be interested in finding out temperature
and units sold like what we have done
earlier
so we can do the same thing based on
function so this is same as
correlation of temperature in units sold
so i can get rid of this one now how do
i do it using the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into data we need to click on data
analysis and here you have the option
called correlation let's select this now
that basically needs an input range so
we need the range now i might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
i've selected all the columns here
we will say group by columns obviously
we need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading
now output range you can just give one
simple cell and that's where your data
will start from or you can give a new
workbook so click on ok
and that basically gives you
that basically gives your
correlation of your different variables
and what are the values and we can check
these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically
temperature
and price of ice cream
and that basically shows me 0.96149
you have temperature in units sold so
you have 0.2859
now you can also look at units sold
and say for example price of ice cream
you can look at these particular values
so if i would be interested in finding
out
what is the relationship between these
variables i can easily find using
correlation so i could be
basically writing in a formula here and
selecting what are the cells so here we
were selecting a2
and c
here we were selecting a and b now might
be i'm interested in price of ice cream
and units sold and if that's what i'm
interested in then i will give a range
of b2 to b8 c2 to c8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values
so it's very simple in excel and you can
use either the data analysis tab
and
get your correlation or you can use
formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to
get some values based on periodic data
that means
might be i'm interested in range of
values i'm interested in seeing a sample
of values for
a particular period which could be
basically
a
range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if i go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which i see here might be i want
to see say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or i
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly i would want to pick
up
say three temperature values now how do
i do it so for example here i have seven
values now if i go
for periodic sampling
the sample
or periodic sample value which i need to
give has to be lesser than the total
input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here
and let's go for data analysis
so we can go for sampling here click on
ok
and that needs a range of values so we
will select a2 to a8 now i could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case i can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row
now here we can go for
number of samples which we are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
i have seven values so what if i select
five
so for example if i say five
that means
i could just get one value so basically
when i'm saying 5 out of 7 so that's
just giving me out of 5 i want one value
so i can then just give an output range
so here i can basically select this cell
i'll say okay and now you see
it just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is i've
said five it has given me the fifth
value that's your periodic sampling so
for example we want more values so let's
reduce this period
to might be 2 which basically gives me
every second value so i can basically
say for example 2 and say ok
and then
say ok so that shows me
26
then you have 35
then you have 40 and then well this one
does not have any more values so that's
your periodic sampling now if you go for
random sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis go for sampling i'll
go for number of samples how many you
want so for example out of seven values
randomly i want three values
and i can just give this say okay
and then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range so let's select this
and say okay and that gives me random
three values from this
values of temperature so we can use
excel to do a simple sampling and we can
choose whether we would want to go for
periodic sampling or
random sampling let's continue learning
excel and how excel can be used for data
analysis now we have seen
sampling histogram correlation
descriptive stats and now also let's
look at regression now what is
regression so when you talk about
statistical modeling regression analysis
is used to estimate the relationship
between
two or more variables and basically we
would want to look at
two or more variables
and
basically a relationship of those
variables with the response or the
target right so for example if we look
at our data here we have temperature we
have price of ice cream and then we have
units sold and we can
go ahead and make predictions so for
example when you look at regression here
you see something like this which is
regression statistics
you have anova
you have different plots which we have
here which is x
variable x variable 2 and then you have
normal probability plot now we have
already seen how you can
have your add-in that is data analysis
which helps you in doing different kind
of data analysis here right now how do
we do this so we have our variables here
which is temperature price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression we need to understand which
one of these are
independent variables which one of these
are dependent variables right so when
you talk about your x
that's your independent variable or we
can say predictor or explanatory
so when you talk about your independent
variables or as we say predictors
or explanatory variables these are the
factors that
might influence the dependent variable
and when you talk about dependent
variable that's your response or target
that's the main factor you're trying to
understand or predict so we can plot a
scatter plot to see relationship between
variables
if they are linearly related are they
positively related
negatively related and so on we can also
get values such as r square which is
coefficient of determination
regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so
here is one of the links of one of my
edits other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
spark
now here let's see how do we do this in
excel so basically we would want to use
our variables which is temperature price
of ice cream units sold
and then get these plots so what we can
do is for example i can get rid of this
and might be i can just say
no borders
and
when it comes to these plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal
using your data analysis
add-in tool
so we have been given variables here now
as i said when we talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have
multiple variables right so you might
have heard of univariate analysis
bivariate analysis and so on well
here we are focusing more on using excel
to do our regression analysis so i will
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things
as basics should be known that when we
talk about regression analysis what does
it do it helps you understand how the
dependent variable changes
when one
or more independent variables vary
and
it basically allows us to mathematically
determine which of those variables
really has an impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so
mainly the goal of the model is to get
the smallest possible sum of squares and
draw a line that comes closest to the
data so that's what we mean by our
regression line or basically looking at
the points
and seeing if the points fall on a
regression line if there are residuals
that is points which do not fall on the
regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about
statistics we differentiate between a
simple and multiple linear regression so
you have something called a simple
linear regression
models
which basically gives you the
relationship between dependent variable
and one independent variable using a
linear function and if you use two or
more variables that is explanatory
variables to predict the dependent
variable we are actually dealing with
multiple linear regression
so if the dependent variable is modeled
as a non-linear function
because the data relationships do not
follow a straight line
we have to use non-linear regression
now what we will do is we'll see how we
can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this
might be based on temperature price of
ice cream we would want to find out how
many units were sold now what we can do
is we can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert
you can then choose the kind of plots
which you want and here you have
insert scatter plot so we can choose
this and you can choose the first option
so that gives you a blank layout and
what you can do is now you need to
select data so for example let's click
on select data and then you can say add
so what we would want is we can give a
name so we want x values and we want our
y values right so when you talk about y
that's your dependent variable or your
response or target so that is in our
case units sold and x values are one
set of features or variables or multiple
variables so here i can click on this
series x values and then i can
select this
now in y values what i can do is i can
select these
and then i can just say okay
so that shows me that it would be giving
me a
regression scatter plot
now let's say okay
and we have some points plotted here now
if you would want to see the impact of
one individual variable such as
temperature or price of ice cream you
could as well do that now what you can
also do is you can add more meaning to
this
by giving in a title or you can also go
into quick layout and you have various
options here so you see it gives you
what is the access title what is the
series
and i would prefer to use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your r square and that gives you
your y and x that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change the chart title to something else
a scatter plot
of
dependent
uh was independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning
and
we can get rid of this one so we have
series and we can say what are these
points if you would want to add in
legend if you would want to do that or i
can just get rid of this
and
i will keep these values here which we
will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always
compare these values so here i have
created a simple scatter plot
and then i can look at dependent ways
independent variables
or i could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis
so basically you can here
say for example just say y
and might be here i will say
x and we can rename that later
now
how do we perform data analysis or get
into regression
right now what we would want to do is
we would want to get
or we would want to do the regression
analysis to demonstrate the relationship
between
dependent and independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation you might have known
about it so it is basically y
when you say y
equals
you can say
b x plus a
plus c
and this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression when
x
is your independent variable
y
is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected
mean value of y
when all x variables are equal to 0 so
basically on a regression graph that's
the point where line crosses the y axis
and that's your intercept
when you talk about b that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as x changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your uh
sorry that's basically your random error
term right which is basically
the difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise
right now what we can do is we can also
reduce this
equation to
y is b x
plus a
and that's the equation of a line we can
look into this and the linear equation
can be understood mathematically in this
way now how do we do it in excel so what
we can simply do is
here let me
[Music]
yeah
so we need to get into data and then
here we have our data analysis add in
you can click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression
so that's what we would want to do now
we'll say okay now here you need to give
your input y range so as i said you will
have to select
the dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your x and y
so y being your target
that's basically your units sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to x either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so i
will select temperature price of ice
cream
and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels
right
now we can always look at the confidence
level we can change that
so you can say whether you want it in a
new worksheet or you can just say output
range and i will probably
just click here and select one of the
cell here
now we can also choose the other options
which we would want to see as a part of
this regression analysis
so basically we have selected input y
range which is your dependent variable
you have selected x range which is your
independent variable and if we are
building a multi regression model then
we
have
chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range which is basically on this sheet
and then we can select the residuals
so that basically gives you
your residuals now we can also get your
line fit plots which you were seeing
earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots
and then basically just say okay
and
let's say okay
and that basically gives you
your regression analysis output
so we
basically have your summary output
we also have anova
we have our serial output that's from
the previous one
and basically we can get rid of this
that's not required
i can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have our plots so we
can basically look into these
so we have our normal
let's get rid of these
let's get rid of this let's get rid of
this
and then what we can do is
since we had some existing data
it has overwritten so let me get rid of
this and i'll repeat this step again and
let's say water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do a reaction analysis
so we go get into data we get into data
analysis we choose
regression we have already chosen our y
range which is column c
x range is multiple variables we have
gone for labels
output range which we would want to
select a particular cell
so let me select this
i am going for residuals line fit plots
and normal probability plots and say
okay
so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah
and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature here the variable is price
of ice cream right so that's your one
variable and second variable and then
you also have your normal probability
plot
now to interpret this
or to understand what we have here where
we look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at multiple r value here
and we can
let's also fine tune this one
here
we have our values here and if you see
we have our r square now we can then
basically look at
our multiple r so what is your multiple
r that's your correlation coefficient
which basically measures the strength of
linear relationship
between two variables so
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient
it can be any value between -1 and 1 and
its absolute value indicates the
relationship
strength
so
the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so 1 basically
means a strong positive relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and 0 means no relationship
at all
now when you are looking at r square
that is the coefficient of determination
which is used as an indicator of the
goodness of the fit
so it basically shows how many points
fall on the regression line
so your r square value is basically
calculated from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now
when we talk about
looking at the value of your r square so
it is basically we can be
seeing
that this is 0.450788
that's the value which i am talking
about so it basically means
45 of our values fit the regression
analysis model so in other words
45 percent of dependent variables that
is your y values are explained by the
independent variables that is your x
values
so
normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit
and here we have considered multiple
variables now when you talk about your
adjusted r square it is the r square
adjusted
for the number of independent variables
in the model
so
you would want to use this value instead
of r square for shows the precision of
your regression analysis so the smaller
the value the more certain you can be
about your regression equation so
when when we talk about your r square
that represents the percentage of
dependent variables variance that is
explained by the model and standard
error is basically an absolute measure
that shows the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into regression
statistics
terminologies to basically understand
more of this and if you're already from
data science background that
then you already know what i'm talking
about we are just seeing how excel
easily helps us in doing these things
now
we can also look at observations here
which is basically the number of
observations in our model which is 7.
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your anova values here
so we basically see df you have ss
ms f and significance f
now to understand these
so basically what we are doing is or
what excel is doing is it splits the sum
of squares into individual components
that give information about the levels
of variability within your regression
model so when you talk about your df
that's basically the number of degrees
of freedom
associated with the source of variance
you have sum of squares that is your ss
so smaller the residual ss compared with
the total ss
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about ms that's
your mean square you have f is basically
the f statistic
or you can say
f test for the null hypothesis
basically it is used to test the overall
significance of the model and then you
finally have your significance f
which is the p value of f so
uh when we when we usually talk about c
simple linear regression the in anova
part is
not
really used or it's rarely used
right but when we look at the
significance f value that gives an idea
of how reliably
or statistically significant our results
are so if significance f is less than
0.05
that's five percent our model is okay if
it is greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at so you basically have
your intercept here so when you talk
about your intercept
temperature price of ice cream so we
know we are looking at our variables and
then we are also look at looking at our
intercept which basically gives you
more details on your coefficients
so the the main important thing when we
talk about regression analysis
is basically your coefficients it
basically enables you to build a linear
regression equation
uh in the form of y equals bx plus a
which i explained earlier
and then basically we can understand
our regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have it shows what
is the predicted units sold and then it
also gives you your residuals
so we can compare the estimated and
actual number of sold umbrellas based on
the observation
so we have 11.20
here and if you compare that's basically
12
the second one is 15 and here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of actual units sold
and what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these
and
we will see if there is any difference
or no
right
so
obviously there will be or there would
be some difference because independent
variables are never
perfect predictors of your dependent
variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values
so that's what we see here in the
residual section
so for example when we look at this one
which is 11.209
and the actual is 12 we see what is the
residual and how far
is the predicted value from the actual
value
so
similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our graphs
so we have basically our variables
we are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically
add in more details to this particular
plot and you also have normal
probability plot which is basically
getting
your values from your probability output
here so this is how you can perform a
simple regression analysis and now what
you can do is you can as i said
you can basically be looking at your
scatter plot you can be looking at your
y and x and your r square values right
but remember what are the variables
which you are selecting
and then you can compare these
with basically the values what you see
here
so remember here i've chosen
my both set of variables
and you can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target so
it's pretty simple here you can
add more details to your scatter plot or
the plots what we have created
or
some people prefer to do it using
formulas
so
basically we have some statistical
functions that it can help you do linear
regression analysis such as
you have
lines you have slope you have intercept
you have correlation and so on so
basically
you can use these particular functions
and what you will have to do is
you will have to
basically go in for a function if that's
what you would want to do and then you
can search for functions
and say for example i'll just say nest
and say go and here i have my function
so if i would want to really use this
one i can do that what i will have to do
is then select the variable so if you
just say okay and that basically says
your known y's known x your constants
your stats and basically you can use the
formula also but we are not covering
that here might be in the later videos
we can do that so just try out and
perform some regression analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of performing
regression analysis
using your data analysis add-in in excel
in this tutorial we will be talking
about macros used in excel and also the
visual basic application programming
for macros so what is excel macro you do
certain daily tasks and daily reports or
monthly reports that you generate and
you use data from your excel and use
scrub data and you basically have the
same things performed or done on the
excel sheets
every time and every
day or monthly or bi-weekly or any
number of times that you open your excel
you
remove certain columns you add certain
things and you
change certain values and
these are the things that you do
an n number of times on an excel
and this can all be done
by simple automated
way which is macros so what it
does is it is a set of tasks that you
can execute as many number of times as
you want
when you create a macro basically what
it does is it will record all your mouse
clicks and keystrokes
basically if for example you have your
monthly accounts report that is there
and it comes every day and you have to
put it and
extract certain data and remove certain
columns
that you do every time that you open
that sheet for instance you remove that
column i
which has the
obsolete values offer of your accounts
or the sheets
that you have and you remove that column
and you edit some names you add such
things every time that you open that
report and then you format it in a
proper way and send it to your
management so this can all be done
in a simple
running script called macros so what you
do is you record those
mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically a
set of codes or a task that you can
execute and automate and it can be done
a number of times
so
it makes your life easy
now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your excel
it's a simple uh tab that you need to
add
in the ribbon section which i'll be
showing you across
and this will enable the macros on your
excel so you go to files
go to options
and then you need to customize a ribbon
click customize ribbon
and then there is a developer tab which
you see here it should be activated so
you just need to select that
click on the
tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macro so now you
you have your data and you can run
macros or record a macro and run it
on your excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon
customize ribbon and you can
add or remove
your macros from here so this is two
ways that you need to that you can
activate your macros so how you record a
macro is the next thing
so here i have a work orders sheet that
i receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and how you record a
macro you have certain set of tasks that
you do
and
you know this report has so many things
that are obsolete which you do not need
which has to be put across to your
management or your
for your use so how you record or
start a macro you go to the developer
tab and start recording a macro as soon
as you click on this record macro button
it will start
recording your keystrokes on the mouse
mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do
so
this is the sheet that i have
and
we'll try to run macros on this and see
what it does
so here i have and
this actually works this way
i need to go to the developer tab and
start recording a macro
so when i click a record macro it
starts uh recording my mouse clicks and
keystrokes so in this sheet i have to
you know remove some columns and
the columns that are obsolete and the
data that looks uh
weird here should be removed and all
what i need is the work order number the
district and the tactician name and the
kind of service that we provide and
the
requested workday
the cost
and the payment so this is what i want
and i do it every day when i receive the
sheet and i have to
make these changes and
send it across to the accounts team
so what i do is i simply
automate this by running a macro
so
i go to
let's see how it records the macro
i click record macro i save it as work
order
accounts
and i'll add a little description link
work orders
for
account
cost
click ok
in
see what i do is basically i
add the borders first
so that the data looks proper
and then i do not want this column i
delete it i do not want the number of
technicians that are there
i do not want all these and i also want
the labor hours the account and what
kind of payment this is very crucial for
the economy i do not want any of these
obsolete data
so i just delete this
okay
and then
i just want to have some cosmetic
changes done so
i make sure this
doesn't have any border
and
that's it this is the task that i
perform
every day i still don't need this
and i go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now i have the macro
save
and when i have it i have
you know automated these all these steps
in one simple click
and how i execute it in another sheet so
i will show it across to you
the next thing so here i have the next
report that has to be
changed or formatted and send it across
so i simply go the next morning and go
to the developer tab
and
go to the macro and i have this macro
save which we ran the just now and i
simple with a single click i will be
able to do these daily tasks
and execute in a flash so i just click
run and it does the rest for me i have
my report ready and is in a proper
format that is required and it can be
sent across so here as we see it is done
in a single click by running
a simple macro continuing our
work on macro we can simply do this by a
single click of a button by adding a
button so what you have to do is go to
the developer tab and in the control
section you will see the insert option
when you click on the insert drop down
you will see
form controls and you can say select a
button
and here i select a button
and the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro
and when i just
assign that macro to this button
i can edit the text by
making it as
work order
accounts just to make it simple
okay
and
now if you see if i just click this
button it will run the macro
and format our sheet
so this is how we
run the macros in a single click of a
button by adding the button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros you can record and
you can edit your mac
so when i click view macros it will show
you what are the macros that i have and
that i can run
and you can simply run it
alternatively
and you can record a macro as well
instead of from the developer tab if you
just click on record macro it will do
the same functions that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have
to use a simple application in excel
which is the vba visual basic
application to edit your macro you go to
the developer tab
and then click on visual basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on
and you can edit the
macro here
so as we see
if you go back to the excel
we see that
our sheet we have been working on
the sheet and it has the column still k
and the actual sheet is this
so if i go to the visual basic editor
and
i'll make sure they know i remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m
and i just delete that
and i click
run
i go back to my sheet
and you see
these changes are not there
okay
this is your old
macro and this is our new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority
of my orders
so these are the things that we can edit
with the vba
what is vba visual basic application it
is basically a visual basic application
language uh that is used for macros in
excel
so what it basically does visual basic
for application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate task by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily tasks
by running a simple macro
now to help us
you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our
abilities to
ease our work and automate our task we
use vba
so
why vba there are many advantages of
using vba and why we prefer vba in
macros for excel
so basically it is a very simple
language it saves time in
performing tedious tasks you have number
of tasks that you do every day as we
have seen in the previous section
how we uh you can simplify your daily
task by just running a simple macro and
this vba helps us in performing those
steps
in a very simple manner
another thing is it supports
english like statements there are
multiple statements that you can use and
which are very basic english language
statements
and this can help us or it is very easy
to program or
code or edit these commands you can
select the range you can it is like a
if an else statement
and things like that we will look into
those in details in the next sections
now one more thing is it improves the
functionality of excel by allowing you
to make excel behave the way you want
there are multiple functions that you
perform in excel like selecting a number
of rows or columns or selecting a set of
cells
in particular you do it on a daily basis
so these things can easily be performed
and easily be edited and executed by
using vba
we will look into those in detail now
what is the vba editor interface this is
particularly uh
an interface which you will have
look in detail
where where you can edit your commands
or your codes for your excel
now how this is achieved we will see it
here
now these are the this is basically the
vba editor interface where you can see
the uh
this is the toolbar section where it
shows all the options where in undo or
save or file they will see those details
in the next section this is basically
the toolbar section of the vba editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important uh menu
bar option
and when you can insert different
modules and buttons and all we'll look
into those in details run is one more
important thing all these things fall
under menu bar
the next thing is the vba code window
maybe a code window as it says is the
code window where your actual code
resides
wherein you can go into it and edit the
code or write the codes and select the
different range of functions that you
can perform and this is basically the
bdb vba code window
where you
edit your or write your codes
the next thing is the project explorer
project explorer is simply like a
windows explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your
vba
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the
the excel sheets or the worksheets that
you're working on or the modules that
you have saved and so on basically it is
an explorer for your vba like a windows
explorer which is for the file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties windows shows you the
properties of the worksheet that you're
working on
for instance here we are working on the
sheet2
and it shows the properties what are the
kind of
[Music]
worksheet that we have the page breaks
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that
the next thing is the immediate window
and the
watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool
or a window wherein you can run and
execute simple
lines of codes individual excel code
that you can run it will allow you to
test individual lines
which is very useful and handy when you
are writing and debugging codes
the output if the
lines that you execute can be seen here
in the immediate window whereas watch
window watch window is similar to it but
it displays the value of the watch
expression in its current current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the vba code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see
the use the
advantages of having a watch window
in your
vba interface
so these are the things that we'll learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
visual basic for application
for macros and
uh i'm going to show you how to
you know run some codes and run some
macros and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the vba for macros
so
there are two ways to
open the visual basic application
and the first thing is you can run alt
f11
click on the sheet and then just press
and it will open the
visual basic for application window or
alternatively you can just go and click
on the video basic and it will open the
sheet folder i mean the code window for
you and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window and this is the
project explorer
and this is the immediate window
i will you can run some
testing course immediately it will show
you the output so here we see the
project explorer window where we see the
modules
for our visual basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see
how the code develops okay so i just go
here and click
record macro
and i save it as
a format
and
columns
okay
this will woodwork and i just save it
click okay
and it has started recording so now what
i'll do is
make it simple and i just delete some
columns here
okay
i do not need this
i delete this derivate i want this i
want the amount of payment parts cost
labor hours i do not want this
number of technicians forget it
okay
and i go for the left and see what all
do i need i need i don't need this
i delete all these and
i just expand this so that it's clearly
visible and then i want to change the
format i mean the hot
so
i select this
[Music]
and i change it to time stream
okay
go back to my
developer tab click stop recording it is
saved
okay
now i go back to my
code
and see
the
macro here
so we see the macro here and
we can see
in detail what it looks like so
we see the code what it's doing and what
the macro
run has generated the code with so we
see we have basically the name of the
macro is format columns
and what it is doing we're just
selecting the columns and
deleting some we're checking the range
on some columns ee select that is the e
column that we have selected
and then again so on
and
the next thing is the font selection
that is mentioned
we are changing it to times new roman
size is 11 so
it is basically
a basic vba code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with m sub so this
is the code or format of the vba code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
vba and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation i have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and
i'll try to explain some basic uh
functions and
the commands and the codes that we use
to
accomplish the
task that we with vba
so as we see this is a blank sheet and i
have selected a new module for it
so here i uh start the code and as it
says it starts with sub and
i am specifying the
the module name as
number so i'll just try to make it quite
simple and
you know so we as soon as we enter the
sub it sends with the end sub and so
this is the
start of the code and this is the end of
the code and whatever is there should be
here and this is the name of the
code or the macro now
i'll explain it further about the temp
statement why is it used and what is it
used for
so dim is basically a keyword which is
the
short form of dimension and it is used
to declare variables in the vba so here
i am trying to specify
a variable called x and how i'm going to
do it i
will
have it as a number or an integer or
anything so here in this example i'll
put it as an integer or a number okay
and as i put as it populates
the prompt so i select integer
and for example i select the number to
be
500
okay
and here i'm trying to assign a
variable integer
a cell a value of
500 with a
keyword
so where exactly i want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay
range i am selecting
it should be under course where i'm
going to put the
value of x as and i close the bracket
and
what should be the value
we will value should be x
so now as i click
run sub
or you can do it with the
by running the alt or f5 key and it will
run the code so you see here in the
excel sheet it executes the value
of the cell b5 to be 500 so this is one
simple function that you can do
with the
dimension keyboard or dim keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed we proceed further with
certain
more examples some more examples and how
we assign the string value as a as a
text or
something else okay
now i'm going to show you what dim can
be executed
used as to set variables thing can be
used as
a double
when double is basically a longer form
of single variable it usually takes more
space but uses uh needs more larger
numbers okay and then you can
set double and i just don't specify it
and we can use date
it basically stores the date values okay
and then again string so what string
does if you use string it stores the
text it can contain numbers it will have
some text as calculations or anything
can be performed so these are the basic
thing that i will cover
and
you can also use different
values for it so i will discuss this in
the next example
okay
[Music]
so in the next example i'll try to start
or use a string value for it and
i put it as a string
sub string
[Music]
value
[Music]
this is my name so as soon as i hit
enter it ends with the answer prompt and
now i can give my code
so
i put it as dim book as
string
okay
now
i'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value
of a country to one of the
cells so
let's see
how it goes and
i select country
and in country i select
mark
[Music]
okay
now what is the value or the cell that
basically takes the or we will put the
name of the country at so i have to
specify a range and as soon as i hit
it goes and i have to specify the
the cell
here so here i put it as g
and uh
okay
so i close it
and i put a value what value i am going
to assign it is a country
okay
now
i'll try to run this code by simply
and see
g4
the name
populates as a country here so
this is a dim keyword you being used as
a string in our vba code
so
we can also use
vba to you know pop up a message or an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be uh
executed using uh
the
code here which i'm going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
[Music]
i'm going to name it as double value and
again the name keyword i'm going to use
the
keyword as double
okay y double is used is basically uh it
gives a longer it can be used for a
longer form of single variable takes it
usually takes more space and larger
numbers and we'll try to assign it okay
now i'm going to pop up a message in
this which says value of a is so and so
so i'm going to give value of a as
250
okay
and how i it pops up a message okay
so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value i mean uh it will
prompt you to enter the value what kind
of uh button you want and
you you can enter the text and you can
enter very so here i'm going to
write a code which
you know which gives a pop-up message a
message box saying that the value of a
is signed so
that you call a
i'm going to put it in percent
code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay
now that's it
and let's try to run this and you will
see a message by popping message box
popping up
okay so the value of
the message box
pops up saying the value of a is 250
so
in the next example i am going to
write a code wherein you know you can
give a value or a string you can assign
it to a selected cell and this basically
used when you
have some
you know when you have a
task of you know giving a value to a
particular cell or you have to assign a
text
or say something about a report okay so
this let's see how it goes and we use
the
i will say
it as
fun with some procedures
[Music]
this is the name and
again name
so here i am going to i'm going to give
a user input and it will be as a
string
okay you can give anywhere i mean any
string or any statement what my user
input will be i will define it here
[Music]
because
this
is the
report
for
vbq
let's make it simple
okay
and where i'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell
that i
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
i have defined user input as this is a
report for vba so this cell turns into
you this is a report for vba
i run this
and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and
you know it makes life quite simple when
you use vba
as we have seen before we have used
message box now i'm going to use the
same message box
to
display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes
i'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your
name
and i'm going to put it under course
that my name is
[Music]
and we'll try to
run it
see here
so it pops up a message saying that my
name isn't fun so this is a message box
that you can display and i can do
anything with this
[Music]
this is
[Music]
okay i run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you
open an excel sheet or try to run a
workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or
you know define
report or kind of
data in it and this can be used using
run using the message box
now i have another good example wherein
you know you can write a code to
tell excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so
here it is
i put this up
okay
number
and
it will again
populate a message box
which
will set it to
the the entered
[Music]
value
is
and it should tell me
which or i specify
which cell it is that we are going to
find the value of okay
so i give a range
of
i have to give it in codes
i'm going to
code completed
and it should tell me the value
of the number that is present in the
cell
a1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
i can change it to
a
4
as well
and try to run it and it will give me
the number so
this is simple way of you know
populating a message box which will tell
us the
value of it
let me show you one more simple example
where in a message box pops up on a
welcome message that can be pop set when
you open the uh excel or worksheet so
so let's
name it as auto
open
and then
again message box i want it to populate
and
what does it say
i put it in quotes welcome
to our
worksheet
of workshop
[Music]
it's very simple you just run it and
[Music]
see
it pops up a message saying welcome to a
workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or to simple
welcome message on
excel
next i'm going to show you a code
pairing you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
[Music]
curve
so we name it as add value
now i specify the range i mean where
i am going to specify a cell
where
the value will be given to the
cell
i'm going to
give it as v5
okay to put it as codes
close the parenthesis
is the value that i'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0
okay so now with this code i mean i'm
going to assign a value of 250 to the
cell b5 let's see
run it see
again i do it to b10
okay so this is how you can assign a
value to a particular
cell
now i can run uh the same thing and give
a range of cells i mean
let me make it very simple here
p
i give it as
b one
through
b
five
as
four five zero so
let's see what it does
see here i'm going i'm specifying the
range to be b1 through b5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay
and
then i can give a another set of range
here
like let me specify it
range to be
[Music]
c
one
i have to give it a course
it will give me an error symbol colon
c4
and i separate it with a comma and i can
specify another range so the next one
will be d1
to
d4
and then i close the codes close the
parenthesis
what is the value that i give is
let's say
2 3 0.
and i try to run it
so it gives the value
of c1 through c4 and d1 through d4 as
230 as we specified it in the
so this is one of one more example where
you can assign values to the
uh
so range of cells or cells and with the
vba
one more thing i can uh
you know assign a value to a particular
cell by specifying these cells it's a
very simple
just specify the cells like
six
comma
7
okay
and
i close the parenthesis
i assign a value to it
value equals
10.
let's see
see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
row six
and column sub
okay
so this is one more example wherein you
can assign values to particular cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario wherein you need to select
a
range of cells in your sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using vba
so i will show you how
this is our
let's say select a
range
okay and
and i am going to set a dim
variable as
example
okay let's say it has example and
what i'm doing is i'm specific range
because i need to select a range of
cells okay
now i'm going to set the variable as
set example where i'm going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected
so let's say a
1
to
t
5
okay this will be the
selection
and what i'm going to
set the value okay i am going to set a
value
example
i'm going to give it a value of
256 so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here i'm selecting a
set of
cells a range of cells and i'm going to
assign a value
with this function so this makes it
quite simple and this will be used in a
regular daily task when you know there
is there will be a scenario where you
have to select a set of cells and give a
give a value to it so you can do it with
a click of a button with the vpn
now i can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so
there is
i'll remove this
and
instead of assigning a value i'll just
put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then you see it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or cells with these
codes
now what if i want to do a selection of
the same
rows and columns in the next sheet
and i can do this with the
set of another set of commands so i will
show you how
so here let's say you know we said the
same thing
and we specify the worksheets okay
worksheets
i want it in sheet2 okay so i just put
it as g2 and i activated basically
activating it and now i am going to
specify the worksheet
to
and what is the range that i'm going to
select the same thing okay
the range will be
a1
to
d5
what i'm going to do i'm going to select
it
okay
and see what happens here
okay okay
so here i am selecting the worksheet too
i'm activating it and i'm going to
assign range and i'm going to select it
so i can just
copy the same or select the same set of
cells
in the next sheet
okay now when
there will be
a as i said there will be you know by
requirement where you need to copy some
cell contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that it's uh
again a simple
code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a
copy
and paste i'm just making it simple
by giving something that we can
understand and relate
[Music]
okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select this range
and i'm going to copy it and paste it
somewhere here okay
so let me just remove this
and
i'll show you
first we have to specify the range where
you want to copy
the cells okay so let's say it is again
a1
it should be in course
okay that's
five
course
and i am going to select it okay
then
what i am going to do is
once you select this the selection that
you have
should what should be the function and i
am going to specify the selection
and the function should be copying it
okay so i just
said that
and where i'm going to paste it so i
have to now specify the range
where i have to
paste this selection
and you can just mention the
column here let's say
g
10
okay
and close it
i'm going to select it
and then where i'm going to paste it i
can do it in this sheet okay
active sheet
and
paste it
so we are selecting a range of cells
selection
and that selection what we are doing is
we will copy it
and now we are going to specify the
range where you are going to
select it and then
paste it
quite simple
let's see
okay
okay
and
you can just change it so it is visible
on this
okay
so
this makes uh quite easy
and you can run it
the next scenario will be like
when you need to
get the count of the number of cells
like you have to have a selection and
you need to count the number of cells so
this can also be done and it's quite
easy
i am going to show it to you
let's say the sub the
account
cells
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you're using it and
i'm going to set a
variable let's say
i'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay we will
specify the range of
the cells that we are going to
that we need to count basically
so i'm going to
set a variable as a range and
then
what we're going to do is
and we specify the range here
you can specify the range or your
selection where you count the where you
need the count of the number of cells
so a one
now how you want the output you want it
you want a message box to pop up
so you will set a message box
and
what should it give you will give you
the count of the
variable that is the variable is here is
examples okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this area
okay now
let's see it says
okay here i think i'm listed so i just
specify the
number here
and let's see so it gives you the number
of
count in this 20 okay
now let's see i want to
[Music]
six so it gives you the selection so
it's quite simple it will be very useful
in our daily task and then you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it
well i can further tweak this and to
determine the
or the count the number of rows or
columns so it's again very simple i just
need to do some changes here i have to
set the
column count
so if i want to
calculate the number of columns
just
[Music]
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message
the number of columns here
see
it gives there are five columns okay one
two three
one two three four five okay
so it gives us the number of columns
here
if i change it to
should give me
four
followers
okay similarly you can count the number
of rows here
just change it to rows
see
says six rows are there
okay
should give me number
see
so this way you can calculate the number
of
count the number of
cells number of columns number of rows
with this
the next thing i'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the
most widely used statement and one
whoever is in programming i'm very much
familiar with this function so what it
does is we specify a condition if
condition is met then the output output
should be such and such we can specify
the condition and it will check
whether that condition is there and if
it is
uh
space i mean if it is
achieved then you will have to specify
the output as well so this can be
achieved with the if statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understand the basic uh english
language so it's not very complicated
and i'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition
and if that condition is met
then the result you specify the
condition and the result
okay
so this is one thing and then you can
specify the else or else condition
where you know you specify the condition
too
then
the result should be
this
so here you are going to specify two
conditions or multiple conditions where
you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be
something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or marks
and you have to
select a result you can't do this
manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
i have it here
okay
let's show that
and
i specify as
a
statement
okay now i have to specify the
variables now i have two variables i
have a score and i have a
result and the score is an integer the
number and the result is a string pass
or fail so i specify this okay dim
score
i specify it as integer okay
and then
there's another variable that i have to
set
the result
as
string
okay
now what the score will be the score i
have to specify the range
score i'm giving it as a range i mean
it's in my
cell a1
okay
i specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
sorry
should be a duct
okay
and then i'm specifying a condition here
if
score value the variable
is greater than or equal so as i said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
english
language functions
then
the
result result is another variable that i
have said result what it should be it
should be
in codes
pass
okay
so
if this condition is met then the result
will be this okay
and now where i want to specify my
result i should give a range for that as
well so i give it in the next column or
any one
this is the basic
example
value should be
the result
okay let's see how it runs
see
says pass
change to 40.
it doesn't give me anything because i
have specified only one condition here
okay
change 75 let's see how it runs
see
so this way it's very basic condition
that you are specifying you are
specifying two variables the score and
the result
and then you are giving a value for it
and you are specifying the condition if
the score is greater than then the
result should be passed
now in the next
section uh
we will simply tweak this and use an if
then else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition
and see so here again we'll use two
variables that is the score as integer
and the result as a string and let's uh
stick to the same values
now
i'm going to specify it and if the score
is greater than 60
then
the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before
and then
i'm going to specify another condition
else
the result should be
should be
okay
and now
i have to put it to the end if statement
i have to
specify the nsu and the result will be
again in the value i mean the range will
be v1 so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is passed otherwise it is fail
okay so we are specifying two variables
again we are giving it a range and we
are specifying one condition if this
condition is met the result is passed
otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
uh the next statement that we use uh or
we're going to discuss is the
loop statement that is the for loop
statement and why we use it there are
there are situations and
tasks that you need to execute and
you need to do it several number of
times
these are basically executed
sequentially it means one after another
so the first statement or the function
is executed and the next
is taken up so
and then the next and so on so
these loop statements allow us to
execute a statement or a group of
statements multiple number of times many
number of times and this happens only
when the first task or the first
task is done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we will discuss a
simple example
of the
for loop statement
so let's see how it
works
and i'm going to set up a
loop statement okay again the i'm going
to make it as loop one
so here it is i have to specify the
variable that is dim
and i'm going to specify x as an integer
okay i'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it
executes okay for x equals to 1 to
24 okay let's see
and
i'm going to specify the range
range as
so what i'm going to do is basically i'm
going to fill the
column a
from 1 to 24 with some value 1 from 1 to
24 with the values of 1 through 24 okay
so i'm setting up a range
and
how it ends is
it gives me a
value now it excuse this and goes to the
next so i'll explain you how so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up an
integer a variable x as integer and we
are setting the value of x to be 1 to 24
so here
for one it executes the first thing is
it it takes x as 1
and it fills in
a1
and then
the next value of x will be 2
and it goes to a2 and fills the value as
2 so just let's try to execute this and
you will see
the
row column a filled with 1 through 24
see it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as x
and the number of values is going to be
24
okay so this is one basic example of a
for loop statement
uh now let's do some more uh addition to
this uh
example by
you know executing another set of for
loop
and giving the output and we'll code the
output to be the color code advance in
the column b so how we do it it's a
basic simple example that i'm going to
take and again
what i'm going to do is i will have this
values here and i'm going to color code
the
b column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see
and
what i'm going to do is i'm only going
to change the
b
and what action is going here we put up
a value now we're going to
select it
and with this selection
what i'm going to do is it should select
it
and
it should color the interior with what
the color index
okay
and the value of x
and then i'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the box to be colored and i'm going to
put it as a solid
it will kill the whole thing with the
solid
and then i just execute it see
it takes this
column b
and it's coded like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for loop statements
so there are numerous examples and
exercises that you can perform tasks we
can perform with the vba
and this can be found in detail
in our next courses advanced courses now
with that we have come to an end of this
live session on data analytics with
excel if you have any queries regarding
any of the topics covered in this
session or if you need the resources
used in this particular session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you